the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
friends became foes at the u.s juniors
and senior championships in saint louis
recharged and rested players battled it
out following the rest day larry
christensen is no longer alone at the
top with maxim delugey and dimitri
gorovich winning their games to join him
in a tie for first young phenom
christopher yu is running away with the
junior's title notching his fourth
straight win
despite impressive wins by her peers
sophie moore suzuki is proving to be the
class of the event remaining undefeated
the legends are up in the air with young
leaders asserting dominance round seven
of impeccable chess coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day seven of
the us juniors and us seniors chess
championships held at the saint louis
chess club we start day seven at the
world chess hall of fame in front of one
of the most famous chess tables in the
world uh table that was used in the 1966
cuba chess olympia while it has a lot of
details made specifically for the
comfort of the players and we actually
here at the saint louis desktop have
modeled our own tables based on this the
players are ready to showcase their
metal showcased what they're made of
let's go to the studio and start today's
action
hello everyone and welcome back to the
beautiful city of saint louis host to
three u.s championships the girls the
juniors the seniors we are in round
seven and we're ready to call all the
action from our studios here at the
saint louis chess club and scholastic
center dorset wonderful to see you it's
going wonderful excited for today
absolutely
something has snapped i don't know
what's in the water but i tell you round
six featured an enormous
number of decisive games and in two of
the sections we have runaway
leaders in one section we have a tie for
first dorsa do the honors and the girls
what's our standings
well sophie susie uh sophie morris
suzuki is running away with the event
perfect score six out of six incredible
um then we have two uh three not so
close but followers jennifer you talia
cervantes and rochelle wu
all with four points and in the juniors
uh christopher you is having an almost
perfect score five and a half out of six
wow
yes very very beautiful game yesterday
as well and he does have two people
tailing him uh with four points andrew
hong and amishra absolutely and in the
seniors we have a
three-way tie i love this yeah
uh dimitri gorivich hilary christensen
and maxine bloogey are all four points
and
it's gonna be a very fun section to
watch for
absolutely as the players get ready they
get wanded coming in
just to make sure no electronic devices
at all
you see
backwards and fronts
and uh for the three national
championships dorsa what is our format
it's kind of a classic one templar round
robin 90 minutes for the first 40 move
and then everybody gets an extra 30
minutes uh on mu 40 and they do have the
30 second increment from the first rule
right but there are no draw offers
before the 30th move and it's kind of a
traditional point system you win you get
a points you draw you get half a client
and you lose you don't really get
anything you get nothing and with six
games already six rounds already
concluded our remaining schedule well
today we're here round seven we got two
more rounds to go so tomorrow july 15
and the following day july 16th and
potential for playoff i have to say i'm
sensing a playoff in the senior section
it feels like we're heading in that
direction doesn't it and we're always as
fortunate as ever to have christian in
studio uh christian who's our gladiator
for today
it's good to see you guys always a
pleasure to be back in the studio
calling the action here at the st louis
chess club calling the games of the best
juniors as well as the best seniors and
legends of american chess but one player
that is just simply showcasing her stuff
is sophie maurice suzuki this incredible
young lady look at that line score six
out of six unbeaten she hasn't drawn a
single game she's simply dominating her
competition right now and well today she
has the chance to potentially score
another victory and complete a caruana
well you might be asking what the
caruana is that is a seven out of seven
but let's look through history and see
what players have had this type of
massive scores to start off with and if
they want the event or not and we're
going to start with vaseline topalov six
and a half out of seven at the 2005
candidates tournament in san luis
argentina and he did go on to win that
event handily well vessel into palov was
not the only one this is the man that i
was talking about fabiano caruana and we
all remember that here at the saint
louis chess club in the 2014 sing field
cup he started off with a blazing hot
seven out of seven could have easily
been eight out of eight if he would have
converted a decisive advantage against
the world champion magnus carlsen he
also won that event handily and of
course more recently we have jennifer
you eight straight wins at the 2019 u.s
women's championship she also became the
champion and won the coveted title yane
pomnyashi much more recently just last
month five and a half out of seven at
the 2022
candidates of course we know what
happened in that one he did win at that
event with one round to spare and of
course we have the young lady of the
hour that is sophie maurice suzuki six
out of six just a brilliant score and
just a brilliant display of very very
precise chess at the 2022 u.s junior
girls championship and let's take a look
at who she's playing today well this is
it the big clash that we were
anticipating a few days ago her against
the 2019 us women's champion that is
woman grand master jennifer you
unfortunately for her lost yesterday but
will be looking to bounce back today
with a crucial victory by the way this
young lady sophie mori suzuki if she
wins today she has a great chance at
locking up the championship with two
rounds to spare this is just simply
incredible just display by this young
lady but so many more stories are
developing in both the juniors as well
as the senior championships guys what do
you have your eyes on well a very
challenging pairing to be sure but
lay the table for our viewers and tell
them what we can expect in the pairings
for the girls well as we were talking
about sophie is playing one of her well
closest rivals
yes she's playing jenna for you today so
that's a matchup that we'll definitely
keep an eye on
talia another four point tied for second
is playing
uh ellen wang
and russell who another four pool four
point player is playing um prasannam
uh in the junior as
in the juniors how
who does christopher youth play well
yeah christopher he was playing um
david
i was sorry i was just thinking he had
such a nice interview yesterday right
yeah and we do have few other um four
point three and a half
versus justin wang yes and another one
uh jacobson playing hong is another uh
interesting one because three and a half
right
and christopher you there he is almost
perfect
five and a half out of six he's running
away with the tournament he'll have the
white pieces today we'll see if
david broski can slow him down and in
the seniors where we have a three-way
tie three weeks uh what
right
right i think uh
the the big one to keep an eye on
potentially could be accopian three and
a half points versus max delugey who has
four points igor nook novika three
versus uh larry christensen's four that
will be a good one another four pointer
is guravich who's playing uh kaidano
gregory kaidanov absolutely so
all of these players have been fighting
very hard for the last week or so as we
get a nice bird's eye view of the plane
haul
and i really do enjoy this playing high
everybody's all mixed up no on one side
the the seniors or anything like that
but they're all
intertwined there um but they've been
fighting very hard to slap past me what
are they fighting for it's tough money
you guys talk money exactly well for the
price the price fund for the uh woman
section well the girls section yes uh is
total of twenty thousand six hundred
dollars first place does get a nice six
thousand dollar
and in the uh junior
juniors is a
kind of a devil
uh they do have they're fighting for
total uh price fund of forty thousand
dollars first place does go home with a
nice twenty twelve thousand dollar
paycheck
exactly also they have some scholarships
right uh for the two winners
yes the sole first place winner for
girls and boys does gets ten thousand
dollars to the institution of their
choosing each and this is a very nice
scholarship that is funded by usgs and
the dwayne barber foundation
great shout out thanks to dwayne and his
wife susan barbour for all that they do
for chess and in the
seniors uh they're going to be padding
their retirement accounts uh doors
and there's a scholarship here
they are their total forex fund is a
nice 75 thousand dollars first place
does get a pretty cool 20k you're right
all right the last place even gets a
nice three thousand dollars
and uh the round is underway as we start
round seven
and shabber and igor uh we see oh karo
khan i just have my eye on the sofia
more suzuki just because it's ready
because i am thinking that jennifer you
the number one seed coming in the
tournament woman grand master
u.s women's champion
i mean if sophie
passes this test today i mean it's it's
it's all good by passing the test i mean
scoring just a draw or win and uh
we are seeing
oh and
this already tells me that sophie is not
backing down
against the slav defense one of the
things that white can do to come try to
neutralize and take a lot of the
um
i want to say
out of the opening is just to do the
slav
exchange
what has happened earlier in the
tournament
on the left that's actually not the game
of sophie suzuki
we actually have the analysis board on
the right that's uh that's the actual
game that looks like somebody else's
we got a lot of players to figure out
who's playing that's one game right but
no so you were mentioning slav yes and
she's played knight
f6 so exactly here i think a lot of
players like to use the move order e7 e6
so this is a kind of a
i want to say
foxy
very crafty move order the idea is that
you're still thinking about capturing
the pawn and if they play something i'm
just going to suggest say g3 you can
also
throw out a dutch defense with f5 knight
f6
uh type of players i used to play this
actually as black really yeah i know
those crafty players right the triangle
system right i was calling it i think
after e6 a lot of players were of course
knight c3 is one of the topical lines
and then you take on c4 and then there's
a ridiculous theory in ceiling but also
you can play as white in general e3 and
that's when uh i was usually going f5
now the reason for that is
now you committed your knight on f3
already right so you don't have ideas of
bishop d3 knight g to f3 and then e4 to
break in the center like that so
also by the fact that you put the pawn
on e3 so i i didn't really like f5
against g3n i will explain why because
the bishop is open after g3 after g3 i
usually slap the pawn on c4 give me that
and let's play some sort of uh well i
think it's more or less an improved
version of the catalog exactly
exactly with the pawn on c6 and
with the knight still on essex but that
was not jennifer's choice against knight
f3 she's played knight f6
we do have knight c3 takes so we're
going into a very standard slav
with bishop f5 and now
i got to tell you so much theory
has
has developed over the move knight e5 i
mean it's extraordinary uh how deep the
analysis has been actually
over the year
from from the start of the slav defense
e2 e3 e7 e6 bishop takes c4 seriously
for decades
this approach by white dominated but
it is 95 on the board yeah christian 95
is on the board yes yeah and this has
been become
uh incredibly topical i remember a world
championship match between
um
vladimir kramnik and vessel and topolof
uh that basically decided the world
championship
um in what was called uh i'm gonna call
it the
at least the cow mick the kalmickian
ending
they played a specific line that kept
going into it ending
and that became known as the kamikian
ending and the idea why do we play
knight e5 to capture the play first
things first clear
but also what we're really doing is this
bishop on f5 bothers me
and after for example a move like e7 e6
they like to play f3 all right and the
idea is after bishop b4 they want to
play e4 let's go for it exactly and an
entire
line of play a huge
variation goes with all of a piece
sacrifice that goes with bishop b4 after
the move knight e5 do we have a move yet
on the board yes which was 97 yep okay
in view of the idea of the fact that
theoretically f3 and e4 is working for
white they often times play knight d7
knight takes c4 as played on the port
and now there's a choice e7 e6 as well
as knight b6 knight b6 less played b6
okay i mean these ladies are just going
right down
exactly they're going right down the
primrose path of theory the dictates of
theory now after knight e5
again from white's point of view white
would love to have f3 e4
followed by a5 included
and because white wants a5 black goes
and it does a little bit of wish
blocking okay stops her with a7 a5 often
times in the slav defense the b4 square
is critical
uh critical that black has control over
the b4 square either with a bishop or
even sometimes with a knight this is a
this is it's great to see the ladies
coming out and playing the theory right
right i was just wondering because i
mean they are similar in asia and they
kind of i feel like guru playing each
other do we have any uh
games of the previous games
that would be nice but even if just like
what was the like have they been down
this path before
is that something that they both
expected from each other wonderful that
you should ask such questions because i
am telling you christian has got it all
forget it
he does not go to sleep
before he has a very very clear idea
wrong absolutely wrong am i
unfortunately yes but one of the very
nice games uh in this line is actually
the one that probably you are going to
mention as well uh yasser the big clash
between fabiano caruana and dingley ren
dingley ran with white pieces and
fabiano caruana with the black pieces
from the candidates in 2020 and we know
what happened in that one ding was
having a very bad event and yet he
managed to win and instill fear in his
opponent's heart let's see how that
happened f3 bishop to b4 this was the
uh point that you are making after e4
for example you can go bishop to ac4
followed by knight takes c4 and the
theory just expands at that point
exactly it does seem like it um tends to
be uh an equal position after that if
both parties know their theoretical
knowledge now at the same time king 2f2
became a big big uh move in this
position and let's take a look
knight to c4 castle king to f2 and now
e5 this was the big uh novelty that
fabiano caruana essayed in that game he
by the way blitzed out a few more moves
but unfortunately for him was unable to
find the right move in the decisive
moment and in fact that gave the
advantage to digging iran which went on
to convert a brilliant game i have to
say ding was not having good results up
to that point but this one was just
simply a brilliant game by the chinese
player so just to answer your question
no they haven't i or at least i don't
know whether they have played this
specific variation uh the players that
we have but as a model game this one is
definitely one of them uh but we have a7
a5 instead of e7 e6 yes one of the
dictates of theory suggests that sophie
should do after a5 the same thing f3 f3
yeah yeah it's it's all about the center
right now it's all about trying to block
and um make it uncomfortable for the
bitchporn f5 because you know that black
is going to try to develop well either
with e6 or g6 and both of those moves
are going to uh take away one of the
important squares from the bishop right
especially if you play e6 this bishop
will not be able to return back home so
it will have to find the home of its own
on this diagonal and then you have a lot
of things and a lot of resources coming
down that path for example if you go e6
i can continue with e4 and now i have a
feeling i can even start thinking about
the moves such as h4 and try to put even
more pressure on the bishpawn g6 at the
same time i also have uh pretty much at
any point whenever i want this capture
on g6 and taking away the two bishops so
that's one option f3 is one of them g3
is a move as well but f3 is on the board
right now it seems like these ladies
definitely know what they're doing now
e6 is not the only movie it does feel
like knight fd7 in fact is the main line
right now and i'm 100 sure if we already
have that on the board i don't think we
do but knight fd7 should probably come
shortly because
no
bishop to d7
no this cannot i don't think this is
right maybe we can see the camera bishop
d7 has never been played and it makes no
sense bishop to d7 so
my guess right now until we get the
camera fit is that we're going to see
actually knight f to d7 this is probably
just a relay um situation that we have
with leeches and knight of d7 knight xd7
e4 is also an option but i think knight
fd7 um capturing that knight makes the
most sense and now black can pretty much
take with anything queen d7 which
doesn't make a lot of
sense at least to my eyes because of oh
we do have we have bishops
on the live board is it what is that a
joke
that looks like a joke move i'm not
gonna lie because
that really does look like a relay error
but i am seeing it with my own two eyes
uh questions
make that four eyes we got four eyes
over here on the board
bishop
it's a novelty by the way um i mean it
looks like a bathroom and it's probably
the worst novelty i've seen ever in my
life right
right now the computer is saying plus
1.8
right what is bishop that's a decisive
advantage already after bishop white
wants to play e4 or that bishop d7
doesn't stop it doesn't interfere i'm
shocked i'm in shock right now
what is this move i just simply go e4
what is the bishop doing on d7
maybe c even c5 what am i
nothing
nothing
i'll take it
um yeah that's a confusing one we're
gonna leave that just for a moment
because could we pan out a little bit
and maybe see jennifer's face i'm really
curious whether she's
e4 is on the board okay
you know yes we were talking she's
playing so fast what's happening
we were talking in order to win a
tournament you need you know the
universe and luck and everything
are there harmonic convergences
right everything has to come together
and uh it's all working for sophie yeah
the only thing that i can think of is
that she did what i did uh in my worst
moment in chess in my chest career that
is played the second move of my
calculation right or my preparation
knight d7 and then knight takes e7
bishop takes d7 i'm sure that was what
her intention was and
maybe even horrified she touched her
bishop first that yeah because this
makes no sense to develop your bishop
from c8 to f5
voluntarily bring it back and give your
opponent the complete command of the
center
this this is this is incredible and
an opening gone seriously wrong and you
were saying dorset and i completely
agree it's like when it rains it pours
everything
has gone so very very well for sophia
including the start of this round seven
against a crucial rival jennifer you
wow
uh shocking i think i think i need to
take a break from
this game yes pick anything else i
wanted to take us to the game of
rochelle
uh versus gracie because
it's very nice to see the king's indian
i know that
the modern chess has really frowned upon
the fact that black voluntarily gives
white a very commanding imposing uh
central pawns
on yeah on e4 d4 and c4 but i have to
tell you that i love to play the black
side of the king city quite a lot of it
too and i've had great results me too i
love the fact that mike king is super
well defended behind this fortress uh
and i liked uh not playing those benoni
positions that we've been seeing i like
playing the king's indian
variations now h2h3
while it has a a a very long
old pedigree the reality is
it was never really popular but modern
day players most specifically
lavon aronian has made this move popular
and why do you play h2h3 because against
the traditional e5 which is what you're
trying to do in a king's indian and now
that you've lured the pawn to a d5 this
is an ideal square for the knight
so knight d7
g4
knight c5 queen c2 a5 and i just wanted
to stop here at a5 and explain what's
going on
so
first of all yes in the kings indeed
c4 because
so in the king's indian after the move
d7 d5 you as black
want to play the move f7 f5
so
likely your knight is going to move your
knight is going to retreat
or your knight is going to go to h5
and from white's point of view
white is sitting there saying i see that
that's coming
i'm going to try to set up a a make a
setup
where
you're playing f7f5 is actually bad for
your position
so what rochelle did is after 97 she
played the move g4
and in her mind she's already
seeing the move f7 f5 come then what she
wants to do is play g takes f5 and after
you recapture d takes the the g file
will be open and since black's king has
already declared its its home king g8
the move rook g1 will give her a
ready-made attack i see that the uh
g-file that kind of makes me think
what's gonna happen to white's king
exactly white's king is most likely
going to go queenside all right so
after the move uh g4 gracie changes her
plan she starts to say think uh oh
f7 f5 is going to have a boomerang
effect all i'm going to do is help my
opponent
attack my king what i'm going to do
is attack in the center
knight c5 attacks the pawn on e4 queen
to c2
oh come on you can do it yes yes
glory queen c2 defends the pawn on e4
and by the way
i'm now ready to play the move b2b4
drive this knight back
wasted to waste of time for blah for
black a7 a5 i do approve of this move me
too i like this move a lot now
just what you said
where is white's
king going to go you've got to make room
for the king and bishop to g5 was her
choice rochelle's thinking i'm going to
castle uh queenside i get my bishop out
of the way and in the meanwhile i'm
pinning this knight making it a little
bit awkward c7 c6 on the board and i'm
expecting castles although
they're
we're still in theory
and there are other choices that white
has made
but i like the move castles
and
to sit there and say
these are the types of battles i really
really love dorset and chess i like it
when one side is castled on the queen
side and one side is castled on the king
side
and you know you come out you come at me
with everything you got i'll come right
back
you know with everything i've got and
you're looking for a bloodbath yes i'm
looking for a clash
a clash of styles and
when we have the kings on opposite
flanks that's those are the kinds of
games i love christian your your
reflection on what i've said and
what's your favorite type of opening
battle
um well i mean i'm a grunfeld player so
i definitely enjoy uh theoretical
battles now at the same time as a
grunfeld player i generally feel quite
exposed because uh we know from an
objective point of view if you know all
your theory the groomfeld is extremely
extremely sound now the problem is
you're kind of a sitting duck whenever
you play the grunfeld because white and
most players with the white pieces this
is how uh they play against the
groomfire they don't have one specific
line that they repeat over and over they
just simply deviate and go all over the
place because it's simple for them to
dictate where the game goes and actually
just focus on one particular variation
and try to learn that before maybe one
or two days before uh the game right or
before the tournament they come to a
tournament with a specific approach
against the groomfield so unfortunately
for me i've been uh let's say subject to
uh a great preparation from uh my
opponents with the black pieces
especially now let's take a look at this
game guys because this one is also
extremely important and i have to say
christopher yu has just been impressing
me in this tournament just like sophie
has they're both playing very good chess
not only that but they have control out
of the opening almost every single game
it feels like they're not falling behind
out of the opening and this just goes to
show how
in shape they are coming into this event
and this is what i'm seeing from
christopher in this game
as well so we see the open
lopez and then after knight to d2 the
main line used to be queen to d7
nowadays bishop to g4 became more
topical and at this point
knight takes e4 is the main line knight
64 used to be the main line at least
until very recently when uh they managed
to find some ideas which will be shown
in the game that's happening right now
take only for take only for queen to d5
and this is why i was a bit puzzled and
actually when i saw this position i
thought that christopher is most likely
just going to try to go for a draw but i
don't think we're seeing that right now
queen d5 and after queen d5 take take on
f3 this is considered to be more or less
okay for black if they know how to
arrange their pc still white maintains a
little bit of an edge but not much um in
this end game now christopher decided to
go a completely different route and he
played the move h3 this is a novel
approach only four games have played in
this particular position and this is why
after knight xd2 take on g4 knight takes
f1 it's actually an exchange sacrifice a
very early exchange sacrifice knight to
a5 almost forced because you have to do
something with this knight you know
you're going to lose the pawn on d5
there's no way to defend it you cannot
go d4 for example and just simply give
white such a terrible and such a
dangerous center of pawns so that's why
you go knight to a5 bishop takes d5 c6
bishop to e4 this is the current
position that we have on the board one
hour and 31 minutes for christopher one
hour and 24 minutes for david brosky
they're still following a very topical
game that is a game between chef chenko
kirill and vidit queen takes the one
rook takes the one
it's all about this end game how do we
assess this end game rook to d8 either
rook to d8 rook a28 or rook f to d8 and
then of course white is not going to
exchange the rooks we know that this is
not something that white should do they
should sidestep with a move rook to a1
and it's all about once again who
analyzed this end game better because
it's not easy at the beginning of the
end game the computer is saying zero
zero zero if you let it think for a
little bit and if you uh guide him uh
towards uh well a more clear picture
well unfortunately it does seem to give
white a slight edge so this is i'm very
curious as to what christopher has
prepared after a move such as rook has
to say just natural moves what is the
plan right now g3 kg2
rook to h1 is one of them knight to d4
to jump with this knight to f5 is
another one of them i'm looking at the
position and from a practical
perspective it definitely looks like a
two-game result in this one so uh i'm
very very curious once again to see what
what christopher is going to come up
with and we see knight to c4 in fact not
queen takes the one first so
that that tells me that bishop to c1 is
no longer a possibility right because of
queen takes d1 so
it changes the character of the position
quite a lot this last move knight to c4
without exchanging the queens and
i think well we're going to have to wait
and see it seems like christopher is
taking his first thing he's not
recognizing this move he's wondering
wait wait a minute you were supposed to
take on d1 first right what's happening
after knight to c4 and in fact it does
seem like white right now has a slight
edge after just the simple queen tuitu
exactly
using the
majority again two bishops or bishop and
pawn
for the rook but the question is can i
utilize that majority with what you were
saying christian knight to d4 and attack
the c6 pawn and maybe jump to f5 but
queenie too leaving the queens on the
board
that seems like uh a very nice uh choice
by
by christopher i don't think knight c4
was a precise move it's a tempting move
because you will be gaining the two
bishops so you will be gaining one of
the bishops from white but then you're
going to be left in the position with
opposite colored bishops and we know the
most important factor of assessment in
opposite color bishop positions is who
has the initiative exactly and it is
white who has the initiative and doesn't
have an opponent on the light squares
for the very nicely centralized bishop
on e4 and i'm going to be able to use
all sorts of mechanisms to uh create
dangers around your king for example
after queen to e2 then i can see a g3
king g2 h1 transfer of the rook to the h
file i'm seeing this as a very dangerous
situation for black what do you guys
think agreed i just simply agreed the
bishops of opposite color
suggest to me that uh the player who has
the initiative will will enjoy the
unopposed bishop and i like what you
just said too g3 king g2
bring your rook to h1 um you've got a
lot more freedom in the position than
this black by the way this pawn on c6 is
also a really weak pawn you can see that
after for example knight takes e3 checks
why did you play knight c4 if not to
take the bishop queen ticks now
you know you you you can't play c5 and
just give back the exchange you're
likely going to have to play a move like
rook c8 and then after g3
king g2
rook will slide over
and this knight
is looking to pack a punch oh yeah it
will land either on c6 or f5
and i think christopher and the problem
is that when you go g6 and try to close
that diagonal i'm going to get the queen
to h6
and get even closer to your king and
potentially create more amazing threats
when you try to it doesn't help you the
g6 doesn't actually help you queen h6
and rook eight
rook to h1 uh one of the things that
happens and uh
when you're winning tournament when
you're winning a tournament per me and
everything is flowing your way i mean
it's just like you you you get your
preparation on the board
like it's so hard to get preparation of
the board it's like your opponent is
preparing to avoid your preparation
so you're always constantly playing this
hide-and-seek game and sometimes you
just never even get your preparation
like i've seen
fabiano get in some remarkable
preparation and i think to myself how
fortunate he is and then we asked him
about and he said oh i i prepared it two
years ago for somebody else
and then mvl fell into it and it's like
oh that's what happened so it's like
christopher has some opening ideas but
he's getting
uh
he's he's having an enormous success and
he's getting his ideas on uh the board i
this this exchange sacrifice i'm
unfamiliar with but it looks good yes
sir what you're telling me is that if
guys like fabiano carawana can remember
theory uh all the way up to two years
and i cannot remember theory up to two
days i know is that like how do these
players do this exactly i i
i think they're super human i really
they're alien they're they're the aliens
live among us a lot of people keep
asking me like do these top players have
photographic memory and i'm like
i mean they have definitely really good
memory but photographic memory to be
such a such a nice
tool to have in high level chess it
would be phenomenal and i i spoke
to many many players about this and what
is it that the great players have in
common
and uh one
explanation was given to me by ben
larson they have strong stomachs well
and i went what he says well they travel
the world
and they're having all of these diets
from all over you've got to have a
strong stomach to be able to withstand
all of these diets and i said what else
a great memory a great memory i don't
necessarily say a photographic memory
but they remember dates and places and
who their opponents was and yes you know
i lost to christian
in that simultaneous it's like what
simultaneous
some of their recall is just astounding
like they'll tell you stories
uh that just thrill and amaze you i'll
tell you one very very very quick one
right
so uh miguel neidor the great miguel
nadar
had just played his second
tournament game against alexander
alekhine and they had played one draw
earlier in
mar del plata another draw later in
buenos aires so two draws
and miguel had taken alec
out for dinner
and festivities festivities festivities
they ended up really uh getting drunk
essentially yeah
and miguel neidorf toasted alekhine and
said
and here's a toast to you uh alexander
alekhine world chess champion
with whom i have
two draws and a win
so i lead two to one
and alekhine said
no i may be drunk
but today we had our second draw and it
is his two draws and he says
well do you remember that you came to
poland seven years ago and you gave a
simultaneous oh
at the warsaw chess club
and alekhine's thinking thinking
and he goes but we didn't play
and miguel says that's right because
we we we tricked you we had a
simultaneous for 40 players but only 20
showed up
10 you played and saw and we proposed to
you that you played 10 blindfold games
oh
and i was one of the blindfold games
and alekhine goes
did you give me a sicilian with rook c8
takes c3 and rook c3 takes a3
and he goes yes that was me
he says oh but we didn't meet each other
i don't remember you
so najdorf who's completely drunk this
is like seven years ago
is telling alekhine about a simultaneous
game he played which she was also
blindfolded which he was blindfolded and
he remembered the game and i mean oh boy
yeah exactly like the memories of these
players
are crazy are like really really really
crazy good and i remember um losing a
number of bets to gary kasparov about
memory and he and he remembered games
against players that he had no business
knowing and he just studied a lot magnus
carlson he's another guy with an
extraordinary
memory a question hypothesized if he has
a photographic memory i don't think he's
ever confirmed or denied it right
i think he's very sharp uh some so
what what do these great players have in
in common christian and do you have
examples of extraordinary feats of
memory well i i worked quite extensively
with fabiano caruana and i was astounded
by his memory i think what he does at
least himself is uh he looks at chess
every single day and he doesn't look at
chess for just a couple of hours he
usually goes for like four or five hours
every single day no exceptions almost
even probably when he's on vacation so
um he just repeats his lines all the
times he doesn't go
a week without him looking at his
repertoire so when you do that even if
you get to play your repertoire or one
of your novelties that you looked at
first initially two years ago you've
repeated it countless of times uh
throughout those two years so i think
this is what separates this professional
2800 2750 players that just simply live
and breathe chest this is the big
differentiator a guy like magnus carson
i don't know him personally i've never
worked with him uh but i can tell you
that much he's a workhorse as well we
have this perception that no he likes to
do other things as well sure he does but
he's also spending a lot of time and by
the way his innate abilities just like
his memory for example are just um off
the charts so i mean this players in
general i think this is how
they use it if your name is not magnus
carson you're probably just going to
look at your openings at your repertoire
every single week and you're going to
look at chess every single day for four
or five hours right
um wow let's uh return our attention to
chess for just a moment i've been going
through some of the senior uh games by
the way do you have uh
how would you on a scale of one to ten
describe your own memory well
would you give yourself a five right now
i'm professional students starting med
school so i need a good memory for that
exactly but chess wise i remember i had
this
part i've had like i believe in power of
preparation and
um
this was this one game that was in 2014
durable in south africa right after the
rest i didn't really do much on the rest
day because i really wanted to win and
it was i wanted to play something a
little different against dragon and i
was playing somebody who was a little
lower rated but it was
it was you know i was playing for the
title so i still wanted to do my best so
i remember i was susie was sophie was
saying yesterday having the actual
chessboard i had that and i was going
through my lines in dragon and i had it
all memorized and
um up until i moved 25-27
she just she played the whole thing
right up until and then she played like
um so we just got to it
we got to an end game that i also had
prepared
and um she just played something
different there and i just want a bishop
and she resigned
so the only move i actually had to think
about without remembering was pushing my
pawn to trap her bishop right
that was it that was almost with 30 and
yeah she was arching 30.
that was i think that was one of the
very few games that i had like the whole
game prepared and all i had to do was
like
make one move and win right out of my
prep but right i remember i once had i
was playing in brazil um
in sao paulo brazil against henrikh
mkhitaryan and it's one of those things
i'm leading the match i have a point
lead one game remaining i need to draw
with black and i clinch the match
so one of the things i was very lucky
with in henrique is he was stubborn nice
he absolutely absolutely absolutely
believed in his uh preparation and his
opening analysis and so i could prepare
very deeply and i prepared
a begoliubov
bogo indian we call it a
golia buff indian
and i prepared it like the night before
just by myself this wasn't computers or
anything like that no no no i just knew
he was going to play this way and i
could lead the game right into an ending
which it went right into my preparation
and i made a very comfortable draw to
secure the match to secure match victory
and sometimes just needing a draw with
black knowing how to draw with black is
also a great part of being a
professional player and i remember that
that was probably one of my single best
preparations it was just like
everything just flowed and he went right
into the last nice and i remembered it
very well too
just looking uh vladimir kopien versus
max max delugey now max delugey always
plays this his entire life i mean you
talk about yourself christian as a
grunfeld player max delugey is always in
his entire career plate this line is
black against one e4 and he's played the
queen's gambit accepted as black against
one d4 so uh for vladimir talking about
star stubborn players he could really
really prepare because he knows
that max has played this line of uh this
variation
this whole lot h6 queen e5 and i won't
bother you to bore you with all the
details but just to let you know all of
this has been played yep literally
hundreds of games oh yeah a lot of fun a
lot of a lot of games and probably
even the two players
have uh uh played this position b2b4
that's a a nice little tricky move don't
forget
that there's a discover check uh
that white is banking on to try to take
advantage of this rook
that's on d8 b4 b5
and uh kind of waiting here for the
for the
the move to be played but again i i want
to assure that this is all
standard
opening theory uh also i wanted to look
at the well actually before
is not as well known i think bishop to
e4 was in fact uh the main move in the
position and it was recently played in a
big game between magnus carlsen and
timor rajab really 2021 yes there was
actually not as many games in this
position before only one game and the
players are actually following that game
which is almost for sure a
correspondence game bishop to e4 was the
main move bishop to d7 and now knight to
b5 immediately trying to take advantage
of these weaknesses around black cam now
rook ab8 was the move proposed by magnus
carlsen and it does seem like it's the
best one and it potentially also
finishes the line because it does seem
like the game generally tends to
dissolve into an equal position after
this move very nice move a preparatory
move rook to be defending the pawn on b7
taking advantage of the fact that knight
to d6 is not going to come with as much
oomph right in the position so what we
have is b4 very interesting uh strategy
and up to this point maxim lugi had one
hour and 35 minutes right so he
definitely knew what's happening in the
position and i'm pretty sure he knew
about that game between magnus and timo
rajabov b4 bishop to d7
after quite a significant thing b5 this
is the position that we have right now
i'm really liking what i'm seeing from
white coming up with more or less a
novel idea again this is a game from
2002
2300 versus 2300 no grand master chess
or anything of that nature but
asking some serious questions where are
you going to put the knight if you go
knight to d4 well i'm going to go a4
keep taking as much space as possible
and the knight on d4 we know knights
love outposts unfortunately the knight
on d4 doesn't have any outposts and
bishop to e4 is coming with uh
devastating consequences attack on the
knight as well as attack on the bishop
the pawn on b7 so
nightway 5 seems to be the computer's
choice and also the best move in the
position but it's not easy to get the
knight all the way to a5 right on the
side we know that's not generally how we
think about chess we see the knights on
the side we understand that they're dim
nevertheless now that you committed this
pawn all the way to b5 this square c4 is
what i'm going to target not only that
but the knight on a5 nicely protects the
b7 pawn that is one of your main
weaknesses so if you look at the
position start comparing your options
you get to the conclusion that probably
knight to a5
is the right approach lugi is thinking
right now and by the way after knight to
a5 the game continue i can continue i
can go bishop to f1 followed by king to
b2 i really like what he did by just
simply taking up more space on the queen
side i like jacobian's chances this one
quite an interesting game developing
absolutely and then another game between
our tournament leaders igor novikov is
larry a has white against larry
christianson he's just played the move
a2 a3 prepping the minority attack uh
with b2 b4 in a rather standard looking
queens gambit decline position uh larry
is actually facing a very uh important
moment
should he play the move c7 c5 now
and counter attack in the center he's
got his development
so he's ready to play c7 c5 pardon me
rook c8 and support c5 if you don't play
it now white is going to get b2b4 and
you won't play it ever now there are
times that you simply want to play c6
and play the move bishop g4 and not
necessarily
change the pawn structure so a critical
moment going on between igor and larry
and finally think of pawn c5 there has
been some developments that sophie
versus jennifer ew's game okay i'll go
there just a second i'll finish this as
larry pardon me that was larry
christensen and in the other tournament
co-leader
was dimitri gervais and that position's
kind of blown up uh against gregory
kaidanov this was a catalan
slav slash catalan
game a4c5 takes bishop e4
and
it's a double-edged but uh still
theoretical theoretical battle being
waged between dmitry gurvich and gregory
karidanov sorry uh let's go to uh what
you were saying heyman you mentioned
ponzi favren was like oh there has been
a pawn c5 happening here and which game
is uh sophie versus jennifer okay yeah i
think after bishop d7 the move bishop d7
that jennifer played i think
i needed a little something else to look
at okay but it seems like she had some
sort of preparation
no no no she has absolutely nothing
let's sing it out yeah sick there's
absolutely no preparation well then why
would she puts it up
i i don't actually
we're going to ask her that if we're
going to get her in the studio i can
guarantee you that this is not
preparation because
the engine eval and the position if you
look at it
it's not good and not after the move
that white played queen to b3 that was
actually a mistake but right a much
better alternative would have been try
to compare once again
how is this position looking compared to
uh the position without the knights on
e5 and f6
black would have played the main line
knight fd7 right and then take back with
the bishop there's a huge difference
it just seems like your pieces black
species are stepping on each other's
feet and especially after this move rook
to c8 your plan is pretty obvious
you're not hiding anything in the
position you want to play the move c5
and liberate your pieces now an easy way
to stop that and target the bishop
before at the same time take advantage
of the fact
that you have these two pieces still
left on the board knight on e5 and the
knight on f6 i can just simply drop back
with the knight to d3 this would have
created serious trouble for black
because what do you do next do you take
on c3 and give me the bishop pair and
then never play c5 ever in your life
absolutely not probably c5
doesn't work anymore i have more
attackers than you have defenders it's
easy to see that do you go bishop to e7
sure you can go bishop to e7 but then i
go queen to b3 once again c5 is not
happening anytime soon it's a completely
different position than what we right
now have on the board after the move c5
jennifer finally got her moving
her breaking c5 which was
shouldn't have been allowed and it could
have easily been prevented with a simple
move such as knight to d3
after queen to b3 c5 rook d1 it does
seem like black slowly slowly it's
getting her pieces out into play still
white has more control uh white is still
better yeah exactly uh
but i i think that this was just a a
slip uh like a fold by jennifer
with her preparation she mixed uh her
lines up i agree if you take the knight
on e5
off the board just off the board and you
take the knight on f6 away
uh
black's play becomes a lot easier this
knight is kind of reaching into the
position so to speak whereas this knight
on f6 is actually well
kind of passive
i'll leave it at that but the inclusion
by having those both those nights on the
board really really nice for sophie
and um just a quick question for you the
christian christian because i would i'm
i was agreeing with you
my original thought was play knight d3
stop the move c5 but i stopped myself
because of knight c4 and i went oh no
my bishop on
c1 yeah yeah and then i have to go back
and then that's the problem then
then uh but then i can target it with
queen to b3 right again example or
knight to c5
and yeah and the this is where i started
thinking maybe something after b5 yeah
lazy man's chest and i said they say
well wait a minute i want something
cleaner and i was looking for something
else but how about knight c5 uh instead
of instead of between v3 just changing
the character or the position but you're
bishop on d7 oh man if you have to take
on c5 and good light exchange going with
the bishop on d7
that's not coming to life anytime soon
also the knight on c4 is kind of stuck
because where do you put the knight on
c4 exactly i have to i was trying to
follow it up with this move b7b5 and
it's not the only move uh guys right i
can also just simply go b3
that's the simple way out knight d6 is
not an option because i go e5 right so
you have to go back to b6 and once again
my question is very important
i don't like my position how do you play
c5 exactly
knight d3 would have really put the
kibosh on jennifer's break she did
manage however
to play the move queen c7 and this is
where
uh
christian is feeling like jennifer's
fighting her way getting uh a breath of
fresh air in the position yeah sure
it i mean it still strikes me as like
white's for choice right i i will take
the two bishops you can't take with the
queen and walk into a discovery so
i presume you're going to recapture with
the knight and now i can think about
knight b5
it's better better for one definitely
better but not necessarily you're maybe
not the 2.5 that the engine not even
close not even close yeah it was after
knight to d3 close to two-point uh
advantage right right now after queen's
c7 0.5
okay so it's a big difference huge
difference
a lot let's just jump to alice lee for a
moment because alex i'm telling you
yesterday yeah but she came back from
the dead talia cervantes
had her you know
up
dead dead to rights and let's see if she
can you know
get her own little win streak going
again we're seeing another slav this
time with queen c2
and
again typical of the slav
playing bishop f5 and you don't
voluntarily retreat you play moves like
e7 e6
thereafter okay so now the bishop is
well everything's going good
b5 pause
my spidey sense is tingling i've
definitely
what are you looking at where um
maybe
maybe there were some issues after b4
and it could happen that bishop e4
might hurt but okay
zoe did not capture she she sensed that
something was wrong but i was looking at
the pawn i had to uh b4 bishop e4 bishop
by the way this is one of the
key
strategies that black employs whenever
you've got a fianchetto bishop
if i can put a bishop in the way of that
diagonal like bishop e4 neutralizing the
bishop on g2 so alice is looking good
okay
no i was about to say that zoe
really helped alice
a lot
this trade on b6
is really
favorable for black why
because the rook on ca rook on a8
is developed it hasn't moved but it's
already playing a key role in the game
by being on the half open file so that
trade benefited
alice a lot and after queen d5 well i
like
black's position i understand exactly
what she's doing this bishop on d2 is a
little bit passive so that after c5 it's
not it doesn't have a real good
you know it's one thing of the bishops
on c3
but it's on d2
next
this queen and bishop are doing very
well and most importantly uh uh
i see a
a pussycat
look at that
and
she's in fifth place having come back
again she got that victory yesterday
against talia and if she could put
together back-to-back victories she
might
might be a factor in the podium we'll se
in the race of the podium but queen d5
she's doing great at the moment
blacklist pushes c5
or c5 c4
cool yeah very nice grip on the light
squares if she can get those moves in so
nice and what's happening uh christian
in the junior contest we left
christopher
you some time ago
uh has he
improved his position um christopher you
let's see what happened in this one i
was actually looking at the seniors oh
sure so we will get to that in just a
second please queen to d7 was played
which was in fact the best move
according to the engine bishop to f5
queen to d5 and now bishop to f4 this is
the current position that we have on the
board now
i see a recommendation and i'm trying to
understand yes now i understand why
knight takes b2
it's on tap it's a possibility you
cannot take back because of going to c4
exactly queen to c4 queen to e2 and the
bishop f4 is hanging
did christopher just missed
this move knight takes b2 does he have
something else i'm looking at
e6 perhaps trying to gain uh some sort
of play on this side but then again i go
here you take and then i take with the
rook bishop to e6 and we get some sort
of madness ensuing right now on the
board because sure you did get your
exchange back right but i get to trade
the queens off you have a lot of
weaknesses on the king side specifically
this pawn on c3 already attacked by the
bishop on f6
your majority on the king's side it's
not as compelling is not as aggressive
as
the potential that i have on the queen
side with my majority and this weakness
on c3 as black so
bishop to f4 might have been
a misstep by young christopher yu and
this could create a shake-up at the top
if david proxy actually manages to win
with the black pieces
this is no wonder this would be a
shocker beating a wonder liang and uh he
had a really bad start
he's looking at david
and for sure i mean
he played the move queen d5
looking for these types of tactical
opportunities the move bishop f4
looks not only queen d5 but queen to d7
first inviting this temple with bishop
to f5 and then get the queen to d5 if
you're making these two moves back to
back you know what you're looking for
and that is all this type of taking
advantage of the fact that the king is
on f1 with the move knight takes b2 he's
definitely looking at that one we're
going to have to wait and see whether
he's going to play it or or not and how
will christopher respond to that but
this is such a critical game for the
current standings in the junior section
we see christopher you well he's
creating some separation at the top five
and a half points four points for abi
manu and andrew hung and then we see
david brosky he's just hitting up right
now he won yesterday with black pieces
against a wonder that was a critical
victory for him well his uh
check it out
he took it right knight takes me too she
shook his head for a second and they
raised me too a very
interested
andrew hung there saying hmm you know
that's nice
that's nice christopher missed it look
at him
he's puzzled brandon jacobson and andrew
hung are
locked together in a very oh he's
shaking his head struggle and
they they want to see somebody stop the
christopher
you express
so i and knight takes me too what an
opportunity he did it big opportunity
and uh this will be a shake up at the
top if brotzky manages to win with the
black pieces
still still a long way yeah still a long
way e6 is is a big fighting move right
now and bishop to f6 has to be the right
continuation after that it's going to be
a long battle between
these two players
and he noted that at the beginning of
the show actually in the first few
rounds david almost never goes away too
far
from his be he gets not from the board
he doesn't leave
yeah uh this is something we're talking
about during the other case he comes
back the candidates
tournament does you know like the minor
pieces left alone they're like nice
targets and i was telling you about the
loose pieces loose pieces drop off yes
yes we had a whole um
exactly
um
i have been very very very critical uh
of carissa unfairly but i have been i of
course i admire her courage and the fact
that she's playing in the juniors she
could be a champion of the girl section
i mean she would have been the
overwhelming favorite but she took on
the courageous challenge of going into
the juniors good for her
except for the way she's played
essentially the way she's played is
she's avoided theoretical battles she's
played like and the hippopotamus and and
other things and secondly her time
management has been terrible
so she's played bad openings and she's
consumed a lot of time playing those bad
openings
that's not a formula for success so
today what does she do
against bellagi she plays a very sharp
scotch
theoretical battle
and as far as i can tell she's actually
played pretty you're right
quickly and guess what
she has a very decent position yeah this
is great i mean uh she's just played the
move b2b
she did start taking uh quite a lot uh
from like the two three moves ago so
she's been spending like the last few
months yeah and these are difficult
moves uh you have to
play with great precision when gary
kasparov
was rejuvenating the scotch with a whole
uh
an amazing array of new ideas
he also played it very
slowly because he was weighing all of
these variations that he had been
creating but you can see what white has
in mind carissa would love simply love
to play the moves bishop b2 bishop g2
and castles at the end of which she
would have
great command of the center thanks to
the pawns on e5
thanks to the double pawns on the c file
this bishop on c8 is saying
excuse me
what is my motivation what am i doing
what's my role and also
again if she could just play bishop
bishop and castles
her follow-up would be knight to e4 and
a ready-made attack
on the king side so balaji has us to
be
equally
very very consequent
in his next series of moves and uh
theoretical battles i love them
i just have to say and not in this
specific move order but the idea of um
let's say i want to play spawn g6 now
okay not i don't think that's a really
good idea but let's say we point knight
to e4 okay
i had like similar positions about they
were like oh she dropped the pawn queen
takes e5 and then
knight f6 bye bye queen
i've had a lot of fun with those yeah
with 94 96 and 96. yeah well those those
traps
exist
all
all over in the scotch defense it's just
amazing to me
uh how many um tactical tricks can occur
out of such an innocent
uh looking position now again i don't
think g6 g6 is like you say it's
inviting knight e4 i think a lot is
based on d5
as well as a4 remember what we're just
saying about alice's alice lee's
position developing the rook by playing
a5 a4 opening up the a file you might
see something for example like this
as a kind of a line
or just second after a4 you might be see
something like would you like to trade
off these rooks
and again white is looking to position
his her bishop on the open diagonal so
great carissa is taking a different
she's played a completely different way
today
her play so far in the tournament has
been poor in terms of results
but what has really happened is she's
she's played poor openings and spent a
lot of time
i think here today she's much better
theoretically prepared and well we wish
her well where would you like to take
his dorsal um
i have some ideas about
just just because we really need to look
at this game is so consequential for the
standings in the senior section which is
highly disputed right now three players
at the top with four points right but
one of them uh one player with three and
a half points that is chasing is
vladimir akopian who is playing one of
the leaders maxim dlugian we've seen
this position and we said knight to d4
and actually showed you how knight d4 is
not necessarily the best move in the
position because this knight gets
stranded doesn't have an outpost a
secure outpost in the center and i said
knight to a5 is not going to be once
again from a practical perspective an
easy move to make just because as humans
we don't like putting the knight on the
side now he played the move knight to d4
actually after a long thing knight to d4
and this is a big mistake according to
the engines right now white is very
close to having building up at least a
decisive advantage a4 was played
immediately the best movie in the
position and for example if you try to
continue with the natural
a6 right right you've been focusing your
attention on this uh expansion of
white's pawn especially this spear on b5
the problem is you don't have time to go
e6 bishop to e4 that's a double attack
attacking the knight without an outpost
on d4 as well as the pawn on b7 you can
defend both with the bishop on c8 but
after b6 you start looking at this
position and it looks like one of those
wrestling matches in which one player is
pinned down to the ground and is never
coming back up right because i'm going
to actually go a5
solidify uh the position on the queen
side then get the knight to c5 you're
completely tied down as black you're
completely lost at this point engine is
saying plus 3.4 from a practical
perspective is pretty much over at this
point so
a4 a6 not a good move but what does
black have to do well the problem is if
you go rook to c8 which by the way once
again very practical choice and very
human move after king to b2 this only
improves my position because now you
don't have a square for the bishop to go
to c8 defend the pawn on b7 this threat
bishop to e4 big big threat in the
position is reinforced also by moving
the rook from the a file a6 is not as
potent anymore because a6 8 xb5 doesn't
open up the a file for the rook so rook
to a to c8 an easy move to make as black
not as good bishop to e8 seems to be the
only move that maintains the balance in
the position some sort of a balance
still white is clearly better knight to
e4 and now a6 but then c3 knight to f5
kick the knight away then solidify uh
this pawn complex on the queen side
i get it you have some checks you can
take take rook to a one but it doesn't
give you much right and in fact it
leaves your eighth rank unattended and
after bishop to b1 you don't have any
way to continue your attack on the queen
side my king is perfectly safe and
you're starting to have huge problems
with the pawn on b7 the big weakness in
the position in black's camp as well as
the eighth rank and
this whole concept of getting the knight
to the center should have been focused
at least
on a route to target the pawn on e5
right
it cannot be protected by another pawn
so it should be a weakness or at least
regarded as a weakness the problem is
the knight on f5
so far away from attacking my weakness
on e5 the pawn on e5 it's not looking
good after a4 right now maximum looking
in a deep thing one hour and five
minutes and you don't want to be in this
position against the rating favorite
going into the event vladimir kopian
trailing by only half a point the
leaders if he wins this one he leapfrogs
into the lead and will have to wait for
larry and dmitry gurevich's results and
potentially could take the lead after
this one well and this is why such an
important game vladimir kopian on the
bible with three and a half points
playing against uh maxim at four he's
thinking i've caught my opponent in some
very nice prep just wanted to go to the
game of dmitry uh gurvich and gregory
kaidanov we used to say in the old days
you had these grandmaster draws oh yes
that the grand masters knew a 15 16 18
20 move variation and they knew it was
equal and they would say grand master
draw 106.
okay i know that one grand master draw
you know 208 you know and it looks like
we've got a grandmaster draw going on
between dimitri garvich and gregory
kaidanoff brewing as we've just seen a
kind of a repetition in a theoretical
theoretically disputed line we've seen
bishop e4 queen d5
bishop
d5 attacking the queen queen c2 and now
we're expecting
uh gregory to play
bishop e4 and keep harassing
uh the queen
and maybe a repetition we'll keep an eye
on this one dmitry gurvich kind of came
in with kind of modest goals but
tied for first you kind of feel that
competitiveness right spark
uh start uh
glowing a little bit uh for him as he uh
is in a tie for first so we'll keep an
eye on that one and uh anyone in the
ladies who would like yeah i i was
again i
liked the kings indian so i was turning
to the game of rochelle
and gracie and we left it at the move
bishop g5 and i was more than curious
to see how gracie was going to handle
her business
he has played
c667c6 yeah because i remember i was
thinking oh well
long castle some b5 stuff it could get
really right
knight d2 now gracie made a move
i'm not that keen on uh queen c7
okay
so you had asked me a very salient
question
not that long ago what is white
going to do with her
queen
a king pardon me and i said castle's
long fair okay
in that case what gracie should be doing
in my view
is playing the move a 5 a4 so that when
you cast a lung we have a lot of people
there to greet you
you want your queen on a5 so you gotta
you're always eyeballing opportunities
at a3 oftentimes once you've castled
queenside you tuck your king away you
play a move like king b1 and then let me
just put some moves on the board for
just a moment
uh what we're about to see is that
black's going to attack you know
you know big time on the queen side and
y you know is going to go big time on
the king side and it's going to be the
clash but notice that the queen sitting
on a5
again it's not only just kind of
reaching into what's beginning to
produce but it's support right
gracie actually in this moment she chose
the move for me
uh right here after knight d2 she chose
the move queen c7 which to my taste a
little bit passive and maybe the queen's
not great on them unless you say phrase
me
christian news yesterday that you very
liked
the the pieces don't match the position
oh it's uh
this move does not fit the requirements
thank you so much of the position the
queen is required to be a little bit
more aggressive if you're going to play
attacking chess if you're going to
um you recognize that your opponent's
castling
queen side you you you need to put your
your pieces in the thick of the battle
queen c7 isn't there
no harm no foul i mean it's not like
it's the worst move ever played not at
all it just feels like it might not be
the best square bishop e2 very very
useful move why because that starts to
support ideas of h4h5 development
development good
get ready to connect the rooks bishop e2
h7h6
a move i would shy away from one of the
things that uh for those of you who
watch a lot of our broadcast you'll hear
christian refer to it time and time
again and he uses the term anchor
when you make this move a7 a6
or
not anchor a hook a hook yes i beg your
partner not a anchor hook
with the move h6 you've given white a
hook
she can play the move g4 g5 in the near
future
open up your king side
the move h7 h6 feels a little bit
mis-timed so two
moves by gracie and i'm not a fan of
i still like that a4 that you mentioned
earlier because a4 just because um even
even even after h6 even like after
everything because a4 is
stopping any potential b3 b4 or anything
it just paralyzes the clean side and
just claims it's like literally like
puts a flag
that's my territory yeah go the other
way exactly
i like this a4 at any point from here on
out
exactly and i think she'll play it at
some point and grace is knight d7 also
where exactly are you heading h4 okay
rochelle's playing it very nicely here i
like this move h4 knight b6
again um
you're not really um causing white any
difficulties white is saying look now
you've stepped in front of your b5
p-pawn
so
takes
knight b5
and it feels to me like rochelle has
played this wonderfully like really
really really wonderfully and she's
completely now in the driver's seat
thanks to this move knight b5 which is a
tempo against the queen let's just move
the queen somewhere i'm not sure where
queen e7 oops excuse me and i'm gonna
take now i'm looking at knight takes d6
and bishop takes c5 i'll move my king
off the c file and i will have
the open c file and i'll be the one in
charge
gracie's in trouble in this game what do
you have for us christian i was looking
at the game between a wonder and pedro
because we've seen a wonder just uh
finishing miniatures especially after he
loses a game he gets very angry and
we've seen what happened against carissa
he just
finished karissa off in a matter of an
hour and a half and this is exactly
what's happening right now against pedro
espinosa as well he got a completely
winning position out of the opening and
let's take a look at how did that happen
well right we've seen this move knight
takes d4 at this point
simplifying the position in the center
the problem is that that opens up a lot
of diagonals and you need to understand
the consequences of that and it doesn't
seem like pedro understood that after e5
he's starting to be on the back foot
opening up not taking the pawn on d4
immediately but firstly opening up the
long diagonal if you take on e5 i'm
going to take on e5 back attacking the
queen at the same time and bishop takes
a8 would come next with a devastating
attack and material advantage so you
have to go well
probably not knight to d5 actually
knight to h7 in this position seems to
have been the better option not an easy
move to make by the way going backwards
like this in general is a very very
difficult to do uh thing to do in chess
and knight takes d4 then you have to
find all these type of
crazy ideas with a bishop to g4
not very human-like not very natural in
the position much more natural is get
the knight to a d5 in the center the
problem is that after knight takes a d4
i'm looking at the position knight takes
c6 is coming right there is no doubt
about that and after that bishop takes
d5 is also coming there's no doubt about
that if you allow me to and get a free
pawn how do you defend against that
i don't really see how you can defend
against that you can take on e5 but then
i take you have to take back with the
pawn because the knight on d5 is hanging
now
well i can pick the pawn on e5 that's
one option i can play the move queen to
d3 and start targeting the weaknesses on
the king side the pawn on g6 then follow
it up with rookie to d1 and just bring
all my pieces on their right squares
it's not looking good from a practical
perspective as well as from an objective
perspective let's take a look yeah okay
right now the engine is saying plus 2.3
wow this one is uh a devastating
advantage
for
a wonder in liang once again pedro is
bringing out the fashion in this
tournament yes he yes he is he's uh
regaled us
in the rounds with his very colorful
shirts uh
a big shout out to pedro i love it i
love it he's putting uh pressure on
lavonna ronia to up his game but as we
get ready for our first break you're
holding something that comes from q
boutique what do you got torso well i
told you i'd recently got a car and
license and everything so this will
definitely go perfect for my new parking
spot chess master park yeah i love it it
is from qboutique st louis.com
say yasser you get a discount
i'm telling you five percent man
count me in it's really fun
okay let me just take it from you so i
can give you a close-up everybody yeah
it's a
chess master parking only it's really
cool metal parking sign and you can add
it to your game room i don't know if
it's violators will get checked okay i
mean this is a very uh very serious
violators will get checked i actually
like this myself as we go on break uh we
asked the seniors
what their goals were we'll see you on
the other side and get their answers
what are the goals and ambitions that
you're bringing to this tournament um
finish the tournament alive with a pulse
and actually i'd be happy to go plus one
that's what modest goal but
you know pretty realistic
i'm the oldest guy in the tournament um
and i've been preparing more physically
than men than
chess wise
nowadays i get a little bored uh you
know going over variations and so i can
get more of a
hit from um you know doing physical
stuff
uh you know for professional chess
player
the goal is to play
i mean
the best what you can do to show your
best chess
and not to think too much about the
result to play well because this year
the tournament will be extremely strong
probably
the strongest tournament
senior tournament
compared to
previous years i try not to think about
the result because
usually
this is something which usually has
negative effect on my performance
also i learn from a lot of professional
athletes they always say one game at the
time
and that's going to be my approach i am
mainly trying not to embarrass myself
like i said i'm you know chess is really
you know love of my life but it's
certainly not something that i spent too
much time in the last 20 years
so i'm just hoping to have good fun and
i mean good time
and as they ignite some old friendships
and hopefully like i said you know had
some
decent score since i'm like a regional
champion i think the goal stays the same
you know to win it like
but the competition is
getting stronger in every year and i'm
getting older so
we'll see how it goes well i certainly
like to win first first place
um
it's a very prestigious tournament it's
drawing the best players uh i was able
to win this tournament in 2020
but uh that was a coveted year and we
played online so it's not quite the same
thing to be
you know winning it here in the presence
of all the other players so i'd like to
to be able to win one of these
tournaments in person you know i've been
uh busy for a while used to
play professional chess all the time so
now i'm just getting back into it so
i'm just going to really thoroughly
enjoy playing here i mean um i last last
the time i played i started horrendously
but then i won the last three games
which i guess gives me the biggest
winning streak of anyone here
so i hope to at least reverse the trend
may you know start with wins and maybe
uh
and maybe not do some losses at the end
my goals are very modest
and these days because of my age and
stuff i'm more care about results of my
students and one of my great students is
playing here it's alice live has been
for wonderful years together so i'm
watching her and she's very strong she's
very strong player
by watching her results and growing up
it's great and myself of course i would
not want to play well but
i'm not a favorite
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the us girls u.s
juniors and u.s seniors championships
here are our pairings for this
all-important round seven dorset as we
see an amazing result from sofia mora
suzuki she's a perfect six she's going
up against a key rival today jennifer
you yes sir every time you see perfect i
want to just knock on the woods
and let's take a look at some of these
games including uh
i wanted to say uh sophia's uh which i'm
gonna just jump to her game she's
playing against uh jennifer we think
that jennifer
literally made an error in the opening
it's kind of one of those finger failure
errors you want to make a move but you
do it in the wrong movie i told you
about my story right that i was thinking
like i love my position what do i do
that was the last round when i get gold
in the world youth and then i realized
wait i made a move when and then i
checked my handwriting i wrote down i
can't remember did i do that and you
were telling me a story that you had
that happened to you oh i've made every
mistake in the world twice i feel like
this bishop d7 was one of them
yeah well let's just catch up with the
games because we think
that in fact this position was so good
for white
that sofia missed an opportunity to
really
increase her advantage with the move
knight d3 essentially the move rook c8
by jennifer
telegraphs
her very strong desire
to play c6 e5 and if if she uh sophia
had played the move knight d3 she just
put a kibosh on that idea altogether
you're not going to
play c5
she didn't do that she played queen b3
and this looks very attractive after all
you're bringing your pieces into play
but this is actually giving jennifer the
time that she needs to harmonize her
pawns and pieces and this bishop could
drop back to e8 suddenly and suddenly
wait a minute on on a bad day a move
like for example d4 takes c5 bishop
takes and rook takes could land with the
knight on e5
um under attack so let me just make a
bad move for white for just a second
sorry yes
a bad move and i'm gonna make like i
don't know two bad moves
and suddenly this is the type of thing
where
jessica see what you're going for nice
yeah jennifer's sitting there saying
okay i've got these ideas suddenly and
she never really could have had them a
moment ago so c5 on the board now from
um sophie's point of view
she's recognizing wait a minute
something kind of
went wrong
maybe i should start to bail out here a
bit maybe i should just play knight
takes d7
capture the bishop while the capturing
is good i can stick a knight on b5 and
i'm not going to be worse i'll be a
little bit better but the advantage that
she had
a real dip another way that's um
christian was explaining uh before we
went on break was about how the position
would be different um the the sophie's
game if um earlier if jennifer had
played the correct knight d7 move and
those knights the e5 and f6 knight would
have been traded
that was a very good comparison and in
this in the game in the position that we
have right now
yes
knight d7 would have been the way the
way to go and just comparing this
this um how it would have turned out
with how that actually turned out with
the knight on e5 and the knight on f6
so this was i think we think
what uh jennifer expected
and the knight on f6 and the knight on
e5 are both missing boom so she was
ready to play this position but if you
look at the analysis board
versus the actual board the knight on f6
is a really
awkward piece because it has nowhere to
go
whereas the knight on e5 was playing a
very nice role so that is a game and i
just wanted to uh again rochelle wu
who's really on the outside looking in
everything has gone perfectly for her
after knight to d7 she's got
sorry i was like wait that pawn on d6 is
gone
she lost it
she lost it it's that bad
and uh
completely winning now for rochelle this
bishop is ready to pop out to c4 this
knight will shut down the c file knight
to c7 and then it will just be
all she wrote on the on the king side
i might be mistaken but i'm going to say
it anyways this was like five six years
ago when i first came to us uh within
the first year i remember that i think
she was working with one of my teammates
and uh it was funny because i remember
her like this tiny girl's voice on skype
gracie
rochelle rochelle i don't think it was
rochelle because i just remember the
number she was like oh that that kid
rochelle and then i see that she's
playing so well here but
i
i i you know i don't even think she
knows i know this is right
but it was always so fun to see how like
a 11 year old 12 year old grows up to
play so cool
right
yeah
i it's always funny uh remembering my
own summer chess camps where i was
giving
chess comedy yeah yeah coaching and you
know little jeffrey jean running all
right
would you like to play would you like to
play vince he was so so so very happy
now he's like a 2700 i've heard a lot of
stories about ray robson also growing up
from yay
yeah there was a wonderful i don't know
if it's on youtube but if you do get a
chance do take a look it was like 10
years of st louis chess club oh yes i
remember that he was so
small that was
what triggered the memory was we saw ray
robson literally grow up at the st louis
chess club and he went from a
five-year-old a five foot ten year old
to a six and a half foot
you know 25 year old it was like what
it's pretty impressive
uh christian why we're having fun
i know you've been working hard looking
at all the games figuring them out i was
having some fun with this game okay
actually with a lot of games but this
one in particular because
i mean brandon jacobson with the white
pieces is in deep trouble and let's take
a look at how they got to where they are
right now uh this position we've seen
this idea of taking on d5 uh this nimsa
with e3 bishop d3 taking on d5 and an
early bishop d2 or queen to c2 a very
interesting game and recent game is the
one between dingley wren and rajabov and
actually that was a huge clash that kind
of uh truthingly ran out of contention
for the candidates tournament rajabov
won that game handily with the black
pieces and this is exactly a very
reminiscent situation to what we've seen
in that game take a look at that game if
you do have time knight to d7
queen to c2 c5 now get the knight first
to d7 so that whenever you go c5 you
could potentially take with the knight
he decided not to take with the knight
he decided to take with the bishop now
the knight on d7 not only that it's
ready to take back on c5 with the knight
and attack bishop one d3 but also
protect the bishop right now without the
knight on d7 some ideas of knight takes
d5 could have uh arrived on the board
and just discovery attack on the bishop
on c5 now castle knight to e5 everything
seems to be more or less fine for white
but take a look at this move knight f to
g4
allowing white to take on h7 with a
check you can take that pawn that's fine
go take go take it king to h8 what do
you do next because you know what's
coming your way queen to h4 is coming
now that the bishop h7 is there queen
two h4 will not only be
a it will be a triple threat
attack the pawn on f2 attack the pawn on
h2 and attack the bishop on h7 you
cannot go g3 because first of all g6
just traps the bishop but also knight to
f3 looks like a very threatening uh
check you don't have the bishop on g2
the fianchetto bishop close to your king
you actually don't have any pieces close
to your king except maybe this knight on
e2 but unfortunately it doesn't really
help you too much you have a lot of
weaknesses on the light squares knight
fg4 came as a thunder in the position
and for example if you go h3 right now
boom knight takes f2 taking advantage
once again that you place your bishop on
h7
queen to h4
if you go king to g1 i'm not even
taking on h7 and allowing the queen
trade no no no i'm looking to check
matey right now with the move knight to
f3 exactly yes knight to f3 if you take
rook takes e3 comes on the board taking
advantage of all of my pieces the bishop
on c5 is ready to deliver the check the
fatal check in the position this is just
looking uh tremendous for andrew hong
right now knight fg4
and brandon jacobson is
stopped stopped exactly
after rook fd1 let's take a look so
castle he still had one hour and 15
minutes after rook fd1 53 minutes
after knight fg4 another 15-minute thing
right now he's on 40 minutes and
thinking
and i have to oh my goodness look at him
he understands that there's so many
pieces and so many attackers swarming
around his king and in fact he doesn't
have any defenders
ready to help
yeah looks like thunder and lightning
are about to strike his position another
game i really want you to weigh in on
christian
is the game of christopher you
uh and david brodsky when we left it uh
david had just unleashed a very nice uh
sacrifice knight takes pizza too and
it's not really a sacrifice it's what we
call a
sham sacrifice what that means is a fake
sacrifice it looks like i'm sacrificing
a knight knight takes b2 but it's not a
sacrifice it's a sham sacrifice i'm
faking it
because i will go queen
uh
uh
a c4 check and if you cover the queen
well cover your king pardon me uh i pick
up the bishop so uh i didn't sacrifice
anything in fact i traded yes this was a
yasser approved pawn and that's an oh
big time big time but we had some
interesting developments thereafter
one thing was the move e6 we kind of
briefly very very briefly looked at it
but from a different move order queen
c490 and i wanted to get chris
christian
your perspective right here because
uh david said look let's trade queens
i'm not going to be worse i'm going to
be better life's good we think
but could he have taken the bishop on f4
after the move knight e5 that is to say
move 21 95 he played queen takes e2
correct but well if you take on f4
what's uh the follow up
well follow up you have to take on f7
most likely
with the pawn with a pawn yes exactly
and then because i am a rook down i want
to take a full rook exactly and now if
you go
king to h8 a g3
g3
i'm getting close to somehow checkmating
you so it is it is a rook at the moment
imagine this position for example if you
go queen to g5 okay
king to g2 okay and now you try to save
the knight knight to c4 right perfect i
have the idea of knight to g6 knight to
g6 right exactly and i'm not 100 sure
you can by the way uh defend against
that anyway by take and now rook to h1
yeah exactly and i'll just go into h6
take take take on e7 you're going to get
checkmated
after point g5 maybe just throw in the
f4 to make sure the queen goes to h6
then do everything we're going to do the
same thing same thing we're going to do
the same thing because right now rook h1
is coming with a tempo so take take take
on f7 king to h8 g3 and if you do go to
h6 then once again king to g2
so again take take king
g3 if we go immediately to jesus the
same thing you you are threatening
checkmate at that point queen to h1 is a
checkmate exactly i don't have time to
do anything but king to g2 right and
get the rook to h1 now the thing is
you are a rook up right exactly
your rook doesn't really help you that
much i want you to go to h1
so that's not the only move i can't
start with knight to g6 but i think rh1
is good enough right
in any case we're going to get into a
position of bishops of opposite colors
um
i think it would be easier to play white
easier to play with i just wanted to
make sure that you know like
he left his bishop on f4 hanging did
christopher
and now after 95 takes takes
bishop f6 rook h1
and david has been kind of shaking his
head like
did i get confused
take it away christian
this is a huge game
for
our junior championship oh absolutely
i'm not sure why he's shaking his head
uh rook h1 must have been a move that he
considered absolutely and he's not
losing no no no he's he's he's all right
i mean he can play h6 right now i'm a
bit uh surprised that he's
so disappointed in his position why not
just simply h6 right so h6
uh i'm assuming white has to take on f7
check yes and then i'm assuming we've
got to recapture it rook takes f7 i mean
king h8 knight g6
is not what i am playing for now you
could take the rook you can play bishop
e6 but the whole point is that uh
black desperately wants to get in this
crucial move bishop on e5
bishop on f6 takes e5
so could they do that before h6
to just eliminate
funny business on f7 so bishop takes e5
if any bishop takes seven king is right
i don't really think there is
i have at least a perpetual now yeah
well we we're thinking black is for
choice oh
but not only perpetual maybe i can even
try to do something exactly you you
might play for more
but uh definitely black uh we think
black is for choice um it's actually
very close to equality right now really
at this moment but that's that's kind of
what
distracts me a little bit why is he so
uh annoyed with his
position david brodsky i mean he really
is annoyed
he found that like nice knight takes p2
so he probably imagined there is
something after it so perhaps he
assessed the position as
better much better yeah maybe he thinks
he missed something on the way but i
don't think she did i mean the choice of
coin four queen takes bishop earlier was
there but i think he did the right thing
turning the queens off queen takes f4
was too dangerous completely agree no um
i think christopher first of all he kept
his school he missed knight takes b2 he
for sure was quite clear but he kept his
school he found the right move e6 and
now we're headed straight into this
variation which indeed from an objective
assessment it does seem like it's close
to a balanced position wow so after all
of those not the exciting tactics yes
it's it's just balanced it's it's not
equal yet no i i cannot you know despite
the fact that the engine is saying zero
zero this is a balanced position
anything can happen and the eval can
change uh with each other because
there's so many nuances and details that
both players have to be aware of well as
i'm looking at the position i'm thinking
if it's black's turn bishop takes e5
resign
it's over instantaneously
instantaneously i'm an exchange up so
you as white and not only that but
you know your your queen side pawns are
toast i mean i i can easily target
so you've got to do something like takes
rook takes and come up with some
wonderful
ways of winning back your exchange if
you don't do it rather quickly
it won't happen and uh i'm
saying okay
is this really a balanced position for
christopher if you take take take
wouldn't you think well
a little easier to play black i mean
you're ready to go knight a4 takes
c1 yes absolutely but maybe you don't
have to take on f7 first right that's
what i'm thinking that you have to do
something else so you you play the move
h6 and let's wait and see what
christopher comes up with because he's
about to he's doing what he said
yesterday he's ready to make a move he
took off
take on f7 now again king h8 is not a
move so you have to recapture right away
bravo by the way
to david and immediately taken
christopher didn't stop for bishop e6
he just grabbed the rook um expecting
king takes f7 and this is the end game
where we're just about to talk about
where i was saying
to my eyes
i think exactly
yeah
yeah
and uh the engines actually agree with
you yes sir um
this is the first time
it's all about that weakness on c3 right
that is the big problem that's what i'm
targeting how
for example how do you defend after
bishop to e4
bishop to e4 so what if i go bishop to
e4 try to target try to find some
weaknesses in your position as well the
first thing i want to do is rook e8 rook
e8 yes
now at least i can get the king to f3
and i feel like
whenever you take on a c3 let's say
knight to a4 knight takes c3 at least
that knight takes e3 doesn't come with a
check
so i'm partially happy because of that
logical we've got a partial
partial happiness
um
and i think he's going for it
i think he's looking at bishop to e4
which once again it makes at least my i
kind of like the king on uh e2 myself if
i'm in black shoes
as much as i really really want to play
knight a4 and knight takes c3 uh i like
my pawn on c6 uh once i win the pawn on
c3 i want to i want to get that going he
has played the movie
before yeah and again this
do not do this people at home
do not do what christopher you just did
he took the bishop and he put it on e4
and he held it and he held it and he
held it and sort of like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the move i want to play i'll
let you know do that before you do it
make sure of your move before you reach
out i think that is the most uh ideal
way right but i've had opponents of
course it's really like annoyed me
exactly
it could be a way to annoy your
opponents i never wanted to annoy your
opponents christian that's what i say
that's one of
the rules that it's easier said than
done because i know i've heard it many
times yes don't hover over your pieces
but
almost always there's at least a couple
of moments in one's game that you do
that and i've seen it even with the very
top level players now christopher i
think he does it quite often
maybe everything's the uh
it may be a little slow motion but
the point is is like he's just holding
it
holding it
yeah
okay let it go but also what crystal and
you can see right in front of him he has
a black queen a black knight a black
rook a pawn and he kind of all he holds
them and he fiddles with them as he's
analyzing again very bad habit because
when i'm looking at the board i'm kind
of looking beyond the board as well so
you're fiddling
i see
right and it's disturbing yeah yeah
don't disturb your opponent now i'll let
you in on a little secret about the
position please um bishop to e4 was
actually not a good move i didn't think
it was that great i i thought it's a
great move it's kind of helping black
isn't it and he played knight a4 the
best move in the position quickly david
broadski right now is taking over this
game i think christopher did not realize
that after the knight is coming to c3
well you have another weakness that you
need to worry about a2 right a2 is
falling as well not only that that let's
go bishop take c6 knight takes c3 maybe
yes check
now
the king has to
get i mean it makes no sense to i know i
go to d8 and rook to david eight and
look at this you've got this guy
how do you defend the pawn on a2 and
gift me the pawn i agree i get it the
position opened up the bishop should in
theory uh be uh strong but the knight on
c3 is just dominating the board right
now right
i i like i like what black is doing i
like the fact that david is actually
playing extremely quickly and putting a
lot of pressure on christopher and look
as christopher right now um christopher
has 47 minutes david 51 so very close in
time okay that's balanced yeah but
as we're getting closer to the end of
the tournament
you start telling yourself stories i'm
so close to winning the tournament i'm
so close to becoming the champion i'm so
close to qualifying because this is the
u.s championship qualifier to the us
championship that's a big prize that's
that's a huge price in itself and we
don't mention it enough but qualifying
to the us chess championships means that
you're going to be meeting uh fabiano
caruana wesley so linear dominguez and
uh all owners
as well so
right now we're seeing bishop take c6
knight c3 king to f3 it's a big prize
for this young
15 year of age christopher you so
there's a lot of pressure on him right
now right so maybe we're seeing a little
bit of a crack
in christopher's psychological state he
wouldn't be the first to find himself
close to the finish line
and
fall
over before crossing uh but you're
absolutely right christian i really
really want to emphasize that to the
audience
that when i played in the junior
championships and they were qualifiers
to the u.s championship
that was like wow what a cool goal that
was i really really wanted to qualify
and again because of the pandemic we're
going to be playing catch-up at this
year's u.s championships for the open as
well as the women's section where we'll
be inviting
two junior players i think
uh the winner of this juniors as well as
the winner the juniors before so the
field will be a little bit bigger than
our normal field to
accommodate the best players the
question is uh hence neiman uh qualified
from last year but he also qualifies by
rating because he's already
down to uh power to 700 or something
along those lines so
does the second place from 2021 qualify
like why we will probably need some
clarification right i always understood
that you use your first qualification
criteria in this case it would have been
the junior junior recently hans nemes is
rating i mean has exploded right i mean
we're talking 250 rating points in the
last three years christian yes 20 24 50
to like 2700 in a matter of like i think
he decided
to go for it at around 16 years of age
right now he's close to 19. and he his
his leap was just impressive absolutely
so
yeah i think he's in by
um quite
about no no by junior so then we get an
extra qualifier by rating perhaps or
yeah that's the way it would go but okay
in the moment christopher you
in trouble
can david brodsky maintain his nerve i
mean he's quadriceps when everything
well so far so he's played a whole slew
of fantastic movie yeah he's a fantastic
moves uh in
we saw it yesterday in his game against
the wonder liang as well
he was up against the number one seed a
wonder liang david brodsky
and once he got his winning position i
want to say he played it virtually
flawlessly i have no no complaints this
moment
he's got a pretty big edge and you can
see christopher getting nervous here and
we'll keep our eye on this game
you were saying that brandon
london was into give you an update on
that one yes please and maybe we should
go to that one yes because a lot of
fireworks are coming yes bishop to e1
was played
check this sequence out queen to h4 easy
move first one but you need to calculate
the consequences after that
you want to go back no you don't want to
go back sorry to interrupt your question
my board the bishop is not on h7
it's not no no it's not okay no there's
so much he did not take on
that was a poison pawn this queen to h4
coming uh into into the attack also with
a hit on the bishop on h7 was just too
much no keep the bishop on d3 gotcha
you cannot touch the pawn on h7 h3 now
what do you do now do you go backwards
no absolutely not you lose uh you lose a
beat 965 the tables turn don't think
about it don't think about that think
about sacrifices right right
knight takes e3 is one of them but
knight g3 f3
is actually the best move
in the position delivering a decisive
advantage for black g takes f3 what do
you do now
take my other knight as well oh boy
i takes e3 i need to invade your
position as fast as possible if you take
bishop takes c3 that's going to be a
checkmate you move the king anywhere
queen takes h3 you move bishop f2 i just
simply pick it up with the queen and
then checkmate in the next few moves
right you cannot do that beautiful so
knight to e3
maybe you can go queen to a4 right but
then i just simply go queen to g5 i'm
not exchanging the queens
knight to g3 bishop takes h3
everything gets involved all my forces
are getting involved into a pack
with tempo wow there's so many problems
that you have to deal with right now
knight xd1 will open up the action of my
bishop on c5 which will indeed open up
the potential of queen takes g3 making
use of the fact that this pawn on f2 is
pinned
so bishop takes h3 not only that he took
a pawn but at the same time he defended
the rook that's why we couldn't do
knight takes d1 before you have to
defend the rook first very complex
battle right now and we're showing you
all these lines right crazy looking
lines
andrew hung has to calculate this yeah
andrew hong not only has to calculate
this but has to trust his calculation as
well it's very easy to start doubting
yourself at this point but we know if
anybody can do it andrew hong it is
andrew hong likes to take risks we've
seen him taking a lot of risks yesterday
against karissa as uh well he's not
going to shy away from those
complications and if he sees this knight
to f3 followed by knight takes e3 well
he is breaking through right now
yes sometimes you just tip your hat and
say well done young man queen h4
knight f3 knight e3
those are sparkling
tactical shots i love it dorsa yeah i
just wanted to mention like um you know
like just teaching people they always
ask why not why should i always put my
knight on f3
that that queen getting into h4 is one
of it exactly yeah it's just so such a
having that knight on f3 instead of v2
of course i feel like if you play knight
to e2 you gotta at some point get that
f3 e4 done if you don't get that done
then what's my knight doing on e2
exactly so i just i feel like the
opening maybe got misplayed a little no
question about it it did uh knight on f3
would prevent moves like queen h4 or
defending h2 the knight on e2 is good
for literally one purpose yeah i
understand it could go on to d4 i but
you could also go to d4 from f3 the
knight on e2 really has one purpose you
put your knight on f4 to um
to tickle uh the isolated queen pawn if
your knight the knight should have been
on f4 already
so that you know you would be able to
protect h3 the fact that black gets to
play queen h4 and after h3 i love this
move knight f
uh 3 check uh one other thing i mean to
follow it up with knight e3 you think
that you're following it up with queen
takes but then you are allowing these
kinds of things where the knight is on
f4
this is crazy good fun
and
this move if knight takes e3
knight f3
knight takes e3 if those moves get
played you're in the tactical puzzle
books of the 23rd century because i just
love this checkmating pattern uh
christian mentioned queen
takes it
with the bishop correct okay we gotta do
we i mean you know we we have to show
style and understanding christian you
know
he struggles but okay a little a little
help from time to time
but you got some breaking news first
christian absolutely yes it does seem
like talia cervantes another potential
suitor for the championship title right
well she's breaking through right now in
her game against ellen wang we have this
position on the board and she can simply
just play the move e5 the king is
extremely weak let's take a look at the
quality of black species the king is
extremely weak you created a lot of
weakness by pushing your pawns in front
of your castle and i will be able to
take advantage of that after the move f4
in the future open up the rook open up
the king you're in trouble the bishop on
b7 well unfortunately c5 never happened
uh the bishop b7 is still stuck and c5
is not yet on tap because the pawn on b5
is hanging so you're a few moves behind
in that regard as well i have the two
bishops i have this diagonal open
towards
your king and it's just looking pretty
rough right now i mean rook to e1 is a
simple move and once again ask you
what are you going to do next as black
because i know what i'm going to do next
i'm going to go e6 if you let me right
so
i'm looking at the quality of the pieces
once again and i'm not seeing any good
pieces for black or any potential for
any counter play for black and this is
alarming i think talia is right now
breaking through but i have to say
talia has had a lot of winning positions
now
she has some difficulties converting
those winning positions but right now
foreign four out of six two points
behind sophie she needs to win
and she also let's not forget
play sophie in the last round with the
white pieces so that could potentially
become a huge clash consequential clash
for the final standings it's like one of
those things uh dorsey you have
hollywood script writers who you know
uh
write these dramatic stories and build
up the drama
and so often it happens in chess
tournaments that i don't know you know
who wrote the script but they draw they
do a pairings of the drawings of lot and
it turns out that the last round
pairings decide first place and that's
what it looks like it's going down to in
the ladies but in the meanwhile sophie
all she's doing is winning every one of
her games before we're about to solve
this game because i just wanted to ask
you because during the candidates
commentary i got so many great book
recommendations from you okay i have you
anything in mind for converting
advantages
for converting yes because that's
something that's that's something that i
had to work a lot on i still do i know
so many people work on
like okay i get a little bit of
advantage
now what do i do right
um so
as we say in chess one of the most
difficult things in chess is winning one
position right and converting those uh
two wins uh is crucial i remember
improve your chest now um
it was a book that was written funnily
enough by jonathan tisdale which is who
was one of our guests so i got so many
good books exactly
that was for me but uh
i
really like games collections seeing you
know the best games and you know looking
at players games holistically uh from
the opening through the middle gate
through the end game and getting carried
along with them um
i'm not sure i'd have a good
recommendation and again uh you know
because you're one recommend one size
does not fit all right i mean something
like the amateur's mind it's a fantastic
book by jeremy sillman really aimed at
class players and experts
may not help somebody like you
you're too good already so you need
something else um christian do you have
some tips as a coach that you would say
guys
this is what it's all about
very specific your current coach has got
some ideas for you very specific uh tips
i i cannot think of any but there's
plenty of books that will put you and
have examples and i have examples uh as
well
of examples in which you are put in a
better position and then you have to
deliver and i think it's all about
experience and whenever you train for a
tournament in preparation for a
tournament you should put yourself in
these type of situations situational
training i think it's extremely
extremely underrated in chess but guys
this game sophie maurice is okay versus
jenny for you yeah
nothing major has happened but that's
what it is guys the time right now
sophie mori suzuki is down to her last
18 minutes wow with 22 moves left in the
position she actually spent more than 30
minutes on this decision to take on c5
at move 17 she had 50 minutes her
opponent one hour and five minutes she
went all the way down to 19 minutes with
his move d takes c5
difficult decision i have to say i'm not
100 sure why she spent so much time
knight xd7 this is what we have on the
board and
her advantage is sleeping right now it's
minimal if anything whatsoever in the
position because what takes these
knight b takes d7 this knight on b6 was
terrible what's the target right
in the position was a terrible night now
finally after the exchange most likely
that's going to come of the dark square
bishops i'm going to be able to get it
to c5 this knight will be able to
transfer back to e5 i'm starting to
really like and warm up to black's
position to jennifer u's position
this would be such a big shake out in
this tournament if jennifer manages
to uh turn the tables on sofia and let's
not forget she was completely busted out
of the opening yesterday that bishop d7
must have been something that she did
not prepare it was a terrible failure
right side if jennifer you does manage
to win we can get her in the studio so i
can ask her what was that bishop they
said she would go to five and then
imagine talia going to five as well and
rochelle and
right i mean what a chasing wolf pack
that would be with two rounds to go our
championship rounds coming up rounds
eight and nine
uh and i just wanted to follow up on the
sophie game for a moment because
knight on b6 takes t d7 is such a
suggestive recapture the knight on b6 is
terribly placed it's not going forwards
it's not even going sideways
this would be brilliant a
bishop trade but i wanted to just point
this out
that after a move like knight b5 the
queen could actually post up and this is
where we're starting to see again i'm
helping black a lot
my bishop now right i mean everything
kind of went wrong for white suddenly
this queen is looking good this knight
is looking good
maybe this pawn is even a tad weaker
than the pawn on a5 so this is how
jennifer
you know gets a really good position out
of a really bad opening and she took
with the b knight yes exactly so this is
a game and we mentioned rochelle and
talia from rochelle came from what i see
it seems pretty dead
for i mean winning for rochelle she she
won upon she's won an exchange
it's all going yeah she's just got to be
how do you say mindful
that there isn't something well even
her rook on d2 is just
yeah it's wonderful yeah it's wonderful
even if you did attack the rook i could
play sorry what did you oops there's
also queen takes aa
sorry that's uh that's the position is
so good you don't even want to take that
i didn't even want to take the
it's it's good rochelle's got this
italia did you say has her as her uh big
advantage as well she didn't play e5
this is one of your questions what you
just asked or said how do you win
winning positions well in this case e4
e5 really suggests itself tell you
played f4
this looks also good too yeah i don't
think a four is bad but yeah e5
definitely better because i mean e5
you're just asking okay knight where do
you want to go wherever the knight goes
it just feels awkward because now i have
control over the h7 square now if i want
to do f4 stuff i think that's much more
comfortable not necessarily like right
now but if i do end up then i'm opening
up the f5 immediately with my the bishop
the light square bishop staying open so
i'm
tally is still for choice but i'm not
100 sure i like this one and i like what
uh
what uh christians was saying that
now you know your best move is
g5 g7 if you don't get to play that
these dark squares especially your f6
squares which means we think um so
instead of var
these days danish barrage is um
how do i put it i was not saying
grandmaster is in wrestling no um
[Music]
chess expert thank you what's going on
in my ear but i know tom is in my years
so i guess dennis is in tom's ear wow
they're giving out titles just
just like so easily
i had a funny talk with him a while back
about how wonderful
how wonderful it would be to have a
chest that we can bring the pawns back
backward
[Music]
we're like we've gone too far let's uh
let's play it oh we're actually having a
serious all right you know like how
about this impact chess and we were like
well that's a whole different game
totally different game yeah it would be
funny to put the super ground masters
i'd be like all right you guys can all
take your pawns back play
i was about to say i love chess variants
and i play a lot of chess variants but
i've never played a variant where the
pawn goes backwards i think it was anand
who mentioned he's playing in no castle
tournament no castle that was with
vladimir putin maybe there can be a new
tournament no pawns can come back
i don't know christian i think that
would really make
those
pawns even more
helpful useful right right that they
could come back
maybe
i i like the way chess is set up i
understand
you're a traditionalist i i'm i'm a
traditionalist right i like the game
that you propose uh yasser the sarah one
chest has chess
i love that i love the new pieces i love
the elephant the eagle
is that how you call it there you go
the hawk there you go
guys
g5 was the key move right wait g5 was
the key move in this game as well oh the
game between david brodsky and
christopher you christopher played this
move to h5 okay check this nice move out
g5
cutting the action you want to go to c5
and get into my play absolutely not
you're not getting there
g5 i'm cutting the rook away from the
action and after b3 just in flicking to
g7 defend the pawn
still continue attacking the pawn on a2
your rook is now completely out of play
paralyzed yeah and it doesn't seem like
you're anywhere close to creating any
sort of initiative on the king side this
is where you have a pawn majority as
white potential pawn majority if you
manage to go g3 kg to f4 you're very far
away from that you're not going together
and my position is stabilized on the
king side this is what i love to see for
black
and in the meantime i'm just going to
take care of business on this side uh
this pawn is in deep danger i'm going to
go a5 b4 as well if you start attacking
it with bishop to b7
this was have given actually
david brodsky a decisive advantage
wow decisive advantage instead of that
he did not play it he played the move
rook to d3
attempted by the check bishop to e3 and
now we have bishop to g5
but now it looks compelling it does but
how do we assess this position is the
question and i think this is what he's
looking at also we're it seems like
we're headed for this end game take take
rook to a3 take take root takes g5 rook
takes a2 this is the position that i
think we're going to see on the board i
get it you have two past pawns
is that enough
it's better enough it it is black better
it's better black is definitely better
better for sure but how much better his
the computer doesn't agree to the uh to
the idea that black has a decisive
advantage it says that black uh has an
advantage but not enough for for a
victory in that one okay
the players don't have any of the
engines they don't have any of the
assessment how does it look visually in
your opinion
i like black very much
how close do you feel you are from
winning
and by the way this is also a
psychological uh trick that the human
mind is playing on us we are attempting
to go for simplification yes and this is
exactly what david brosky is looking at
right now he sees this idea of bishop to
e4 he sees all these simplifications and
then he sees that there's no way he will
lose that he has all the chances of
actually winning the position and uh no
chance of losing that and he's going for
it it makes sense from a practical
perspective it makes sense and by the
way bishop b4 once again that's a big
decision that christopher right now has
to go for if he wants to maintain the
balance see a wonderful uh back a shot
of joel
i'm nice a little bit more pepper than
salt though that's a good thing that's a
good thing
and of course like you're saying it it's
the it's the human mind
that likes to look for those
simplifications
christopher's thing he played it he
played bishop before he did and
christopher is thinking
that he thinks it's his best chance he
thinks this end game is a draw
okay and and probably he's right
bishop takes g5 h takes g5 rook takes g5
rook a2
may be a draw but he's got to work hard
to earn it oh man by the way as we're in
brake territory i just wanted to give a
quick
look at the carissa yip game before we
go
the crazy part is i think
i am not joking i think both players
despite the fact have taken a lot of
time to get here are still in
theory
that the the scotch defense the scotch
opening
the theory has gone so deeply these days
that um
you're playing a game closer you're one
move away i don't really agree with pawn
takes pawn
but did you want
well white just played the move knight
on d2 pardon me white carissa just
played the movie knight d2
it's an f3 and she's looking at like hey
give me the tempo against your queen
maybe knight g5 which was the first move
out of theory knight f3 is the title f3
was the first that's her novel
yes and by the way a novelty
over a game of sam shanklin versus
laxman
rajaram from 2008
when sam was 2200. 2200. a very young
promising talent a promising sand shag
yes and what happened after
sam actually lost that game
but knight f3 to my mind sometimes you
have a novelty
where
you do something really
crazy unexpected creativity then you
have a novelty that looks like the most
normal move on the board and you ask
yourself nobody ever played knight f3
before christian i mean that's such a a
decently good move uh which one excuse
me again knight f3 by karissa yes knight
to f3 yeah no rook to c2 was the move
that was played i kind of moved away
from that game in just one second let me
get back to it okay
knight to f3 is the best move yes dxc4
is also the best move uh by balaji and
this is what we have queen to e4 queen
to g6
it does seem like both of these players
are playing quite good and precise chess
in fact at this point um
and the way i look at it and the way
probably charissa looks at it emblazoned
as well seems like black is doing just
fine could could it actually be that
we're still in the players both players
no brains no absolutely no chance teresa
has 29 minutes balaji 34 minutes no
chance
no they've been spending a lot of time
up to this point even though they've
been spending a lot of time it's only
been one or two original moves
but no chance they they know i don't
think that theory was any good
let's just put it this way i mean this
was a 2008 game between a 2200 sam
shanklin and a 2400 uh that i actually
have not heard about so i don't think
that was a very theoretically sound game
either i think sam was underrated at
2200. yes i was just gonna say the
position i mean i feel like it's still
one of those like
the
dream positions quote unquote because of
the pawn structure right um but i i'm
having a hard time thinking how to
actually
fight for anything well my first thought
that is that carissa after the move
queenie for queen g6 should trade queens
all right okay so in my mind when i have
such positions i'm thinking my trumps
are the bishop on g2
the knight on f3 these these pieces the
knight on b6 uh the bishop on a6 they're
off the board i understand you've won a
pawn
but i'm thinking let's say you take all
right okay let's say i play e6 let's say
you take and let's see i play 95. now at
the moment the problem is i've given up
a lot of pawns
i wanted to you know black spawn
structures yeah
we we
i've weakened the pawns but
in fact there's still a lot of black
pawns on the board i'm not 100 sure i
i uh i'm justified in making all of
these pawn sacrifices she played queen
h4 and as we get ready for break
christian get in your word breaking news
guys
one of the chasers in the senior section
that is alex chabot who won a brilliant
game yesterday with the black pieces
against kai donald is in deep trouble
right now with the white pieces and this
just happened in the last couple of
moves
let's take a look beautiful position for
white h5 now you can actually take on h5
gift me the pawn why not give me the
pawn this is actually a very nicely
protected pawn
but he did not play that he got tempted
by this pawn storm on the king side with
the move f4 there is a big problem with
this though
h takes g4 h takes g4 you would think
that you're controlling everything right
now right right knight f5 came out of
the blue
opening
attack via h4 which is actually just
simply deadly
deadly in one move he cannot take
because of queen to h4 this is made it's
just me it's just me
wow that's the thing it's just me
whatever if you go rook f3 check check
check
checkmate
that's one way
quinto h2 is the checkmate threat if you
go here queen to h1 is a checkmate if
you go knight to f3 queen to g3 is a
checkmate every single defense is met
with a checkmate
it's after knight to fight you have to
go bishop f2 and guess what
knight to e3 is going to come on the
board right now
knight e knight to e3 the bishop just
came back from e3 the bishop is not
allowed to get off the f2 square h4
because queen h4 once again is the
checkmate threat so knight to e3 that's
going in my place and
igor is sensing the moment he's sensing
it
he's looking at it
and shabala when he played
and then there you have it nice it's on
the board and it's on the board right oh
my goodness what a turn of events
and very quick
you know this is wonderful i have played
with alexander shabalov shabadabadoo so
many times but he just made the move
queen d1 to e1 now 10 years ago when he
made that move
he made it with such
uh i want to say dignity oh my
like ilan like this was all a part of
the plan i have seen knight of five i
have seen queen h4 and checkmate i've
seen you fork my
queen and rook and go ahead and take it
and it was like wait a minute doesn't
this guy know he's busted i mean it is
he knows
now
ten years later you see him holding his
ten years ago he would get up with this
regal oh the boy
yes thank you i was good
to figure that bluff part out thank you
complete bluff
he's been had and he's in trouble in
this game as we go on our break we asked
the girls yes what are your goals for
this tournament here are their answers
and we'll see on the other side of the
break
[Music]
what are the goals and ambitions that
you're bringing to this tournament um i
just like to play a few great games um
it's really for the experience playing
against all these great players that
have been here before and um so i can
meet some new people and just try to
play the best chess i can i mean this is
my first time here so i'm just really
hoping to play good games and i'm not
i'm trying not to be that result
oriented i'd say like i just want to
play the best i can i don't really want
to
set a specific goal because i don't
really want to give myself too much
pressure and just like see where it
takes me as usual i just try to play as
best as i can and be relaxed it's almost
as a vacation because
i just get to be in town and see
you know all of my friends from previous
events and
yeah just play as best as i can and
hopefully results will come my main goal
well obviously i want to win
i have to say that like i played the
first time i played was like was for the
first year they made the tournament i'm
pretty sure which was um i don't know i
was like 11 or 12. and i was already
like top seed then so the fact that i
haven't won is just like something
that's always been kind of bothering me
because it's like oh it should happen at
some point i feel really old in this
field you can see like before i felt
like it was like kind of my generation
players that were like come the upcoming
and then now we're like the ones that
are leaving now there's all these young
players all these new 10 year olds it's
just really interesting to see i mean i
like to win
i always do
but
other than that
my
goals outside of just getting good
results are just
i really want to just chill i just want
to have the most fun that i can
i hope just try my best and see where it
goes and you know try to win the
tournament well it is my first time so
i'm kind of going in with no
expectations but i'm just hoping to take
it day by day and also just play some
chess that i'm proud of i hope to
i'm trying basically i want to be a
fierce competitor play good games
and fight to finish and do my best and
finish at the highest place possible i'm
hoping that i will be able to improve on
my score last year but on the higher
bound i would of course like to try to
win the tournament although it's very
competitive and the players are very
strong so that would be a hard task but
not impossible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of these junior championships
while we were on break a wonders game
has just
finished against pedro espinosa i think
a wonder actually
was the winner in yes that game
and as as also while we were on break
the game between vladimir kopian and
maxim delugi
uh it was a good opening for a copian
but things have gotten better and better
and better
and now it looks like uh
vladimir has really just kind of
dominated the entirety of the board the
center the green side of the gig site
all seem to be in white's favor and
that's a very very big
result because once again
uh vladimir comes into the round a half
a point behind the three uh leaders he's
playing one of them max if he can get
past max and the other
leaders draw a copian will earn a tie
for first and we've just seen captures
on
um
uh e5 okay so check this check this
video out guys
go christian
what if i go knight to sis okay bad idea
forget about it
wait wait wait wait wait
like like forget about it like
don't don't this is what i'm seeing
whenever i see a knight on h4 and a
bishop on e4 i see the knight completely
dominated correct so if i manage to
exchange all of the pieces
on the left side right right leave the
position with only the bishop and the
knight that is game over so i would say
that knight to c6 i gotcha because
there's actually no physical way in
which you can return knight back you can
go g6 and then go knight to f5 and
sacrifice a piece but i think that's
just losing so this is what i was
looking at the problem is you don't have
to take on d8 exactly e4 yeah but
exactly this is where you have
domination or rather to suji
against the knight the bishop on on
e4 dominates the knight very interesting
two
files between the bishop and the knight
or two
um uh you the the bishop ends up
dominating the knight on the two files
of the two rows
um
nice uh but unfortunately you're right
yeah bishop takes
black doesn't have to comply
uh but at this moment uh no compliance
did this is another one of those moments
uh dorset where it's sort of like you're
winning
you're good you're no no no no you're
great if you're
white and you say okay now's the
finishing touches okay
so
christian
it looks
visually like a cobian has everything
his little heart could desire
uh but what's the finishing touches i i
actually well i'm sure we will uh get to
that in just a second oh sorry you've
got something else i apologize
we have a guest let's go for us that's
exactly why we do
yes
uh let me guess uh could it be a wonder
well you have him on the screen right
now yes sir so that's not a difficult
guess we do have a wonderland he's the
only one who's won his game
dominant victory in his game against
pedro espinoza wonder welcome back to
the show congratulations uh big victory
for you it seems like whenever you lose
a game then you come back with some
devastating revenge the next day is that
how you're feeling as well right i mean
sometimes you lose eight rating points
in one day get 0.8 back so a pretty fair
trade there
um
yeah i mean
i thought today is
fine um i mean i think the game went
pretty smoothly and wasn't really much
to discuss there let's uh look at the
game because it did seem like you
mentioned that you broke through quite
early on um especially after this uh
simplification in the center with taking
on d4 and you got that e5 breaking
is that when you felt like you're taking
over the initiative and the game yeah
i'm not too sure how the opening goes um
i had this against parham magsudu from
the black side and it was very similar
like i just wasn't that familiar with
the plans and i sort of set up in a
similar way he did and he just crushed
me with like d4 and and knight takes d4
i mean not the exact position but the
structure was just like queen 2 rook d1
and there was just no chance at all for
me um yeah i don't know if e5 works at
all i mean i thought knight takes d4 was
quite fine as well but
yeah after e5 it looked
okay and knight 2594 and bishop g492 was
a little important but
i think knight that's why uh knight to
h7 was probably the only way to go for
him
um i mean i think probably e5 is not the
best move because it does allow him some
chances like if he loses the exchange
then
um
i mean there's always
some compensation on the light scores so
right more or less acceptable for him
but the way the game went like after it
takes on
after we simplified all this i mean
um
with knight takes e6 and so on
um yeah this should be
technically waiting for white and
i think he didn't defend in the best way
but
um the conversion was quite smooth after
that i wonder congratulations
important victory for you to try to get
back into the game still two rounds to
go who do you have next
um i think i finished with andrew hung
and bolaji
yeah just looking to play two normal
games i think
um looks like christopher's really
running away with it again i think
i'm not too sure but i thought he was
winning again well speaking of that
let's take a look at that game maybe we
can pull that and uh
gauge your interest in that one
he's definitely not winning he's uh on
down right now
and uh a double pawn on the g file
that's
i don't know it looks pretty good for
black right yeah he's probably seen
better days in this tournament um
yeah i i don't know i think um
yeah as i said earlier like basically i
just want to finish this tournament as
fast as possible
so
yeah i mean
today was good but yeah i hope that i
can keep it up i wonder congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow
good luck
[Music]
and
christopher i mean come on
come on this is a terrible position he's
he's literally two pawns down because
the double g file
double bonds on the g
file uh g5 and g2 are not
good full stop
and after for example i'm just going to
keep my bishop on this long diagonal i
love
the possession of the g7 pawn so long as
i hold that g7 pawn these bonds aren't
going anywhere in the meantime i don't
care how slowly
i have to do it
but i will advance those pawns and yes i
will bring my king to the queen side i
think this is technically winning for
david it probably is guys it's just got
to hold his nerve yes just before we
start analyzing this end game sure we uh
do
very significant uh things are happening
in this game between brandon jacobson
and andrew hong we were looking at this
one and we were saying it's so difficult
to calculate all the precise moves and
actually we were giving a certain line
that you will see in the game happened
remarkable every single move the best
move of the engine by black
has been played by andrew hung knight to
f3
big check knight takes e3 you take one
knight take the other one as well no no
no queen 284 right this is exactly the
line that we looked at queen to g5 check
we're not exchanging the queens knight
to g3 we said that you have to defend
this rook on y8 how do you do that in
the best way and best fashion with
bishop takes h3 this is the position
that we have on the board
andrew huang is just bossing his way
right now towards victory because i mean
what do you do right now okay can we
take it i think one is a problem can we
take the night let's start with the can
you take the knight let's start with the
obvious what if i just take with a rook
okay now i understand there's a
discovered check that's going to destroy
me i got to get my king out of dodge
king h2
king to h2
i'm sensing something
my spidey senses are
you gonna just go like this
did you see how he did that he just held
his finger i mean we were just talking
about it
for you i'm learning
okay let's compare who's worse
christopher
[Music]
his bishop look at that he's got it and
then
we've got
we've got our muscle man
[Laughter]
ah kh2 i think this is a good move also
right
again i'm hunting your king right i
don't know let's see let's check the
yeah this is this is completely winning
bishop completely win there's no way i
mean first of all you cannot get off
this discovery channel right something
is going to give at the same time even
after that you're running into another
discovery chat wow um no this is just
losing bishop takes h3 let's turn on the
engine minus three point one this side
advantage and probably only with like
perfect moves by white bishop to d2
seems the best move so far they have
been playing the best moves after this
knight to g4 came on the board
devastating move by the way i'll take it
back bishop d2 does look like a good
move it does and now i go queen to f6
another important move this game is not
over yet threatening f3 yeah this game
is not over yet bishop takes h3 but once
you play bishop h3 you kind of
understand that you have to couple that
with another uh checkmating idea and
that is queen to f6 getting off the pin
as well so it makes some sense from a
practical perspective also
i mean andrew wow
if bishop d2 queen to f6 comes on the
board it seems like the position is sort
of simplifying and i think black is
going to go on and win this one
without a doubt if you were going to
give a brilliancy prize for the three
events
if andrew finds these moves uh you know
bishop d2 queen f6
i mean it's it's a sparkling attacking
game just wonderful so you're asking for
your surprise
[Laughter]
yeah i think we should definitely get a
brilliancy going there but yeah i mean i
just love what he did knight f3 check
knight e3 bishop h3
he is just playing
superb i mean
it is
wow
okay well keep our eye on this one i
want to go to this
wow this is the seniors game i actually
did want to go to the sofia game for
just a moment
because again i mean
when somebody goes
uh six and oh in a tournament it's such
a rarity let let's be fair and uh so
we left it here
she
uh sophie kept the dark square bishops
on the board she understood that bishop
takes c5 knight c5 will benefit her
opponent the knight will be well placed
on the c5 square so she went bishop d2
attacking the pawn on a5 jennifer said
okay i like my pawn let's keep it
ooh that's a nice little
tickle she wants to come out with a
bishop to g3 so jennifer said i'm going
to stop you all right
g3 the queen goes back and
i don't know if f4 or not was her fear
but she stepped back
f4 knight f6 bishop f3 e5
f5 we caught up with the players how do
you feel about f5
i think it was forced i i mean whatever
happened before
we get to this position the one thing i
don't want to see happen is to capture
and the one thing i don't want to do is
capture and give myself an isolated pawn
so
you know
i'm not a fan
but sometimes enforcement is a force
from the police there was a bishop d2
take maybe i was just trying to activate
those bishops because right now my
bishop is beginning to look a little
sure yeah but i do see g three g4
and potentially bishop will come out to
h4 and or g3 on white's agenda
and from jennifer's point of view okay
this guy looks good this guy looks good
this guy doesn't look good so where is
this guy gonna go and the ideal square
was c5 so
sometimes it happens in chess that
you've got your own pieces are fighting
to occupy the square and
i think in jennifer's case she might be
thinking i would rather have my knight
on c5 than my bishop maybe she'll drop
back with her bishop um but this is a
three result game jennifer's fought her
way back into this game uh finally
another another
yes okay you know i'm not a big fan of
pawn sacrifices unless they're sham
all right sacrifices i guess
i don't think so i'm thinking that uh
that this is the kind of line i was
trying oh there is a knight b3 wait a
minute hey look at that
bishop d4 might work if you take
i could go knight c5 and if you go queen
e3
at the end of the day i've got a fork
on b3
life is so lucky look at this
and yes sir you're you're too tricky i
did i i tricked myself what what about
bishop d4 can i get away with bishop d4
yeah most likely you can of course
because if i can get my knight to c5 i'm
kind of bishop d4 seems like a good move
okay i'm probably not gonna have to take
it
um sorry uh
and well p7 is one of the moves bishop
to d4 both of them
with the upcoming knight to c5 on the
board right so black the advantages
seems like that now once again it's all
about the quality of the pieces and
things have changed
right it was the knight on f6 that was
suffering with the pawn on f3 being
controlled like that the knight on b6
was suffering that knight is becoming
one of the strongest pieces in the
position uh from c5 everything has
changed right at the position this is
why we're suffering this nightly
suffering this bishop on d7 i mean what
can you say about that bishop and now uh
for the current moment uh
jennifer jennifer only has one problem
the knight on c5 transfer to part knight
on d7 transfer it to c5 transfer to d4
she's got no problems all of her pieces
are lovely i love that move bishop d4
you like it i i really like that
motivation before okay it just feels
like that is the right direction in this
position all right and we'll keep an eye
on this one rochelle did she win yet uh
you're waiting huh i i should i've been
wait whoa
[Music]
i know exactly it's like what is
happening here there's like some extra
pawns here and there there's an exchange
there's some extra pawns as well and we
just saw the mcqueen default oh that's a
diamond okay yes if we see queen d5 then
the game is over yeah and we think
speaking of games kind of being kind of
firm please take me where you like to go
um i do recall the seniors no let's stay
with the junior girls though okay
because there's another one that is
about to be over that's talia
talia is also about to put the finishing
touches okay so all the ladies with four
points might be winning today while
sophie is in so well actually
i think we're um in
yes talia's game she does have i mean
i mean look at black's king this is over
okay it was after f4 okay if ellen
responded to f4 with knight d7 and that
to my mind really justifies
talia's decision
because she immediately captured on g5
and placed it up with the rook
rook f5 and i i
can just go one more
can i just eat that e4 pawn f4 can i
just eat e4 yes that's what i was saying
i'm saying after knight d7
talia was justified in her decision you
have to take on e4 right
people should watch more of you no no no
no
no no no but uh this this is all uh
italian yeah no no i mean white is just
winning
i was just thinking the last moment that
black could have done something was just
knight takes that was the critical
moment but well wonderful uh anyone else
winning in the ladies section
a lot of uh i wanted to say that alice
lee some time ago
one upon on e2 remember she posted from
queens
on d5 and she she did it she just ended
up uh gobbling the pawn rook takes a2
queen takes a2 alice looking very good
at this moment
let me make sure
that she's keeping
boy she's playing it really well
she's playing it wow
uh
very well uh
a cute move there
c4 you think i can play knight takes
because the bishop protects no the
bishop's in a pin
so there's no knight takes b4 so you
think to yourself well can i play rook
take c4
no because the knight
the the rook blocked
uh the queen's attack of the night so
this move c4 is a very nice visual
uh taking advantage of two pins i'm
assuming knight e5 is
forced only move
and i'm
thinking
that alice has prepared a combination
beginning with the move
c3 am i right
or
have i missed something
i mean
you gotta take right kind of
okay i was gonna play b3 but now i'm
stuck because i'm looking at rook b2 and
i go what do i do next
i wanted to play b3 hold on okay
could you just take back on c3 if rick
takes my bishop b4 say it again please
so it just takes takes yeah
the problem i had was knight c6 but
that's a four one looks very
uh
yeah that's fair
checking f8 and i understand what you
want to do
you want to capture here and then
capture here yes
i do have this
um yeah it feels like i thought alice
was playing it brilliantly with this
move
uh
c4
but after knight e5 i i'm feeling less
sure after c3 pawn takes maybe bring the
rook first so no knight c6 funny stuff
yeah okay you sidestep the funny stuff i
like that
okay you don't you don't walk into a
fork
obviously you can't take and this is
your big threat
i also eliminate that you eliminate both
rook b2
and
takes is terrible that just invites
bishop takes as well as your rook takes
on um
on
so we think we figured it out christian
uh is alice winning with this nice i i i
don't know i'm being uh struck by light
right now okay you guys are the best
educators
uh some of the best educators in the
world now please educate me on this game
of jennifer eu can you please please
please
by the way it was played all right
jennifer can you please explain to me
this last move of jennifer because
i cannot understand this
she just played g5
she's pulling ah
okay
was she playing a hundredth game bullet
message
i think she was i think that the
explanation is very clear to me she was
playing hyper bullet
until six in the morning
and she hasn't calmed down and uh g7
g5
you know sometimes strange things happen
to you you're sitting at the board
you're analyzing deeply
and then you get
freaked out you see your opponent's
threat
jennifer's looking at the board and
jennifer's saying oh my god this is
terrible my opponent is going to play g4
g5 and blow me off the board
and instead of looking at her own
possibilities of bishop to d4 and knight
c5 she starts getting mesmerized
literally she terrorizes herself that
she's she's going to face g3g5
and this becomes you know her great fear
so she says oh
i've got this great idea i'll stop it
by playing g5 myself and then you get
people like christensen a christian
again i apologize christian said uh you
again people like christian said
christian says it says
what the heck were you doing jennifer
what were you thinking i was afraid of
g5 but you exposed your own king yeah oh
you know you're right
you have the beautiful analogy for
furusa's g5s yes what did i say lifting
commodities you're lifting up your
kimono exposing your king yeah i mean
that is a crazy no no no i christian i
cannot answer next game why why would
you play g5 and that's that's what it is
sometimes you ghost
a threat and you make a move that you
can't even explain to yourself
years later i'll explain it to you guys
please all right all right
here we go there's jenna here
jennifer after 10 minutes of think okay
is playing against her opponent's time
now what is the best way to confuse your
opponent and make her spend a lot of
time is with a move such as g5
that's my official explanation and i'll
stick with it an official explanation
well she did spend four minutes so now
she's down to her last eight minutes and
something so she had 12 minutes
sophie
to answer the move g5 and she spent a
third of her time
well if jennifer's intent
was to make her do that
mission accomplished i hope you enjoyed
my explanation
nobody believed you i thought it was
great
it was great it was great
christian you you you you turned a
desert into an oasis thank you thank you
now guys
another big moment came in this game
between vladimir kopian and maxim belugi
remember the end game i was asking you
how do you put the boom boom
boom boom boom and now if you don't have
bishop take c4 it'll take we take and we
said we stopped here it's over we said
it's over
this is the current position on the
board
uh
what you cannot go back because i take
on d7 you cannot recapture because i
have knight takes c5 that's a double
attack i take i pick up the rook this is
game over you cannot take on e4 because
i mean this is yeah that's right a7 i
take on g7 i do whatever i want a7 is
the juicy one
so you have to take on c6 but now i can
take take and take right and that's the
position we want
this is the position we want the energy
is saying zero zero zero no
why with the idea of the only idea to
get the knight out g6 and knight to f5
and apparently that end game somehow
is a draw
i'm puzzled
i don't believe it i don't want to
believe it i don't want to believe it
either i don't want to believe that this
is a draw but
i guess we will have to wait and see
whether the players have to go for this
rotation has to be played on the board
and then you will have to give up your
knight with g6 and knight to f5 wow
but apparently is just a draw right now
and this would be a miraculous
houdini-like escape for maxim de lugi
now another question is i can also do
this take with a bishop and then go back
to e4 right
so i can do this as well
even though i kind of like this pawn on
c6 and by the way we're hearing that
there's breaking news in the junior
section christopher you in a very
difficult position
seemed to have blundered now the
question is where is the blunder is it
bishop to c3
seems like bishop to c3 bishop to c5 and
now rook to a5 is that is is that it
simple rook to d5 followed by bishop to
b4 that seems to be it
because i don't see any way in which you
can defend this right you have to defend
the bishop somehow there's no other
squares and if you go bishop b6 i take
take and the rook is defended right so
that's a loss
after bishop before well
bishop takes before that's a loss
and bishop to this ah bishop to d6 is
the only move maybe this is what he's
looking at
yes this is what he's looking at okay so
we have to be a bit more careful okay
yeah much simpler
about
attacking two pieces in one move
this is it this is game over right now
goodness after bishop to b4 bishop to c3
might just be uh resignation time for
christopher and what would that mean for
our tournament guys well he will lose
now we still have a bimonu
and uh who else is chasing him is upon
you and then there's oh let's get
standings maybe we can get the standings
i'm trying to remember exactly who it
was but i think it was either brandon
jacobs or or andrew hung brandon if it's
brandon
he's in trouble right it's andrew hunk
who is behind and he's winning
that's going to put andrew half a point
behind
christopher you going into the last two
rounds
christopher came in today's round with a
point and a half lead yes
pieces and the white pieces against his
nearest competitors and we were all
about to
to just present him the first place
trophy and congratulations
but
but
bishop to c3
and uh the tournament flares anew
i mean bishop was tea tree when we talk
about it seems like an easy move but
is that the only move no
but
he played for
this moment oh okay guys okay okay okay
so i understand what the idea is bishop
to c3 the only thing that makes sense
for white to try to continue the game is
take on c3 and take on g7 whoa
and david is not happy for whatever
reason i'm trying to understand why
why is he not happy after bishop to c3
he looks so red
he's very very nervous right now
and the big question is going to be can
you
promote the a pawn just with the help of
the rook
because the king will have to be tasked
with uh stopping the white pawn on g6
from promoting
i'm really confused by
david's um approach his technique in
this game because he played the move
b5b4
and one of the things that happens about
pawn moves
is you can always play them you need to
get your pieces
in their correct positions to support
the pawns it's clear that black wants to
go b5
a5 b4 a4 and promote the pawns that's
really clear but you don't need your
king in fact your king's in the way over
here on the king side your bishop is
doing a great job defending the pawn so
immediately just getting your king and
kicking the rook away would be very nice
so i'm thinking he did all of this
purposefully
uh
to set up bishop c3 because otherwise
his play his previous play doesn't make
sense so i was just kind of being the
sherlock holmes and saying play the move
bishop c3 because everything else
doesn't make sense but how easy is that
end game i'm not convinced that bishop
takes c3 played right away
bishop takes g7
and i assume the king
is going to
keep
the g pawn under
observation yes i have the table base
actually after bishop g7 this is winning
yes
this is winning but it's not easy
it's definitely not trivial
well you put your rook on c2
and you put your king on e6 that that
that keeps the
your king is close to the g pawn right
so i go bishop d4 right now let's take
it one more time
i think it's black to move so let's say
i go rook c2 you don't want to go a5
first
i i'm thinking that more or less i want
to make sure i keep
the white king away from the queen side
by the way just breaking news
rue yang yan has won
her game uh what was the table basis
move i'm sorry uh christian i think uh
a5 is is good good enough a5 is good
enough in that position yes okay
and i was thinking that you kind of just
make sure your king
keeps this pawn from promoting yeah put
your rook on c2
almost every move wins really okay so it
is
a5 king e6 king 7 king d5 king d7 rook
c2 rook a3 all of them are winning
gotcha according to the table base is
there any trick up white slave
i mean again it all comes down to that
end game so let's
look at that end game what if i go a5
let's say bishop to c3 right right
by the way we do have a result rochelle
wu is getting closer
to uh
sophie maurice suzuki with a huge
victory against
gracie
bishop c3 runs into rook a3 christian
and by the way our congratulations to
rochelle because i think that's
back-to-back victories yeah including
over jennifer yes yes you from
yesterday's game so
rochelle uh
climbing back into uh the fight putting
some pressure podium uh you can't play
bishop c3 walks into rook a3 that's a
pin and i'll pick up the bishop oops
and once i take the bishop
oh yes i can contain so bishop c3 is not
the right no now let's say i go bishop
d4 right
okay that makes a lot more sense so
bishop to d4
right and then i
i feel like i've got to keep the pawn
under control so king e7 you don't want
to put the king on e6 yeah well either
one either square f8 or e6 i'm just
going to
leave the king
i'm going to give the king a task all
right stop the prize save my uh second g
pawn by playing the starting with the
move g4 that's am i too late
a star move to be sure so a4 king e3
let's go
uh a4 king e3
and let's
move our rook out of the way let's throw
g7 just to have it thrown on the board
yep
king d3 my table base popped up uh
as well uh what what did you say king d3
king david iii
um
a3 what do you like those apples so you
want to put a pawn on eight why i would
assume right exactly so king c3 right
now okay careful because now i wanted to
now i want to take your bishop i'm
running out of uh squares yes
yes you are this might be the idea of
this end game you're running out of
squares on the diagonal exactly
something like this so now you have to
play well what do you have to do bishop
to e3 let's say let's say bishop summer
i don't know bishop f2 definitely not
because a2 can be true to d2 so that's a
problem okay
oh then you go a2 rook b1
this is a one tempo end game guys
sometimes that's what you need christian
just a tempo you know
your kingdom for a tempo
it's a one temple end game a shakespeare
set
i love it my my my kingdom for a horse
um what's happening in chabalovsky yeah
i think he's kind of faster crazy a
little too busted a little too busty
well
let's let me bring it up on my uh board
and i i'm still amazed what you said
about the the
one more one more that about that uh max
ending uh that that should be drawn
that's like what uh worship all off the
last one
naturally
and uh we left it this was this
beautiful move knight f5 completely
turned to tables
shabbalov was really caught out after
that one 93
knights e2 he won an exchange but what
is really worse
is thanks to this open b file the rook
is actually has a as a straight shot
into white's camp
and would you please please like a draw
no says igor i'm an exchange up why
would i want to draw
and ah this is a great move king d7 love
this move
and black is just taking over every
aspect of the board uh the double rooks
on the open
files uh white's king under pressure
this pawn is a nice pawn
to but i think there should even be
something more convincing threats of
bishop
uh f4 even um looks like it's over i
love how when you see pawns that's the
first thing right
it's training it's training it's
training
no but
truth be told the first things i look at
actually are checks fair i look for
those
it's not that i'm looking for mate but
i'm looking for checks because if a king
is exposed
it doesn't matter if i'm a pawn or a
rook up right like we're seeing in the
andrew uh hung game uh it doesn't matter
if he's worked down if he's
if he's making checkmate it's over but
let's jump to christian uh with a
special guest christian
ryan welcome back to the show
congratulations a big uh victory for you
with the black pieces take us through
the game
um well i think i i like i had like a
good position throughout the game um i
don't really think i messed up that much
anywhere were you surprised by uh her
approach with queen takes d4
early in the year
i was i was expecting another line but
yeah you prepared this move knight to d7
against the rock solid with bishop b5
let's keep going yes
and uh yeah after e5 i was like
originally gonna play e6 and stuff but
like i like like white have some e5
ideas so
um yeah that might be kind of josh later
on and she was playing fast at this
point she was blessing out her moves
were he concerned by her pace at all
uh kind of like she it was she like she
usually doesn't go this line so she
probably has prep for something
but then you took away all the squares
that she wanted to place her pieces on
yeah i think she should have taken the
queen here
yes
yeah
queen takes d5 then
i probably castled i guess
and like bishop e6
and the game goes on it's a very complex
middle game after that anything can
happen but she took with the pawn and
you seemed relieved about this uh
uh situation because now at least you
can get your pawns yeah yeah it's like
it's like kind of like a night of
structure i guess and white doesn't have
like any play at all on the queen side
or i mean she might but like it's good
it's like very hard to create anything
mm-hmm and uh
when were you let's say certain that you
finally took over taking advantage of
knight xd6 uh yeah not a possibility
because of queen to c5 yeah like around
here like e4
um you are feeling good yeah i think
rook d4 was just i think bad
but like but there was like it wasn't
like it was kind of hard to like try
like make decisions around here because
like i had like some uh e3 ideas
and e3 were like
yeah
basically
yeah and she played the rook to d4 which
allowed you
to go queen to c5 set up this nice pin
now you didn't even want to put the pawn
on you yeah you wanted to keep the
position open yeah because like i i've
seen this tactic and she couldn't go
like rick g one because the rook on d4
is just hanging very nice very nice spot
take
and then quickly
well yeah it all looks like a very
dominant victory for you i have to say
uh congratulations an important victory
for you you're finishing up uh with who
i think i have talia
talia okay
so talia is a very close to the
leadership position you might be trying
to play spoilers in that regard good
luck tomorrow uh ru yang and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you congratulations
our congratulations and here are more
results uh
well i wonder leon did win his game and
what a game that was
and he is
coming back with three and a half out of
seven unfortunately a 50 score is
not gonna do it with two rounds left and
uh one uh guy is just running away but
that one guy may be losing today and
and the other result that we had in the
girls section was
ruion yen who was just here for a quick
interview exactly had a very nice
victory as well
[Music]
and finally we do have rochelle wu
winning against gracie and rochelle is
kind of keeping her eye on the potential
no question about it she's saying
jennifer come on you can win you can win
knock sophia down
and we do expect this game too there we
go there we go
nice our producers magnificent right
right
and talia is also on five points i
believe that's right she's got five
points one point behind sophie who's
three seconds
how painful
is that loss that talia had against
alice lee yesterday yeah
she wins today she's got five
congratulations she was winning against
alice completely completely i can't
believe she would be at six
with sophie maybe on the back foot oh
boy uh things are getting very very
spicy in the girls championship i love
how there's just no draws here
just an issue with the clocks
potential
accidental repetition
i
that's your bolo scam
what's happening there guys yeah
it's so rare to see these kinds of
things because
everybody
here is an experienced tournament player
they know
that they know when the equipment is
working a battery or something like that
they feel it
we're going to give everybody an extra
two hours yeah to finish the game
that will work
works for the commentators go straight
into tomorrow's commentary i know how
thrilled we would be by the extra two
hours i'm supposed to be teaching at 6
minutes no way
you can dial it in
dial it in you know say sorry guys
but we do have a guest we'll jump to
christian
rochelle
congratulations three victories in a row
how does that feel you're getting close
to that coveted leadership position
feels good
i mean it could feel better like if i
like sometimes i still think about like
that game that i should have won but
didn't so i was like during my game when
i was winning i was like this could be
five in a row
but it's not
yeah but it's not let's take a look at
uh today's game because i have to say
out of the opening it just felt like you
were completely dominant yeah how you
felt as well um yeah i actually she put
a lot of moves i didn't really expect
because i felt like she was being a
little bit passive um
like how she was developing my pieces
and it felt more like she was going
backwards than forwards
and it was like
did you have this prepared in your notes
or um so i completely mixed up my lines
because
like
i i didn't even really know like i still
have no idea
um i think you were doing just fine i
used to play this h3 g4 line yeah um
okay let's keep going
here i was critical of her decision to
play queen c7 it felt passive i thought
rochelle she her basically her best
chance was to play a4 and queen a5
was that on your radar yeah i i thought
she would do something like that too
yeah because after queen c7 it looked
like she never got back into the game
everything went into your favor
i was really confused by knight b6 i had
no idea what the idea of it was right
yeah of course she has to find a way to
get the b pawn moving right yeah
if she doesn't do that there's no way to
open your position i think she missed
knight b5 here to be honest
like that looks like a very
nice intermezzo
and right now after bishop d7 you had
the knight xd6 was that your plan yeah i
was looking at it um i thought
um knight takes i mean bishop d7 knight
takes d6 she would play like
knight two
oh yeah yeah i was considering rook c8
and i was like if i take on c5 then she
takes on c5
and then queen takes rook c8
that's a that's a cheapo
yeah
i was looking at this i thought she
would go for this
um but maybe
the rook first right knight takes c8
rook takes eight and then just move the
king away
is that enough
yeah i think so
i mean i was not expecting knight d7
though
like
i thought it was just really passive
yeah
it just felt like she played the kings
indian and then she played it too safe
yeah or at least try to play it to save
which never works with the kings
and uh yeah you went on to convert
quite uh smoothly after that
congratulations rochelle you're going
into the last two rounds and by the way
did you have any moments to uh check
your friends game jennifer's no i mean
like when i like browse other people's
games i feel like it doesn't really
register in my head i'm just like
walking around
um i like look at the position for like
a bit and then like i kind of just
forget about it
cool cool well still two rounds to go
still a big chance for you to
potentially get the title good luck
thank you for the games
rochelle uh it's hard work for us it's
hard work for us to be commentators
we're going to invite you
to do our job for us wonderful we want
you
to tell us what you think of the game
between sophia and jennifer
which side you would prefer and why
okay then we're gonna go to sleep
ahead give it your best shot the last
move was
these these were the last moves and you
tell us
if you think jennifer
is your choice
or if you think sophia
position would be your choice
yes or so much pressure i know
and your clock is ticking
[Laughter]
okay i
i feel like i would prefer to be black
here um
like
mike's bishop is kind of
not in the game
like both bishops i guess
um like black's putting a decent amount
of pressure on e4 right
black has more time
i wait is what's the material is it even
yeah yes
yeah i think i would prefer to be black
here
what would you guys prefer we're gonna
we we're gonna invite you to be a
commentator
in the very very near future thank you
and good luck in the championship rounds
coming up rounds eight and nine
wonderful by the way we have another
result i hope
andrew
won his game i believe so yes he did but
the question is did he do it in the
brilliant style
that christian was uh espoused you're
hoping for that bishop
i'm hoping for the brilliancy of the
tournament because he sacrificed not
just one night he sacrificed the second
night and right here
is where we left it
sorry it was right here where we left it
bishop takes h3
bishop to d2 best move
queen f6 best move so he's played an
entire series of bang bang bang bang
bang and he's looking at queen takes f3
bishop h7
whoa
what a move king h8 i don't need your
stinking bishop bishop f5
and
resigns
queen g6 what a victory
by andrew what an important victory over
our number two seed brandon jacobson it
was definitely a beautiful game
and we're hearing that alice lee is also
about to win her game we had left it
oops no that's the uh
she we were looking at this combination
with c3 and b3 and we were figuring it
out and let's see what she did she went
for the immediate rook
and as you have pointed out uh dorsa the
the winning threat for alice is to
capture and capture
rook takes bishop
oh that's nasty she's looking at a
bishop takes g3
she's eyeballing that potential
and look at this white is just pinned up
white can't move
and she just
oh
this is actually a very beautiful
very beautiful game
by alice she's setting up now forward uh
and she didn't
it's already on the board yeah she did
yes yeah came to h1 rook takes c1 and
queen to d5 and that's resignation
wow how to resign i'm not picking up
your rook i go knight f3 next yeah king
how did that believe that
yeah just second let me see if i can
yeah she did
no i cannot do it and
yeah wherever you move the king it's a
royal fork
that's a big victory for alice lee right
fantastic
we have a little extra in our board
some technical difficulties
i've got
i've got i i've got this technical
assistant that you know she's not really
licensed
thank you thank you
and we have a guest with christian
we i do have a guest indeed talia
congratulations a big victory for you
yesterday a difficult game against alice
lee you were all over her and
unfortunately you actually lost that
game but today just like champions do
you came back
quite nicely tell us about that thank
you um yeah the the game yesterday i
feel like i played pretty good actually
for most of the game and then at the end
um i was letting my vintage slip and
then of course i made a blunder and i um
lost a pawn that was supposed to help me
win and from then on it was just so
complex um
i wasn't like a
devastator over it it was more of like a
disappointed but not surprised type of
type of moment but i'm glad that today i
bounce back and i think it was a pretty
clean game most of it absolutely it was
indeed let's take a look at it and it
did seem like you got quite a nice
advantage and you girls were blitzing
out and she was blitzing out her moves
she was i was thinking actually um
because i wasn't exactly sure i think i
played
um this line or something very very
similar last year against alice lee
actually and my position was very
comfortable so i was trying to replicate
that here i think i'm quite okay um h6 i
feel like it helped me because whenever
i do knight takes e5
um now i have f4 and if queen d4 my
bishop comes back to f2 and everything
yes so everything is is clean and you
know i have no weaknesses i even have
bishop g3 if i need to
um so you were feeling pretty confident
by now i was feeling good i loved the
bishop player so i was very looking
forward to this um and yeah so here i
was quite surprised with this with the
decision and i felt like i needed to
play something
quickly i don't know if f4 yeah f4
there is some magic to it i don't know
who it was maybe bronstein or someone
said that f4 is always wrong and it
happens to be my favorite move and every
time i play it is wrong
so
well i know
it says f6 is always wrong
that actually i think was a mistake in
the game but
yeah so f4 i thought that if knight
takes e4 i have um bishop takes
um
and we trade everything on e4 and after
f takes g5 i have ideas of rook d7
so i was looking forward to that i'm not
sure if this is enough advantage
for for the game but i haven't had ideas
of rook d7 and if bishop c8 um bishop c
here bishop c8 maybe i don't know if it
works but maybe rook d8
and bishop f2
or bishop b1 like foreign
right i'm not sure if it works but i was
kind of
also looking at it i guess i had time to
decide like if we were going to go into
this line you were enjoying this uh
prospects against your king yeah i felt
like my position was comfortable i
really wasn't expecting knight d7 it
gave me some confidence
um and here i i feel like my position is
very dominant and after f6 e5 i opened
up the two bishops and
i felt like it was very clear
after that
absolutely uh you converted nicely i'd
really like this move h4 just opening up
absolutely every single line towards
your king the bishops are playing all
the rooks are involved into the game the
queen is coming very very nice
conversion by italia congratulations uh
in the last game we know who you're
playing in the last one
you're playing one sophie morris suzuki
uh but who are you playing tomorrow
tomorrow i'm playing ryan actually rue
yang with the black pieces we actually
chatted a bit with her it's going to be
a big clash in that one so
we'll let you rest get your energy back
up and
come back tomorrow try to make another
push thank you
well done
our congratulations from our panel as i
agree bouncing back after
a painful loss let's face it losing a
winning position is never fun but
bouncing back
yeah that's a really really good sign
well don't tell you as she
was a convincing winner and again i'm
looking at these ladies and it's sort of
like wow
they don't know what a draw is
four out of four in the ladies with one
game to go and let's just jump to that
game because it's our very key game
let's go for it and uh time is a factor
isn't it uh dorsal jennifer seems to
have uh
a little below 10 minutes and sophie
does have
uh 3 minutes and 48 seconds
wait i might be
nope nope nope i'm right on the top
you're good
so after rook d4 uh rochelle did not
give us this specific variation shame on
her
uh as all we asked was that she become
the commentator for a mere 20 minutes
while we took a nap and
things have blown up in this game
yeah what do we got we still have
material equality but it feels like
jennifer
this bishop is
really dominant
first of all
and it protects a coupon and the more
i'm looking at it she's taking over dark
squares it's like you've got this pardon
me not you but uh
sophie has this light squared bishop
which
well
it's nothing it's a
it's an open diagonal and moves like
rookie 8 and queen e5 it feels like
jennifer is sneaking into the position
now from white's point of view wait a
minute you lifted the kimono right
shouldn't i be able to play queen d2 and
checkmate so
who do you like and uh
what's going on i'm not the biggest fan
of those that that h4 bishop it's just
not really clicking with me but it can
it the thing is it's it's the bishop's
option to try to trade or not right
that's fair so that makes me think
should we move that mission that night
away at some point it's like something
like a knight h7
because okay let's say we go here all
right i think that was actually what was
played and then the queen eyeballs the
square now there's two things we can do
to stop the queen
we can drop a rook in on e3
which i like a lot right so that just
takes away this move
or we can drop a bishop
in on e3 also which was played in the
game
oh okay sorry
no no no
i'm catching up with the players sorry i
didn't realize that uh
what are the what the clock times again
uh jennifer are you eight minutes and
counting uh sophie three minutes 54.
three minutes and they're bottom they're
they're almost there they just need two
three more moves okay
so
time isn't that big a factor at this
moment then
another guest ready for it i'm not sure
i am but let's uh
let's toss it to christian
andrew we're ready to give you uh the
game of the tournament uh how do you
feel about such a game
um
i mean when he played this rook fd1 it
just looked totally wrong because
he's moving a rook away from a king's
side i has very little to know defenders
so i thought like i didn't calculate
everything all the way obviously but i
assumed knight g4 i mean something has
to be working there for black did you
check this line before the game or did
he surprise you with this taking on d5
and queen c2 which is quite popular
nowadays oh he surprised me with this on
92 bishop d2 idea um
i wasn't exactly sure what to do but i
just try to play natural like 97 c5
looks pretty good for black and um and
what i got in the game was pretty
comfortable because uh this with the
isolated pawn the knight on e2 is
totally misplaced and he obviously has a
lot of weaknesses around his king the
knight coming in g4 sometimes absolutely
and he played this move knight to g4 and
now he played this move bishop to e1 you
spent a lot of time at this point trying
to make queen to h4 work
did you see everything from afar
how did you come to the conclusion that
you have to go for queen to h4 and did
you see
all the ramifications after that knight
to f3 knight take c3 and so on yeah i
mean when i played knight g4 like i i
had already seen this quit h49393 idea
very quickly but it's not so clear which
makes it very hard and by the way black
has other options like not h2 and or
like after qh4 h3 for instance you can
start from 93 and then knight f3 that
was
the moment that we thought that you
might get a bit confused yeah but yeah
yeah we have to yeah i tried to be very
precise my calculations but i think the
knight of 393 is the best and others i
didn't see anything clear so here
the gf393 um queen a4 check i mean 24
queen g5 track knight g3 um again it's
very tempting to play bishop d7 here um
it's a very forcing line
but it seems like white holds on for
instance queen takes d7
um knight takes d1
and there's this move king g2
uh i think this was his idea and white
is holding on for instance rook takes e1
um rook d1
uh bishop f2
uh what they are queen e3 queen you want
me but there's queen g4 here and that's
looks like why is just holding on so i i
just assumed that bishop takes h3 okay
first of all um i didn't see a clear
defense for him but like i just i
thought like even if he had something
here i married i have two pawns
and his like king side cover has been
completely blown open so it must be good
for black no matter what also might as
well get another mechanism of queen f6
queen takes f3 around the king right
checkmating mechanism yeah this bishop
d2 defense i saw but queen f6 looked
pretty good for black so you know and i
think you were actually very very
precise with this last few moves so was
he after bishop to e1 he was making the
best defensive moves uh but you just
kept on piling on the pressure and it
was just too late after bishop e1 queen
to h4 was just a crushing victory for
you congratulations andrew and right now
i'm sure you're keeping an eye on that
game between christopher you and david
brosky what do you think of the game um
i actually haven't taken a look
so not too sure what's going on well
we're trying to get some new
commentators yes
let's take a look
we're recruiting let's take a look at
that game
right now and maybe you can give us your
assessment
the one between christopher you and
david brotzky there it is
is he in time
or is he not
um
i would say it's probably a draw i think
probably a draw interesting um yeah
yeah because usually
um usually with the the side pawn like
the h pawn or a pine is winning um if
you cut the king on the b file but but
here you need like the king to you need
the black's king's help to like force
luxon with the white bishop but here the
king is tied down can we force suicide
oh wait i'm not sure it
seems to me like it looks like a pretty
simple draw for white so actually let's
keep the rook on
right b8 or b7
and then maybe get the pawn to a4
so how do you how what do you play first
king security right rook to b7 yeah king
c2
so you want to stay on c3 and c2 i just
don't see what black is doing here
if you do go a4
that king c3 can you see three and now
after rook to b3 you go king to c2 not
king to c4 now
and what if i go with the rook to g3
oh yes this is yeah this is win yes we
know that
um so after king to c2 what if i go rook
to g3 and try to come with the king now
oh wow
i actually didn't think of
this but how do you make progress
i just just wait kingdom it's always a
good question
because the bishop is taking the b4
square so uh i can put you in a sus one
though so i go king c4
and now i give you a check and if you go
to a3 i go king b5 that's insane so you
have to go on the first round but now
it's with king b3
maybe it's a win
let's check the
table base
right before you live
it's a it's a win okay i'm wrong um
it's it's a win we did not uh no we know
we knew before
we knew before that it's a win but it
did feel like white is making some
progress nevertheless he still uh seems
to be losing now
if he loses that's going to take you
half a point behind him with two rounds
to go how do you feel about your chances
i mean a half point lead with like two
two rounds ago is a pretty sizable
advantage to himself not expecting too
much and he's been playing very well
this tournament um i've had some very
shaky moments um had a
very avoidable loss against christopher
played terribly against abi and
against carissa i almost didn't win so
i've had my shaky moments this
tournament so honestly i'm not expecting
too much but i mean it's always nice to
get back on track with two wins
absolutely congratulations andrew and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you very
much andrew just two two quick comments
uh you were wrong about the analysis but
nonetheless we still want to trade you
for alejandro you're in you're in you
you you you passed you passed next
next next really i cannot let this
moment go without saying you played a
brilliant game today an absolutely
brilliant game and keep that kind of
form up you may be on the podium
good luck in the championship rounds
yeah thanks so much
absolutely wow what a great surprise
[Laughter]
i don't know but i'll
have to think about it
um
what's happening in jennifer's game
all of the
seniors are still playing by the way
boy what it
no i like jennifer's position
if
if i were in jennifer's shoes one of the
one of the things i would love love love
to do is to actually trade these bishops
oh in other words if i could go queen
here and then follow it up with
bishop h
bishop pardon me g5 trade off this
bishops i would like to play knight
versus bishop
because i'm thinking i could then play
h5
sorry i'm just thinking could there be
like a bishop takes off sequence yes you
could do that some stuff oh wait wait
the rook is hanging sorry i can't do
that
sorry i can't hang my rook oops
so that's wrong
uh
oh then i can't
oh
okay
no king h6 bishop f6 and i'm still
hanging the rook
guys yes
so i got some uh
information actually about uh that game
and that moment in shabala versus
malinitsky okay apparently what happened
was
igor at this point played the move queen
from a6 to d8 oh and pressed the clock
when he meant to play queen ceo he
wanted to play queen to c8 which he did
in the game but apparently he played the
illegal move queen from a6 teleported it
to d8 nice and you know what happens you
get two extras some extra time exactly
two extra minutes
but such a an interesting occurrence in
uh the seniors competition
wow did you ever make an illegal move oh
yeah oh yeah cool how many times
not in the recent years but
i mean
i i know i've done it
okay and i've had it done for me and i'm
like
that's time more time for
free and christian you you've made
illegal moves no i don't think i did no
never never as a kid
maybe when i was like
very young
very very young or maybe in some blitz
competition that i cannot remember uh
but i don't think i've made them
um i think the funniest for me was this
was an asian new championship 2011 which
was in
philippines for me um
so
i start you know i have the board i'm
prepared and i go and i'm ready to play
and you play females and i go yes my
king
and both both kings and i was like wait
no no sorry not mine hers hurricane and
i was like okay do i want to continue
this or
so we called up the arbiter and it's
like okay what do we do because this is
not chess right and he was like start
from the top and i was like no this was
my preparation and then she knew what i
had prepared because i already played it
out and i was like ah
oh no
and we have more results coming in in
this round seven uh dorsa take it from
the top who do you got talia did win her
game against ellen wang that was a nice
win moving her to five out of seven and
looking hungrily what's going on in uh
jennifer's game and andrew hong also did
win his game against uh brandon jacobs
really and save the tournament if you
ask me the yasser press yeah big answer
and
zooey unfortunately well not
unfortunately
she's having a bad tournament yes
unfortunately
lost to
alice lee and ellis lee is with us in
the studio so let's go and
welcome her
thank you dorisa alice congratulations
you're starting to string some victories
together how do you feel about your last
couple of games yeah i mean of course
the previous game it was kind of
unexpected that i was able to win
but
speak at that end game i seem to be kind
of losing but this game i thought it was
um
i thought that i kind of was pressing
the entire time
so like out of the opening i was able to
win a pond and i was able to keep it
there was a moment like later where i
felt that
my position might not be winning
that was later when like
so
i think i knew all this up to bishop d2
that was still your preparation yes yeah
i'm not sure because i think after b3 i
was planning to play knight b6 but
uh bishop d2
um
bishop d2 knight b6 i wasn't sure
whether it was as good but i think it
was okay
um
and after a takes b6 rook c1 queen d5
now she could play b3 but like i don't
think she really wanted to because i
might be able to win the a2 pawn and
it's always a long term weakness
and in which case the b3 pawn would be
really weak
so she decided to sacrifice it
with 91
and uh at this point you're already
feeling quite good about your chances i
would assume right yeah um
after
queen d5 and she was able to play this
f3 move um
here i didn't like my position quite as
much because
i think if like knight f6 and
e4 and uh it looks like i'm losing the
pawn
um
but
uh so like knight d6 of course the c5
pawn drops so i have to play knight g5
but now my nike knight is really
awkwardly placed
after e4
queen deforza king g2
and then i played rook d8
i'm not sure whether it was good or not
but i think it was okay
after knight f4 oh yeah uh i was
expecting her to play h4 maybe um
maybe knight f2 not f2 here okay
and it looks like yeah now she's
threatening h4 and she might have some
rd1 ideas where my queen is kind of
awkwardly placed but i think i was
calculating that i should still be able
to keep the pawn
after here
i wasn't sure whether i was winning or
not because i guess she could have
exchanged queens
i'm not sure how good it would have been
but if she exchanged queens i think she
could have tried to
mute the fact that my c5 pawn is weak
and my knight is out of the games and
her knight is also still good so she can
try to like maybe win the c5 pawn uh do
work b5 and then like try to harass my
b-pan with a rook and knight
[Music]
and then you guys
went into this uh
variation kept a lot of pieces on the
board but at the same time a lot of
things unfortunately for her for zoe
they were going quite wrong and she was
up a pawn but unfortunately all her
pieces are in very very bad shape right
now
now uh
you came up with this idea of rook 31
and queen to d5 finished it off nicely
congratulations uh alice now uh tell us
a little bit about your show what's
happening with alice's pawn palace while
you play these tournaments do you still
do the show in between games what's uh
what's the status of that um well
usually uh i do the show like once every
few months
but i i am mostly focusing on this
tournament so i'm not doing it during
the game but i'll probably do one
hopefully soon after the tournament
well big congrats from us and all the
panel string those victories and we'll
see you in the championship rounds thank
you
well done well done very well done
and i just want to sorry i i wanted to
turn our attention to the jennifer
uh versus
pardon me sophia's game versus jennifer
because
they were about to make time control and
i think they just did
and
queen bishop c5h3
wow that is a very strange move for me
opening up
the king side takes takes and we are up
to date with the players i'm not really
loving this for white
uh okay but uh what if i'm gonna go for
it guys
what are you going for queen d2
all right so first of all i don't think
i can take the pawn right so queen d5
you
likely have to go bishop to g2 i cannot
take on f5 is that correct
i i'm with my calculator
that's that's one of the problems yes
f1 i think was another problem but
that's a bigger problem speaking of your
rook on e8 instead of moving the coin
just bring the rook to e3 start poking
g3 start poking so that makes a lot of
sense i love that movie that's when
yes you're a mizzou tiger get it right
you don't actually have a shirt i might
bring that to another no more billikens
[Laughter]
by the way the more i'm looking at
rookie three the less and less i'm
liking sophia's position
i think i mean you see a lot of dark
squares that are being dominated by
black's pieces again i do think that
queen d5 check
knight e4 starts to look very
threatening
i'm liking this for jennifer how are the
computers liking this it's looking
really good this h3 was a big mistake
was it a big h3 was indeed a big mistake
and it does seem like after this move
that you proposed dorsal root to e3 very
precise move now putting a lot of
pressure not only that but also there's
no more bishop takes f6 and queen takes
e8 right this is looking good
h3 was just a bad move at the same time
the position is not easy this position
is not easy you know uh which player
stands better right now and that is
journey for you you have so much control
over the central files you cannot
contest those uh the queen on the eight
as well as the rook on e8 on the central
files and this gives uh black the
advantage outside of that i don't have
that many weaknesses nevertheless
my control of the central files is quite
important h3 was just a mistake the
wrong
side of the board that you're trying to
play on this actually weakens your king
because it weakens the square
g3 as well as the square g4 so imagine
once i get this rook to e3 the rook uh
the queen off the spin and then a knight
potentially coming to g4 wow circling
around your king well you're in deep
deep danger right now it's looking
really good for jenny for you and what a
result
that would be and what that would mean
for the tournament again uh sophie
coming in today's round with a two-point
lead over the field she's just rocking
the ramparts
on her way to the coronation and then
it's a
pickup leader
right not a good thing to be a
tournament leader exactly
christopher you still at the board but
we think it's a table-based win uh i
also wanted to just mention that we do
have a final results in the legends
section
um
so he also was a tournament leader right
yes well one of the three yes
and uh again uh
dimitri coming in with the white pieces
with four tied for first loses to
gregory kaidanoff who had two and a half
gregory is certainly happy with his
victory strangely enough i thought that
was game was headed for a draw and
another result oh another justin yeah
justin wings
mishra mishra was tied for second i
believe so now he's
everything is changing so hard to keep
track wow
and we have christian with a guest
gregory i expected to see you much
earlier here in the studio difficult
tournament uh for you but you're finally
back to 50 percent
how does that feel to win again
i mean it feels good to win the first
game in the tournament but obviously
yesterday's game was very upsetting i
had a huge advantage against alex
shabolov and just completely lost the
threat of the game and
lost the game was very upset so it feels
good to get back to winning ways how did
you come back psychologically from that
what did you do last night um
nothing special
basically
just uh
you know come down and
whatever happens happens when when you
play black against a good player uh very
rarely you can just you know like play
for a win and win
right um i
uh learn hard way that when i play too
aggressively with black pieces i lose
quite often so today you know i
didn't have winning expirations but
um
got equal position after the opening and
slowly slowly dmitri was making small
mistakes and
and actually i think yasser if i'm not
mistaken was calling the trend of the
game that is going towards the grand
master draw
after the opening phase but
you took the bull by the horns at some
point where did you feel like you're
gaining the initiative
um
it happened slowly i i don't think it
was uh
you know just one move but
um i think when dmitry played b3
uh i mean first of all when his knight
got on d1 this was already
um quite an accomplishment for me so
um yeah when
all those moves were played
um and he played knight d1 that's
already
a moment when i feel like i already have
an advantage maybe not a big advantage
but this knight has hard time to come
out knight on g2 is also not good
um and then it's already difficult to
play for white probably with a very
accurate play
uh he can get out but bishop d4 was a
huge mistake so perhaps was bishop f4
the right move instead of knight d1
just try to harass the queen and
but then
i could go to h5 and then the pawn only
two is hanging so you still have another
square to keep connection with the pawn
on e2 very nice right and after knight
to a2 queen takes c2 knight takes b4 you
also pick up the b2 right right right so
it's not like knight d1 was a bad move
and i do it's the point is that after he
played 91 i already felt good maybe it
was a bad symptom right right right
maybe maybe he made some mistakes
earlier in the game
i'm sure he did but
i don't know exactly
you know when and where but
yeah and
yeah and and now his pieces are so
passive that it probably already a
winning position for and you are also
putting a lot of pressure on his time it
seems at this point he only had six
minutes on the clock gave the b3 pawn
had to give you the b3 pawn to get the
queen back into the game
uh
any other critical moments and maybe we
can still keep going i'm not sure why we
went back
i was thinking i wanted to ask gregory
uh
if white could have
taken this pawn
was there a chance for
for him
or you didn't
take on before yeah
it was kind of complex so
uh if white plays queen shakes before
uh
rook b8 uh doesn't work because
white plays knight d4
um
and queen twin takes g2 king cheeks g2
um rook takes b4
knight c6
bishop shakes c5 knight shakes before
bishop shakes before white shouldn't
have any problems i don't think black
has problems because uh
you know i can put knight on d5 at some
point yeah it should be close to equal
yeah yeah
and knight d5 f5 and something like that
and it should be about equal
however uh instead of rook b8 i can play
bishop shake c5 so knight b5
queen shakes b4 bishop cheek c5
and that's tricky
so queen
uh
where does the queen go queen c4 bishop
jakes of chuck winning the queen
so that doesn't work
um
queen
uh okay let's go bishop cheeks e5 yeah
queen a4
now i play rook a8 first
uh
forcing queen to b3
and now rook b8 and now rook b8 and now
knight d4 doesn't work because of bishop
d4 so
that's the line i calculated and it
looks like it works
that's your story and
you're sticking with it
just just wanted to make sure you had
calculated it to the very end gregory
you know keeping you on your toes well
done nice testing the players i see
right uh your overall i mean you've had
seven rounds underneath you you feel
rusty you feel good you're happy to be
playing chess greg uh i'm kind of
playing chess i'm not happy that i'm not
playing well as especially as well as
the last year so right
right yeah defending your title you're
here to defend your title sorry
yeah but maybe it's a little bit too
late
running out of road
right i'm already thinking about next
year
[Laughter]
right it's always good to see you uh
good luck in the remaining two rounds
thank you very much cheers
man these games
i do think we might have two results
coming up in the season okay
just just looking at us
first things i wanted to look at was the
chapal of
okay because that was the crazy game yes
but the black king
if i told you that king walked to a5 and
then walked back would you believe me
nobody would believe you but it did i
saw that somehow the king did get to a5
and uh now it somehow scampered all the
way back i have to say i love it when
it's like i have all the time in the
world i'm just gonna move my king up
there eat the pot i'll just come back
exactly no problem still advantageously
it's just wonderful white is just so
um
busted after that knight f5 move yes way
back when
that it just doesn't really
matter but it goes to show that the
still work for igor i mean he's he's
certainly winning
uh but he was winning 10 15 moves ago
but he still has got to uh reel the
point home again this was the game where
ego went queen on a6 to d8 i have to say
i was looking through the youtube chats
for a little bit that somebody was
mentioning something about who how
somebody else sort of gm norm by making
a
accidental illegal move moving brook and
then castling and nobody said anything
opponent forgot he forgot he made a gm
in that tournament i have no idea who it
was i was just uh skipping through the
chat to see who said what but and there
is a social media there so if you want
to reach out and ask anybody on our
panel any questions you can do that
through the social media i just want to
say i i'm sure i did it more
but i've made quite a number of illegal
moves my favorite illegal move
was i was queening upon
against international master john watson
at the american open a very prestigious
tournament and i was in the cat i was
trying to win a class prize and
john wasn't doing that well in the
tournament but
i got a bad pairing so international
master john watson i was trying to
promote my pawn
on the queen side he was coming at me on
the king side
and then he gave me checkmate
queen h7
checkmate
and i didn't know what to do so i kinged
my pawn i promoted my pond to a king and
i pressed the clock
john
no problem he took my king
on g8
the game continued for another 10 moves
all of his pieces that were mating me on
the king side came back and made it my
newly promoted
king
this was a real game yes
the american open
it's a very prestigious tournament the
extra king he just took us from the next
class yeah well there were these boards
next or so
i
and you know i congratulated him he
signed my scoresheet everything was nice
yeah he checkmated me twice in the same
game
and i took my scoresheet home to seattle
and i showed everybody the game
and the fact that he checkmated me and
then i promoted and they all started
laughing i said well why are you
laughing he said well the game's over he
checkmated you i said no we played
another 15 moves they said yes sir
checkmate ends the game
i go no it didn't
nice
and what happened in christopher you
christian
did while brock's
[Applause]
look at that smile wow look at that
smile this engine started yesterday huh
boy what a victory boy does that shake
up our pairings oh i mean our standings
i mean
christopher is still going to be
half a point ahead but
that opens
up the whole the whole tournament yes
who do you want to look at next i'll
tell you who should we look at guys
because there are some incredible
developments that are just happening
right now in this game between vladimir
akopian and maxim lugi so we got to this
end game right i think we left it
somewhere around
this place
and it was actually not rook takes d7
that akopian decided to go for but b
takes c6 first now this is a little bit
of a different situation because after
rook takes d3 which has to be played you
cannot allow the rooks to stay on the
board
c takes d3 is an option and it's we're
dealing with a different structure this
pawn on d3 will be able to potentially
stop any pawn on any pawn coming on e4
upon avalanche that black is going to
engage in let's see how we got to where
we are right now king d6 king to c3 a6
king to d2 trying to go to this side now
h5 was a very good move you cannot take
on h5 you don't want to take on h5
because if you do that the knight is
going to escape get back into the game
with knight to f5 at the cost of a pawn
i will gladly take that trade with the
black pieces keep the pawn on g4
take take g6
don't go g5 because if you go g5 then
the knight will uh not land on f5 as
easily now knight to f5 is definitely a
move that you have to keep in mind
bishop to h1
king to c7 king to c3 and now we have
this few moves finally white decides to
break with the move a5
take take
g5 was the right move the only move in
the position to actually maintain
equality g5 forced the bishop to get
back to e4 and now knight to f5 and
everything is coming with tempo
this is the point of this sequence
everything is coming with tempo so i'm
winning some time with black pieces take
take now if you take on f5 i can just
simply take on c6 you take on a6 i'm
going to put my king on d4 and then i'm
going to use this
g pawn
i didn't even know if it's b or g this
is a g pawn uh i'm going to use the g
pawn as a decoy i'm going to sacrifice
that then pick up the pawn on d3 that's
going to be an easy draw so
he did not play the move g5 he played
the move knight f5 first but after g
takes f5 g takes a 5. once again
critical moment right now there is only
one winning move in the position only
one winning move in the position
it's not king takes a6 which is the
automatic
it is the automatic but after e4 this is
just a draw you take i take if you go uh
e5 i am going to corral that pawn king
c5 king d4 king takes c5 and if you take
i go king to d6 f6 and now you get e5 in
and king to e6 there's no way for me to
stop uh at that point and if you try to
defend it the problem is i'm too fast
i go e4 and i'm too fast so g takes f5
right now on the board and the right
move is bishop to f3 now what's the
difference
e4 take you take i take
you go here right
now i go f6 you go e5 and now you have
now i go f7 you go k7 now i go bishop d5
and my king is ready to capture this
pawn and this bishop will take care of
the a6 and bishop f3 was just bishop f3
was oh my goodness he found it bishop
there's a reason he found it
exactly
very nicely done by vladimir
and here we're expecting vladimir to
capture on f5 and follow it up with the
f6 move yes f6 and bishop d5 that's yes
that's really beautiful it's it's
incredible
yeah as the king is
inside the box
uh too beautiful beautiful ending i'm
going in my studies
now you might be wondering why not the
bishop on g2 right right because i mean
why bishop f3 are not the bishop to
g2 and let's take a look at this one
take take
take on e4 take on c6
and maybe we can do that on your board
guys yeah i got it
[Music]
so you just uh we need the analysis
board just to
show yes there it is so i put the bishop
on g2 not on f3 i did it just for you
christian mm-hmm and keep going
g2 you take on f5 now i go king d7
king d7 exactly oh the bishop
now after f6 i go king to e8 with the
bishop on f3 you can stop my king from
approaching your pawn with bishop to h5
right and then you're going to pick up
a6 and then catch the pawn
with the bishop on g2 you cannot do that
so bishop
finds the right move
and will take the full point in this one
there is no more complications left on
the board it's obvious right now as your
simple mathematics and ocobium has
everything sorted out and this is huge
because once again jacobian is is
defeating one of our tournament leaders
coming into today's round
max will lose along with dimitri ocobian
will leapfrog those two players which
means can larry christensen
hold on to the lead with a draw who
chose a copian as a winner
who
somebody might must have done it in our
prediction i pick joel i'm way out of
this
i'm not even in this uh
uh and larry is actually
he's in a king and pawnee end game
where
his opponent igor
has double pawns which is the usual
indication
that advantage larry sorry i just wanted
to mention you man you said you picked
joel benjamin to said that he did win
his game today he did yes okay finish
the against nick the fermion
i saw that he was a pawn up
but that's not even getting him back to
50 i think joel is suffering at minus
one i could be wrong on that uh but okay
larry is a little bit
better
um
no this must be a drawing
uh what what what's going on christian
what did the engine say about this one
well let's take a look guys yeah um well
black is better right yes uh how much
better is the question that's the
question right can you find the
breakthrough right now let's say bishop
to c4 and where is the breakthrough i
wanted to ask is the king and pawn in
game winning which one ah after knight
takes b5 right yes yes yes this seems to
be mathematically winning wow so
it's a big moment by the way because you
can easily get tempted to play this one
the problem is that once i establish uh
the opposition with the move king to d5
is going to be very difficult for you to
maintain uh the position as it is for
example king to e3 i can start with the
move f5 king to d3 and then f4 once
again taking advantage of the fact that
i have so much space on this side and a
way to uh pretty much mess up your pawn
structure on the king side if you take
take and the king invades to g3 that's a
problem and if you don't then i mean
you're just simply losing in this one so
knight takes b5 i have a feeling we're
not going to see and by the way another
important variation after knight takes
b5
and f5 if you do try to close up things
with the move f4 the problem is i have
an extra bullet left
g6 cool and this wins the game because
now you have to choose a side if you go
to c3 i go to e4 if you go to e3 i go to
c4 so if right now it was black to move
um if right now it was black to move if
it's black to move then it's a truck
right
you don't have any moves you have to go
back and then i go back and then
whenever you uh go to d5 i'll meet you
on d3 yeah that's i'm going to establish
whoever establishes the opposition at
this point
when what white draws the game and black
wins the game okay so let's assume
therefore that igor has to play the
movie king e3
i thought larry would play bishop to f1
and provoke the king
back to g2 uh back to f2 sorry what am i
saying right you can go king to f2 i
which in fact would probably be a bad
move right yeah and then i wanted to ask
you could you go that is a winning the
the king and that is the winning
position yes
so king to f2 is in fact a bad move so
after bishop f1 you don't play king f2
no okay no no
no and
now the question becomes can you
establish some sort of a fortress with
the move f4
f4 check i assume i have to move my king
i don't know let's say and now king f2
right
to f5 and now king f2 now i drop my
bishop back let's say i go king f3
king f3
so hmm
what should what do you think dorsa
don't you kind of get the feeling that
you're you're doing the magic and
wow and you're doing something good with
uh
larry but by the way we do have a result
akopian did win his game was a very nice
when i have to say i thoroughly enjoyed
that bishop f3
um
and
it's just
it's just so wonderful to see we're
sitting here trying to understand why
engine is saying what he's saying and
these players playing
bishop of three boom ready to go very
beautifully done that was study like
victory right
yes um i'm warming up to the position
for larry and by the way should larry
win then he would take a clear half
point lead going into the penultimate
round um but how realistic is that how
how about the fortress that you were you
were about to show as christian well
let's keep going
so we're expecting king e3 by igor we
understand that this is a losing king
upon endgame i want to play gift be the
pawn king f2 we think is losing because
of king d4 so we have to first drive the
king away with a check
and then drive the bishop away with
let's say bishop back
pardon me king back to f2 and then the
bishop comes
back to this diagonal
exactly so let's go king to e3
that's fine three you'll attack my pawn
on g2
or g3 okay stay there yeah either way
let's let's do it yeah
and you're going to stay here
so your knight is stuck
your king is
well kind of stuck can i can i break
through
i don't know let's let's give it a look
see i i don't see it
uh where do you stay with your king
let's say king ji won
okay and let's say i go
here that's okay let's exchange that
and let's say you come back with your
king
and now can i
go you're you're definitely getting
close
closer definitely getting close
yeah yeah yeah one of my favorite scenes
from movies i'm a big big big movie fan
uh we talk about memory i have a
fantastic
really it's crazy
movie recall
and one of my favorite scenes from
silence of the lambs was anthony hopkins
going closer
you know she's she's got to show her
her id so the king is getting closer
king king d4 king c4 we'll keep an eye
on this one as christians with a special
guest well first of all i'm going to
have nightmares after that hearing you
saying closer closer and yes
i don't want to see you uh tonight
anywhere close to me
we do have david brodsky back to back
victories david against the wonder the
rating favorite as well as christopher
you the leader by far of the tournament
you just simply blew this tournament
wide open how does that feel it feels
great well that's what christopher did
last year when he beat hans in round
eight
so yeah now i've
i'm here to spoil the tournament with
the black pieces and you did now tell us
a bit about the preparation that went
into this game because you guys uh went
into this very topical line very main
line of the open ruy lopez and it felt
like he surprised you
i was the one who was supposed to
surprise him because i haven't played
five in three years
so
i had was preparation was quite quite
interesting because i just
i i spent a lot of time brushing up on
on stuff and i didn't even i wasn't even
sure i'd play e4 so
and then i came to the board and i was i
don't really remember anything here i
know just know there was some type of
tabai game
and the engines say it's about equal
exactly it's kind of a novel uh approach
by white to give up the exchange like
this but a very dangerous one now knight
to c4 seems to have been maybe even
novelty queen takes d1
was uh the move played previously queen
takes the one rook takes one knight c4
and then played just uh that end game
how did you feel about this end game and
why did you shy away i wasn't sure okay
let's say bishop c1 yes and rook d8 and
rookie one and it remains a very complex
yeah
white is looking quite well yeah i don't
like this
uh but okay i remember that in the tub
at a game there was some weird
repetition but white declined and ended
up losing i i'll need to look at that
because i was just blanking here
and he chose to play this move knight to
c4 queen to e2 came this seems to have
been the first move that surprised
christopher
queen d7 how did you uh come up with
this concept of trying to kill the queen
centralized
well i mean he wants to he wants to do
something to my to my king side and i
also have to worry about the c4 knight
because okay
if if he plays something like bishop f4
and b3 then my knight's getting
my knight's getting kicked out i mean i
was originally thinking i'd take on e3
queen takes e3 queen d7 something like
this
i wasn't so sure it's just okay i think
he probably
might still go bishop f5
this is very very complicated queen d5
and now okay if he can just get the rook
to the h file i think he's mating me
exactly more or less exactly i'm not
sure if he can do it so g3 yeah gci
something you just play something like
g3 and
yeah i don't know like it's not coming
too fast but i'm not sure what to do
with how can you stop it yeah how do i
stop it yeah exactly so i thought okay
i'm going to go queen d7 without which
is you know
i mean i obviously want to centralize
mcqueen if i want to stop the attack and
i'm also attacking g4 i mean okay
there's bishop h7 that's a queen sack i
wasn't sure what's happening there but
yeah i expected bishop of five queen d5
and i was very surprised that he let me
play knight takes b2 exactly i was like
he usually doesn't blunder like this and
i think it was a shocker when you play
the move knight b2 for him as well he
seemed uh destabilized at that point
yeah i know this is this is my whole
idea basically then queen d5 which
before knight takes b2 and if bishop
before i'd go we should d4 i'd go c5 and
i think i'd give back the exchange
you should do four c5 bishop e4 and just
give up the exchange yeah queen e6 let's
say
okay bishop a8
now
yeah i can i can take an eight or i can
take an d4 i think take on d4 is better
taken d4 so if knight d4 queen h6
that that's just a piece right that's a
piece yeah
so he has to go somewhere with the
bishop let's say bishop e4
after cd4 bishop b4
okay i'm gonna
take in c3
if he plays bishop of five i have the
intermezzo cb2
it's a it's a funny one so bc3 and then
i thought okay queen
no no if 95 then
but i can take on g4 instead
well that's good that should be fine
this should be fine like equal material
i haven't noticed knight on c4 yeah i
don't see the i mean it's good for me
and what if he plays g3 instead of
bishop f4 did you calculate this uh oh
just just very just slow g3 maybe that's
that's probably the engine move right i
have no idea actually
okay what happens if i take an e5
wait well that's a good question
it's just losing from playing
maybe it is yeah yeah this is funny you
know rook d1 almost tries my queen but
i'm knight takes e3 in this position i
don't know if you can exploit that
somehow very nice it takes e3 and okay
quincy
i can also go queen c4 if i want to
control things but actually yeah i can
take a free pawn why not
excellent and he played this move bishop
to f4 and after knight to b2 you guys
entered this very uh almost forced
sequence yeah 95 like i thought it was
good for him but i underestimated 95. i
thought he's gonna take an f7 bishop e6
but then okay he doesn't have the bishop
pair
now one thing about knight five and the
exchange of the queens and then you guys
got this position after bishop actually
h1 you started shaking your head here
you seem distressed i don't know what
was the reason well actually i'm okay if
we go back even bishop f6 was not an
easy move to make so first of all
there's there's something very funny
originally i thought if he goes f6 that
he just takes and sees if i play f6 i
thought originally okay he takes in c6
and he has good compensation but i
realized that no he can actually the
bishop h7 king h7 rook h1 king g8 knight
g6 oh let's go oh that's nice
and it's just nate that's just me
you know i never seriously considered f6
but then i saw this sound like wow this
is funny it'd not be funny if it
happened to me
i'd be quitting chess but
but that's really nice
and
yeah and instead of f6 i also considered
moves like g6 and g5
but you know yeah g5 is interesting i
thought xgf ef7 king g7
bishop e3
yeah i thought bishop yeah bishop f6
and the game gets pretty wild it's
pretty well i wasn't sure about going
into this and might probably have other
options so
i decided okay let's keep it simple with
bishop six should be fine for me
all right let's keep going bishop to f6
very rich game very very rich full of
content and you guys entered this end
game bishop to a4 immediately blissed
out nightway 43
you have this uh under control but also
you spotted this from afar uh this whole
line i think i saw i forget when i saw
knight a4 but it's a pretty nice move
you just take two there's a knight and i
hear
that i wasn't sure how much i had
because i thought it was good but then i
saw g5 was uh the computer's move just
cut the rook away then defend the pawn
with king g7 and then basically the pawn
on eight oh
oh wow
oh wow yeah and black and king g7
oh wow that is
yeah how do i see that
it's easy to look with an engine because
he's visual indeed okay but
you how did you assess this one okay i
was shocked when he played that f4 i
just you were expecting him to take on
g5 yeah i thought okay this is like
black's obviously for choice but i think
white should hold like he has the
resources to stop the pawns just okay
rick a2
let's say actually f4 was a very
interesting move right now oh he can
even yeah he can even play just to give
you the pawn now the point being that if
you take on g2 i go r5
now whenever you go on the e file i go
back to g5 and then you have to come
back to the ef file oh wow i didn't see
it in this version i thought he goes
rook f5 instead of f4 which is pretty
sensible in my opinion yeah this this is
nice this is nice yeah
yeah
he did not even spend too much time on
this he he played that for quite quickly
i was i don't understand why you don't
want to go into that
game
okay bishop six and now i
i messed up here
i always i
okay i thought i i'm blundered kind of
so i played b4
here before g yeah jesus question mark
yeah my plan was to go king e8 but then
i saw that white has this diabolical
move with d6 diabolical he threatens
he's running bishop g5 and he responds
to me that's a checkmate yeah and i i
didn't know what to do here bishop f6
rookie six
oh and now if you go on the d file it
takes on f6 if you go on the you are
actually losing now yeah i i so i saw
this i was like wow this is amazing like
i don't know i don't know what to do
after rick d6
maybe i'm missing okay maybe
i don't know what to do so maybe
you have to about that b4 is probably a
mistake but okay it's very shaky but we
get into this okay so i thought okay i
probably just have to allow this and i
had no okay this is very hard to assess
honestly it's just raw calculation it's
winning it's winning okay okay i want to
i want to check some things yes because
so bishop c bishop c3 okay this is
forced 446. okay now i thought for a
very long time much as i should okay a5
i hope that doesn't blow it okay bishop
fade is bad no don't go bishop
i thought bishop d4 okay it was critical
okay let's say bishop d4
king e6
yeah or e7 doesn't matter g7
g7 king f7
now king e3
this gets this gets interesting so
so the most primitive line is if i just
push the pawn a4
king d3
a3
a3 yeah so now if king c4 then rook b2
wins that was that's what i thought
but i didn't see a win after king to c3
instead of uh king c4
and what's the difference because if
bishop rook b2 then bishop c5 right
nice and if rookie one then king d3
i didn't i thought i'm just losing the
pawn here and if you
if you take on g2 then just b3 and king
a2 he's he's going to win the pawn back
yeah or he can maybe even hold it if he
doesn't want to play rook and rick
versus bishop
so this is yeah this is
now this this so this is crazy stuff so
instead i decided that
i decided that i'm going to play that i
would play uh
rook c2 instead of uh
oh actually oh are you talking with fail
basis table based yeah yeah yeah we're
looking at table based okay was this the
position that uh no i i wasn't i didn't
think i had could afford to take on g2
but okay you can you can oh i can't
afford to take on yes
okay so a4 let's okay i was recommending
this one a3 a3
but somehow in our analysis this pawn
was already gone right so yeah king c3
king c3 this is already drawn this is a
dress yes so you actually start with
rook takes g2 okay no i thought actually
i didn't see rig g2 i thought i'm gonna
i thought i'm gonna play rook c2 instead
of uh
a4
i don't i don't own a check rex rook c2
here king d3 king d3 oh it's it's
winning okay he's still winning he's
still winning okay now rook
thanksgiving no no i thought
yeah rick c6
somewhere c8 doesn't really matter
um bishop c3
so he seems to run
a4
king c2
now if a3 can be three he's in time no
he's not he's not apparently not
what am i missing a2 a2
bishop a1
it's your bishop
some bishop somewhere okay a6 you don't
have the b2 square
so you're just going to run away okay so
i could have so yeah this is probably
what happens in calculus so deeply i'm
going to accidentally find
find a win somewhere okay okay and is a
three the only winning move because i
was wondering uh is this somewhat
similar to the game if i can play rugby
six here
cut the kingdom
okay it's a draw
so i probably would have okay probably
by here i probably would have found this
this idea that a3 actually wins
david congratulations back-to-back
victories against uh terrific
competitions congratulations you're
definitely playing the spoilers role in
this one we'll see you tomorrow yeah
thank you
well done indeed bravo uh beating the
tournament leader who had scored six and
a half
uh pardon me uh five and a half out of
six he could have had something happen
if he won but
very very impressive uh the game that
still is flaring it's a crazy position
igor uh
igor's game with uh alexander shabalov i
mean
he has to be winning
but somehow he still hasn't clinched it
yet
uh that's definitely a game to keep an
eye on but again i want to bring up the
game of
uh
igor and larry because should larry yes
novikov should larry win this game
then he will be our clear tournament
leader and this is where i was thinking
that
okay igor went for the
fortress that you were suggesting
christian but i do see bishop f6
pardon me bishop c6 f6 and g5 on black's
agenda and maybe he can break the
fortress what does the engine
reckon about uh this position yeah this
position actually it seems like it's
getting closer and closer uh to an
objectively winning position for black
right yes another winning position for
black seems to be jennifer u's game wow
let's jump to that one because that's
the big all important oh yes by the way
we just saw the move bishop
it was rookie three i was wondering and
the rook did capture this pawn on c3
uh jennifer said uh i'll take that
and bishop to d4 we've caught up with
the players now when we left it i think
we just really left it after h3 yeah and
rook e3 so not too many moves have been
played here uh dorsen the players are
getting close to time trouble this was
it no more no more time control for the
players but i mean black i don't know if
time is going to be that's huge of a
factor in this game black is just just
attacking and eating pawns and doing
everything that's what makes you happy
yeah exactly
uh also by the way centralized oh my god
that bishop is monster yes yes no it's
okay uh also uh bishop d4 does set up a
kind of uh
um discovered yes was it going to say
smother
a discovered attack against the rook on
a1 things definitely going jennifer's
way here christian but how
big uh uh
an advantage
does she have
winning advantage guys winning
winning advantage right now now the
question is can he take on f6 and go
into this end game probably not this is
looking like a very sad ending you have
one weakness two weaknesses on f5 your
pieces are uh not very active not
playing an active role right now it's
not looking good right and if you try to
defend the pawn on g3 with your rook the
pawn on a4 is going to be falling bishop
is not ready to get back to the defense
of that pawn during trouble right now so
you cannot go into that end game that's
the decision that she's trying to make
right now so should go for that win f4
or queen to f4
but now i can just simply go rook to c2
that does hurt how do we continue right
now because queen to d5 is a big threat
for example if you go rook to d1 try to
set up this pin queen to d5 or queen to
a8 and the game is over nice so you
cannot do that that's a big problem you
have to stay on uh you have to stay
close
to uh this diagonal right and also have
this bishop g2 come at me maybe there
should be six check oh sorry bishop
takes knight queen right this is
something
this was i i i don't think you can keep
the queens on the board yeah f4 now i
actually go bishop e5 and it's even
worse it's worse yes right your bishop
is not doing anything you're actually
getting checkmated on this side um
it's not looking good guys for uh our
tournament leader sophie morris suzuki
might not be able to pull the fabiano
it's very rare it's very rare to pull up
fabiana other section i was going to go
to the chris yep game for just a moment
and male junior as well
yes
uh charissa is up a piece but
uh it's going to be a perpetual
and they're going fast back and forth
back and forth
yes but queen h6 right queen takes h5
queen h6 um so she's
she's upon down yeah but
the first thing i want to think about is
just can i eat that c7 can i set up camp
for that pawn exactly go after
some move like queen e5 and or
c5 yeah make sense so queen to c5
go after these guys if she wins the
sipon i have no doubts that this game
will be headed towards a draw
and she's reaching for a queen i mean
she's not going to trade i think queen
c5 just wins them where do they get
these bad habits don't do that
no seriously
it's really bad another very very very
bad habit it's not allowed i think it
should just be in the rules as illegal
you cannot come behind me
and stand behind me
you are welcome on your side of the
table that's it i don't like you eating
but if you're going to eat you're going
to have a coffee do it on your side at
the table but when they come and stand
behind you that's distracting i have to
say if it's not in my visual field it
doesn't bother me as much as if
instead of sitting there standing and
they like shake their legs
bobby fisher shook his legs bad uh bad
form by bobby
what bugs you
christian when your phones do something
that you just say
you know i think eating is a big one
eating at the board
not eating snacks but i've seen players
that just bring their whole
meal and they start eating something
that's very smelly
i really don't like that no
loud chewers or gum yes those are also
yeah those are those are terrible sammy
rushevsky did that
purposefully and again uh don't hover
with that and don't hold the pieces make
your move be sure just
be
before you put your hand and actually
a teacher of mine jeffrey parsons he was
a he was an a player but he loved
endgame studies
he said yes sir you're doing it all
wrong i want you to sit on your hands
from there
until you're ready to play
you've got to sit on your hands and it's
very uncomfortable sitting on your hands
so i learned not to do that you know not
to
[Laughter]
oh boy we're going to take a break i
agree and we're going to be back with
more coverage of these three national
championships see you on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and we are back with our
live coverage of the 2022
u.s juniors u.s girls
and u.s senior championships we're
witnessing
the end of the game
between uh balaji and
i want to say christmas
i just wanted to make sure underneath
that hat
underneath the hurricane's right there i
think it's the first time we see that i
couldn't see a thing
nice two kings on the board very good
and a draw uh in a hard-fought draw and
it seems to this game typifies um our
broadcasts from the very start they last
till the very very very hard fought
games in all three sections in all three
sections and it's the only draw of this
round
so far and i don't anticipate drawing
there and let's go to jennifer's
actually that is quite ridiculous it is
the only draw in all three sections yep
that is incredible
we might have seen 15 decisive games
today
well
14 will be the best
but it sure looks like uh
sophie is now down two pawns queens are
off the boards so jennifer when we left
it
well they're playing quickly she's
putting the finishing touches on her
opponent right now okay this one is
looking busted for uh two extra
positions sophie mauricio center exactly
uh a much much much needed victory for
jennifer to be sure um
the only thing you shouldn't do is take
on g4
don't take on g4
not with the bishop on d4 hanging now
that was a respond d4 you can go bishop
e5 and then take on g4 right
and that seems to be more or less okay
yeah this one
is looking really good and what a
victory i mean
let's think about the beginning of the
game guys jennifer played that move
bishop to d7 i'm going to ask her about
that move because yes please
that was definitely an accident it
wasn't theoretical knowledge it wasn't
her preparation it was definitely an
accident and she came back from that
impress yourself
truly and
after the smoke king g2 she's just like
you say don't take on g4 play the move
bishop d4 to e5 attack the rook that's
the simplest move in the world the rook
is attacking the bishop the bishop
returns the favor by attacking the rook
bishop back to e5 later if you want you
can take the bishop on g4 i don't think
you need to
and perhaps even um
easier would be to go rook to g1 now
rook to g1 to take on g4 with
well it depends on where you put the key
if you go with the king to f3 then you
can trade the rooks exactly i love that
one that's an easy way and if you go to
i think you have to go to h3 otherwise
they take on g4 with the knight yes so
can i just go over catch one check now
exactly rook g1 that's the winner that's
the money move well that seems to be
like an easy win because now king g3
bishop e5 exactly
much better
that's nice looking good g1 might force
resignation and she's going for it yes
she did wonderful
beautifully done
yep
wow what a result this was guys
with the black pieces
i mean this is just impressive stuff for
the rating from the rating favorite and
let's not forget this tournament
seemed over going into today's round i
have to say
right maurice suzuki two points
ahead
of her nearest competitors with only
three rounds to go
both of whom had lost the previous round
as well
so it looked like she was
cruising to the finish line
and oops
well that's asleep and you're only one
point ahead and there's three hungry
ladies behind you exactly i
called earlier uh at the very very start
of the broadcast i thought something
strange had happened yesterday where it
was like victories everywhere it was
victory's galore you go to the sinkfield
cup and you
you know if you have 80 draws 20
victories
that's a good thing
it's not unusual and suddenly we were
just seeing uh victories galore
everywhere and what you just said was
that we've had one draw that was the
carissa game that went to naked kings oh
boy i've had a few experiences with you
know upwards experience going on talking
to king and i'm like
many many times for me as well um many
many many games with uh
just oh two kings five takes three four
by the way she's also
under one minute right now knight x g4
is just game over
right
the best you can get is after knight g4
king h3 bishop e5
rook takes g4 and sure will trade the
rooks i have exactly two extra pawns on
the other side then that is for sure and
she's reaching for the king h3
same colored bishops did this get this
is over
so we're expecting bishop e5 now i think
b5 is just the simplest right
there's a lot of ways to win the
position oh boy
do we have any
i mean these are just the vultures right
now right i was gonna say another nice
one i think it's also just bishop f6 and
she played it i it's very nice just to
try to trade everything i think we're
going to see a resignation right now
oh
[Music]
she knows this is over she's composing
her speech you don't want to see that
look
you're her opponent
and this is what nigel short actually
does whenever the game is close to being
done he gets his bottle of water
takes a sip
and just uh pretty much signals to the
opponent that this is over this is done
and
gary tell us one of uh those stories
yes no gary had a habit uh what he liked
to do is in in the days where you
actually wrote down your move in advance
today you can't write write down
your your next move which i always
thought was kind of surprising and there
is the handshake
he would take off his watches to start
the game and he put his watch over his
scoresheet as he wrote down his move he
put his watch over it
and
then when he thought the game was over
he put his watch on as like okay let's
go
it's all done and after the move bishop
f6 we just saw the handshake and
that opens up uh
a lot of possibilities
sophie is still one point absolutely
three people with five points
chasing after her wow
so
five
yeah jennifer talia and uh rochelle
exactly rochelle
thanks to her kings these are getting
heated
right okay so we're off with the legends
and not only in that section guys but
also in the legends section exactly
dorsa very nicely pointed out and let's
take a look at what larry's saying maybe
larry picked up the pawn on g2 that's a
big success
and he did play exactly that whole
sequence with bishop c6 f6 and
igor saying i can't hold
th i can't just sit here and wait with
my king because this king is going to
walk its way over to the b-pawn
closer
and so he so he genesis
he jettisoned the g2 pawn
and we have this position
and it looks like another one of those
where you know the the knight was
sitting on c3 a moment ago holding out
the key
uh from a d5 i wanted to say yeah
but now the knight's on f2
but
ah this is it this is the wrong color so
you can't just play h4 and h3
and win the knight because you've got
the wrong color bishop but king to e5
just put white in seuss one
king to d2 king to d4 and i'm making
progress i'm getting to the b4 pawn
that is my target
no question
if you can play king d4
uh you well pardon me king takes before
you wrap up the game
no problem
he's done it he's going for it guys
what a victory this would be for larry
yeah that would that would give him
clear first by half a point yes
king e1 on the board
half a point uh compared to a copion
as well as
i don't think there is any as well
because there's nowhere as well because
both lost right
so and shibalov who was half a point
behind them is not winning
what shabbat was half a point behind him
but he's not winning he's not willing
he's losing
i heard now winning and i was like what
now
how did chapala turn that around no no
okay all of a sudden
d2
don't we just
trundle over
towards the b-pawn now
at some point you will have to go h4
right
well
why
why not
because four take on b4 and then just go
for the knight
leave the king to attend the pawn the a
pawn and just go for the knight
yeah don't play h3 and allow the knight
to get sacrificed right
but just keep the pawn on h4 the bishop
is nice to place on g2 i mean
this is just uh seems like it's a very
technical easily technical win exactly
and again as you were saying uh would be
huge for larry as he would take a half a
point lead and clear second
would be vladimir okobi
a lot of developments uh would you like
to take a look at chabot's game or sure
not at all i think that game is actually
pretty done
and
whoa
uh we got a visual
in the game between shabala and igor
after the move rook takes f2 bishop
takes f2
this pawn on e5 this pawn on f6 i want
to say
looks like it's
invulnerable
i mean it's defended by the knight on g4
it's defended by the pawn on e5 and igor
said wait a minute
i can take that
and he did and it was like what how did
he lose the pawn
queen takes f6 obviously the pawn is
pinned true as well as the knight all
right so queen takes a deal
so they traded pawns
why
and
christian has jennifer with him let's go
for it thank you guys we are indeed with
the lady of the hour jennifer
congratulations yesterday a difficult
loss but this is what champions do they
bounce back even stronger how does that
feel
um i mean i guess it feels good but
i don't know i don't think i played that
great today to be honest and yesterday
was just so bad so i'm just
my results here i don't think are that
great but yeah how did you try
psychologically to get back in the
competition after yesterday's loss
because that must have felt like a
dagger
um i always get over losses pretty
quickly because i mean i feel like
there's no use and just
kind of thinking you know what if i did
this or if i did this because you can't
change anymore so
um like going into this game i honestly
didn't really think about it that much i
just kind of played it like normal
um
especially since
since i mean i'm like yeah i felt like
my chances were pretty bad after
yesterday so i was just like i'll just
take this normally so let's talk about
this game because you played this move
bishop to d7
was that your preparation you played it
super quick
yeah um well i'm pretty sure this is
what i'm supposed to do uh so
i
had no idea really what she was going to
play
um oh it was 97 then bishop d7 yeah
that's right that is definitely right
i did something i was like this is not
right at all but i haven't looked at
this in a long time um i usually don't
play this this is just something i
prepare like once like for a year ago
that never actually happened and i like
looked at it before but
yeah um i wasn't sure what she was going
to do in the opening so i honestly
didn't really prepare too much because i
mean she like plays everything and she's
been doing really pretty well in the
opening so i was just gonna play
something normal except for this one i
just wanted to change it up a little but
yeah
well
it's good that you did not know the
assessment of the position because this
is already like plus two right bishop d7
uh but you came back into the into the
game you were she allowed you to go c5
were you feeling like you were getting a
breath of fresh air at that point
yeah so
like i said something just didn't feel
right i was like i don't know what i was
doing but i mean after 97 like this is
normal to go for c5 um so yeah that was
just kind of how i was going for
let's keep going uh yeah 97 was and then
once you exchange the knights you go
back we should be seven it's a
completely different story but
still she allowed you to go c5 and now
it felt like you're getting slowly
slowly back into the game is that how
you felt as well yeah um i don't think i
played this part that well like i let
f4 this is just kind of bad but i just
wanted to prevent knight a7
um
so i put the queen back to b8 just
because knight a7 was kind of annoying
at some point but yeah this was i wasn't
so sure about
um and then this moment came all right
yeah i
i'm not going to talk about the merits
of this move but just explain to us the
logic and at least
as well as the train of thought that led
to this move g5 okay i do not know what
the evaluation is but i just
i did not like my position was already
it felt like this was like a turning
point here and it was like if i didn't
do something she's gonna get i mean she
can play g4 and she can push and i'm not
sure what i'm supposed to do here so i
feel like practically g5 is a good idea
because i
didn't see exactly how she was going to
infiltrate like obviously it's a big
weakness but i was this was just more
like a bluff
well it made her think and it definitely
gave you an even greater time advantage
and by the way it wasn't like a bad move
after bishop d4 bishop to e7 tried to
get the knight to c5 uh it seemed like
objectively you were better but after g5
the position is still very complex so
nothing big changes
it just looked like a funny part yeah
yeah i know
yes and then you went g5 now
what was the next critical moment when
did you feel like she went astray
i think uh honestly like surprisingly
this capture e takes the e5
um after i got like this tray like i i
don't think i'm like completely better
here but i feel very comfortable in this
position which at first it didn't it
doesn't look like it but it's just
because her bishop on h4 is pretty
misplaced and you can't take advantage
of like how weak my king is right now
and then so even though like the bishops
look like good like if you look at it
from far it's just
i don't see exactly how she should
continue because right now like if she
has a few moves and maybe she'll be fine
but i'm just kind of taking the
open
uh
yeah
and i think it was actually the 40th
move where she made this huge decision
to play h3 how would you feel about this
move
yeah so i also i did not expect h3 also
because it was move forward and usually
it's like not good to make big decisions
like when you don't have time but after
this it just seems like now i'm
definitely better because um
like because yeah the weakness on the
weekend squares and um the bishop is a
bit misplaced on h3 and i have some
chances absolutely and it did feel like
you're taking over at this point picking
up pawns and
it just seemed like she doesn't have any
way to break through and get to your
king
and after that quite a smooth
victory i have to say the exchange of
the queens another pawn and then that
was all she wrote congratulations uh
jenny for a big victory for you are you
starting to dream once again about the
title or is it too early still
i mean i feel like you always have to
otherwise what are you playing for like
playing for second place that's just not
fun um
but yeah i'm just
kind of just not thinking too much about
it because i mean i'm not that happy
with the way i'm playing
so i'm just i want to focus on that for
now congratulations once again guys any
questions no just our congratulations as
well jennifer good luck
in your remaining two rounds
wow we have it two more games left
yes
only two games left
again
uh
three victories
in the
uh seniors out of the five games played
with two games remaining and we're
expecting
uh
that larry will win
and we think that igor is also going to
win so
this could be
uh around where like you said we have 14
decisive games out of 15. it just yes
something weird is going on guys this is
amazing for
for me i i played in junior
championships i played in
i haven't played in senior championships
i played in tournaments that this draw
uh
i mean i think this is just beating
records
not just
by a small margin but by
a below-out margin i would love to see
you playing the seniors well thank you
very much
you get in there with those guys you'll
see um
for yourselves
uh i mean okay uh in junior play yes
scholastics play you see all kinds of
victories but when you get to the
national championship levels you're not
supposed to see so many decisive games
guys this is remarkable
and we
yeah there's a
speaking of scholarships and scholastics
there's a lot of scholarships
okay so what we have here and this is
really quite remarkable is we have
something called the samford
stanford scholarship stanford
fellowships if you will
and the remarkable part is that so many
players
from the seniors uh there's joe benjamin
and max and belugi who were sanford
fellas
from the juniors
look at who
uh
one two three
four five six of the juniors out of the
eight at one stanford and i think
they're like 25 000 a year
these are very very serious each wow to
give these players a chance to
and of course in the girls there's
jennifer you and alice lee we should
have asked jennifer what are you oh yes
i'll scrap her back literally over two
million dollars over the years have been
awarded to
america's most promising juniors girls
women
and for that matter uh men so i say joe
benjamin was the first ever sanford
fellow 1987. yeah i'm
can you tell me more about the stanford
yeah
oh boy no no i mean where's john
donaldson when i need him because he's
the walking encyclopedia he has all of
this encyclopedia knowledge i think it
was frank sanford he
wanted to leave a legacy to the world of
chess and
he thought
that what he really wanted to do
was help players
devote themselves it's so hard in the
world of chess especially if you go back
to the 70s 60s 50s you couldn't no
sammy rashevsky our really really great
player he was a cpa certified public
accountant he couldn't make a living
from chess bobby fischer struggled
right up until the 1972 world
championship match to really make a
decent living from chess and most of the
people who did make livings from chess
were actually
journalists writers authors nice like
robert byrne he didn't make a lot of
money from chess he made his living from
his new york times column so sanford
said look
i'm going to give you guys a scholarship
that you and i believe it's for two
years so it's like
a fifty thousand dollars wonderful so if
you wanna take time away from school if
you want to take
a break if you will so it's more of like
a sponsorship style a little bit
something that that makes sense yeah
think of it as a sponsorship and that
will work very very well larry just
played the move a5
personally i would have taken the part
on g4 right away
i
you know
but i think larry must be calculating
the move a4
and knight takes h3 and a3
and he's thinking uh
no but bishop takes g4 is the lazy man's
approach
just uh make sure that that
does not and you you play king to b3 i'm
a loving bishop
bishop f5 b3 and then bishop f5 bishop
f5 or bishop oh he's going for the
knight
he wants to push the h pawn
he's not even worried about
the a pawn he wants to go with the
uh-huh just uh
not all of the night
night night to see yeah and that's
enough resignation and that's enough
wonderful
well done larry as larry uh
came in today's round as one of three
players in the lead
he finishes the round as the only leader
in the tournament so well done for two
for larry
and let's take a look at what's
happening in uh
shabala's game guys because i mean is
this as easy anymore
i'm not sure what's going on and just to
finish the thought the stanford
continues to this very day
giving
scholarships to the very very best
of the best and there's the committees
to to discuss and uh
really it's a who's who i remember
patrick wolf
we've already mentioned joel benjamin
but really really if you look at the
fellowships um
boy there's been
the best
it's great and that really helped
change the fortunes for many many many
players why is this a problem the night
isn't the night coming to d oh
i mean there's always the queen
oh
there's always
this perpetual on tap and i don't see
you having any time to do knight to d2
oh oh oh oh excuse me it goes back to g2
i mean i have this would be a remarkable
save we might just say ng6 followed by
queen to f5 and just some sort of a
perpetual right now
whoa but what's upon up why would he
escape so quickly and and do what with
that point i have no idea
because i am giving you some very
serious checks that are going to lead to
a perpetual very soon next move if you
allow me once you don't give a check i
will find the check either a8 or k8 or
if i if i go back and i go queen g6
check king h8 king h3 and then knight d2
maybe
the other way check
let's give you a check on
a8 or a6 i'm not sure where do i want it
let's let's go to a8 sure
okay
now the problem i guess is that a4 i
can't avoid the checks
you can go on the dark source but then
the bishop is coming i'm a little bit
afraid of this guy
then the bishop is coming yeah okay well
let's just
let's just see it take take the plunge
all right let's go
it's like sometimes you know
do you remember the ice bucket challenge
oh yes that was so bad
i did not like this no i took the plunge
i i had two guys uh
ben feingold and aviv friedman they both
had these two ice buckets
my god was that a wake up
[Laughter]
it's actually really dangerous like
doing i didn't know it's dangerous
because um
it could res i mean if you're you know
your temperature's hot and then you get
right
you could have a heart attack yeah
exactly i think i think that's actually
how paul morphy died
is he took a
a a
a cold bath
uh during a very very hot day and this
extreme uh
change of body temperature
uh caused a heart attack really yeah oh
so those plunges yes
you're not joking you really are not
joking uh it can be dangerous i was
actually going to buy one of those like
i saw
ice plungers just to do ice baths so
you're saying that they're actually
dangerous well it could be
look into it uh we're we're
i'm not a biologist
yeah but uh by the way igor said no draw
for you
uh i respect the perpetual check ideas
i'll go knight b3 not to d2 i'll go
knight b3 to a5
and i'll try to bring this minor piece
over to help protect my king instead of
dorset jump in what where is that queen
going he went queen b5 yeah but why
can't i just get bishop h4 stop punching
the chicks bishop h4
i think the whole idea that
black is trying to do is set up knight
to c6
king to d7 exactly how he's supposed to
do that i don't know he actually went a
different route he played knight to b7
so your bishop h4
okay i don't know queen b5 knight to b7
okay so what if i go queen a6 queen a6
just to be i guess you want to hide with
the king on b8 is that it i think so
anything that just allows me to shelter
my king from a perpet
by the way they're going to be playing
on increments soon yes well what am i
saying there are on income
what is the time white house two minutes
17 black has three minutes uh well now
43 i guess
48 thank you wow
and again we're seeing something for me
i i just never have witnessed in in
these national championships
13 victories out of the 14 games played
13 up to this point 13 victories and
this could be the the 14th if
malinitsky manages to win this one but
it's not clear right how do you make it
where did black go wrong because i don't
know i mean i thought he had enough
advantage to just a king walk all over
the board there were a lot of
a lot of moments all right
a lot of moments uh just slowly
died down his attack his attack as well
as his advantage that was something that
gregory said is that he didn't win the
game all at once
gregory kaidanoff rather he just won it
because of slips and slips and slips and
i think that is really what happened to
igor in this game it's not like
what would he lost his advantage in one
terrible move just a lot of lesser moves
accounted for it
sorry you were no no no i'm just trying
to come up with what what what am i
doing
i think you're playing king to c8 and i
think you're playing knight to d8 again
you're you're going to put the knight on
c6 yes sir this is where they came from
came to see it i go queen to a6 yeah i'm
pinning the knight and then when i go
king b8 i go queen bee fighter i always
spin the knight
then the only other thing is
i mean can i put my bishop on
f4 and then by king to c7 to unpin my
knight
i mean i've got to unpin my pieces and
bring them to
the better squares wait a minute what
did he do came to keep f1 what does this
allow queen to see one
quincy should be one and then queen e3
well
he's reaching for his queen you have to
right i mean you see one bishop e1 also
you have to contend with
bishop to g3 is that such an easy
performance check check check check
check
is that such an easy purpose are you
sure it's perpet
i'm feeling tricky
okay so imagine i should actually
but i'm not sure i see the perpetual you
tell me can you say seven i go
you go check right i go if you go bishop
e1 bishop g3 and you go check and i go
king c7
how do you feel checky
how do you feel
he's done it oh
he doesn't want to give a perpetual he
wants to go queen e8 and take on e6 i
think
oh well you're right he did play bishop
e1 with that intent i see it now
you're right and he did igor did not
allow queen takes e6 he went instead of
bishop g3
queen
to e3 that makes a lot of sense now can
we go tricky ticky give me a bishop
oh now can you go check
and
here's an interesting one a social media
comment i'm very curious why the team
thinks shabba missed his opportunity to
save the game well
has he has he
i don't think he has i don't know if we
said that did we say that i don't think
we did
maybe like 20 minutes ago maybe
why did he miss his opportunity he did
not miss his opportunity to say
it's it's a draw right now well actually
it's just turned this game just turned a
couple of moves ago before it was
malnitsky that had
pretty much uh the full point in the
back exactly
so i i don't think i think this is when
shabba had
in the last five moves five to ten moves
his best opportunity to save this one
and he's doing a great job i must say
and bishop
king e2
kind of an indication that
[Music]
i don't know
shabbat might be thinking
shabba is no shabba is not playing for a
win don't say it no no don't say it
don't know shabbat he's one of the most
opportunistically minded players i've
ever played against i mean he has this
incredible
sixth sense for um key moments critical
moments and when things might turn
and the move king e2 he could have
played king to g1 he could have played
bishop to f2
but king e2 is kind of like one of those
moves that says
prove your perpetual check queen i don't
have to prove anything i'm a porno i
know
i really don't have to prove anything as
black
i'm a pawn up there's absolutely zero
chance that you're gonna win this one
okay well then you explain kingi too
i tried but you shot me down that's
almost like my attempt to explain g5 by
uh
which i thought was a brilliant attempt
yeah so bishop f3 all right queen c2
problems i'm assuming or queen d3
well exactly queen d3 is almost a scary
move i think they're just breaking
trying to break the record for the
longest game of the tournament
are they uh that's my ex i don't think
they're close though right
i think there was seven i think there
were other players that were
are we thinking number of moves yes
blender
number of moves all right so i'm
not
so we've already had a 120 move game oh
good
which one
mishra that was yesterday but we cut
the show short
well
we covered a lot of it
we i think they just made
a quick repetition
from the time we had we had to evacuate
to let the construction continue bishop
f3
um i'm
you know it's it's weird queen d3 if the
bishop was on f4 queen d3 would be
winning
so
bishop f4 i also wanted to mention that
from what i see the last pawn move was
on move 58
58 it's the last capture right sorry my
best capture still uh move
okay
so they're just shuffling pieces
and we do have queen d3 check
king f2
again if the bishop was on i4 we'd have
the nice follow-up right he checked
and now queen c2 check oh
where's that queen going
king f1 you know that song called by
myself
i can't sing all by myself thank you yes
i certainly do queen feels yeah
yeah she's not getting any support from
the rest of the
the are you going to see a repetition
right now queen to c2 is that where the
players are going to go i mean
unless there's going to be a
friend for that queen well i see
shabalov is looking at his scoresheet so
he's definitely trying to it's been over
20 moves without the since the last take
but
by the way for me the very very best
pens
to use or not any of these pens that you
have a you click or click click
hands uh writing instruments nice was
cross uh the cross pens i always like
because they were the least they made
the least sound ah you know you you have
exactly you go
ah
you hear all of that and you do have
people who are nervously at the board
you're like stop that
i mean it's crazy bishop
am i seeing that right bishop to a5 i
mean the first thing i think is maybe
bishop g3 check right now for white
there is a bishop on a5
wow targeting that pawn on c3 but now
this opens up the possibility of
potentially going start giving trucks
right let's go for it i'd be a little
bit nervous bishop to g3 check
i'm sure you're gonna have to go king a7
yes and i'm guessing i'm going to go
down and
try to
but
whoa whoa what's the engine say
christian
about this attempt of bishop a5 is it
justified absolutely nothing has changed
yes it's justified but not more than
equality if shaba finds the right moves
and probably the same concept applies as
uh to what he did against the knight and
that is to pin the bishop now the bishop
is the piece that is attacking so i
might as well go queen to e8 you go king
to a7 and now i pin the bishop with
queen to a4 the same concept just
eliminate uh and defend against the
action of the attacking and he's about
to go for it he's doing your favorite
thing
oh
the passive approach with queen to b2
what
wow i'm not sure about that but
the engine is still saying that it's
more or less within the margins of
equality queen to b2 just defending okay
he's also pinning
pinning the knight but now
okay i i've been thumping the table for
some time magically put the knight from
b7 to c6
and i really like
black's chances so queen to d3 now you
want to put the knight magically from
where from b7 to c6 so c6 king
maybe to a7 so i can go knight d8 knight
c6
well he already made one illegal move in
this game he might as well try his
second one right
right so king a7
uh do we have enough time to go bishop
d8 bishop h4 because if i can activate
that bishop from a5
right things might start to look
nice a little
bishop d8 i guess i can i have to go
king g2
well i gotta sidestep this a killer move
uh bishop h4 in that case
so yeah
to be honest i don't know why shabba is
putting his king on dark source
right it doesn't make a lot of sense to
me why not just say king f1 king g2 king
h3 whenever that's
whenever that's possible here we go but
he's going for your plan yes sir
so i mean i'm sure when he started
bringing his knight back from b3 he had
a vision a beautiful vision in his mind
did igor that his knight on c6 would
protect this king beautifully
and maybe reaching
towards the d4
square knight takes d4 ideas
and we have a very interested observer
iworn novikov looking at all the boards
i don't know if this i think this might
be at the club itself or it could be in
the tournament hall no this isn't a
tournament hole because in the in in the
club proper the lobby they have that
really nice screen
with all of the uh games as well and
whoa uh queen e2
i mean queen to e2
offering the trade but wait a minute uh
queen bishop what if i take on c3 queen
takes queen bishop takes a one check in
tanks to take the queen back on d3 king
d2 i don't know about that end game is
that end game that easy bishop takes c3
23 bishop takes c1 you take take we
exchange that
but then two versus one with an active
knight he's not happy about that igor
declined
i
i would have thought a little bit harder
about that ending maybe it's a draw but
bishop takes c3
queen takes d3 bishop takes e1
2 versus one now it must be a draw must
be a draw he played queen f5
let's go
igor wants to play
he certainly does and again i
i won't go so far as to call it a threat
i would call it a beneficial
reorganization
which
fulfills the requirements of the
position put the knight on c6 and then
figure out yes
well because i read it so often i it
almost became a standing
joke like a meme you know
fulfill the requirements of the position
at some point you might even consider
playing e5 right by the way queen a2
stops
that reorganization another king
it's always about the pin
just pin
the bishop pain the knight
one of black species with your queen
right
give the queen a job
queen b2 check on the ball let's go the
other way for the fun of it let's go
king c7
how about king c6 i'll take it
kind of doing the same thing but
maybe
i don't know keeping up the i was going
to say keeping the option of of bishop c
bishop d8 i liked your idea
dorsa
of bishop to d8
and bringing the bishop around to h4 and
christian said why is shebalaf putting
his king on a dark square where it's
vulnerable
and
it's it's a very good question why would
you do that because c6 is on the board
you'd want it on a light square where
your bishop could nicely protect it you
know
uh king c6 okay keeping open
the possibility of bishop d8 um
i'm
what's the end
the engine of al
nothing has changed
what is your
as a human player
thinking that
your your winning potential as black
might be
would you say i i would win this one out
of 10 games i would win it
i think it's three i think what i would
try i wouldn't say that i would say it
really depends on how would my opponent
play it and the way white is playing it
it's just kind of
impossible to win it
yeah i think the trend definitely favors
shabbat yeah and now if you asked me
that question 30 moves ago
okay well i mean i think time is going
to be a huge factor in this game it
hasn't been so far the players have been
playing pretty brisk but that's the
thing right yes sir how do you change
the character of the position
in any way any significant shape or form
that's easy uh
a move e6 e5 in such a position as we
have could come and you can't take on e5
because of bishop b6 check right right
so that's the
that's the kind of if you can time that
then yes but problem with
e5 always the d5 pawn is very weak
remains very yes i and in this
particular moment e5 would have been met
by bishop takes d5 oops no so
queen a4 i think queen a4 would have
been a problem
oh sorry uh queen a3 was played
what's wrong with a5 after queen a4
well let's play it
i'll put it on my board of course
e5 queen a4 check probably queen a4
i'm hoping to that you take so i will
play bishop b6 check
but how
how significant is that move
all right i'll i'll i'll bite i'll take
on e5 okay just a second so should i do
the check right away
oh boy
[Laughter]
oh boy now i can't do the lazy man's
chest um
variations are you trying to vote
yeah i wanted
i want to get the bishop on that
diagonal but
okay
let me catch up with the players but i'm
just saying
that if i'm black i'm looking for that
kind of
an opportunity as well as re
routing my knight to the c6 square i
really have a i have a feeling that if i
can do that i can succe succeed
in winning this game and by the way just
to catch up with the players
king d7
king g2 okay so shabbos putting his king
on on light square
good for him
he should have done this
long time ago ages ago ages ago okay all
right so the pawn on c3 is defending we
don't have to worry about that now what
black has to do is try to find another
configuration the problem is with queen
b3 is that i still have queen to c1
queen to c oh yeah and it doesn't
improve your position
also i think queen to a1 just to keep
contact with the bishop and a5 so that
you cannot involve your knight into the
attack how do you feel about bishop c7
here
that's an attempt yes
yes
bishop to c7 let's play it what if i try
to go from trying to f8
uh bishop c7 queen f8 can i finally at
last
play the move knight d8 and get to my
coveted
c6 square you you can definitely get
there yeah
that would be nice that would be an
improvement
all right so what if i just simply give
up some checks right now uh queen g7
queen to g7 let's say king bad queen g2
queen g2 i didn't see that one coming i
just want to make i i just want to
exchange the queens now queen g4 queen
g4
and let's go down no no don't go there
you shouldn't think it's d5
they should take stephen sorry check
check check first yes
um queen king
king f
a pause
a pause
and now i'm going to get my knight to c6
at last finally yeah no i mean that's
that's an improvement let's say an
improvement let me refresh my board i'm
sorry uh for that
he played queen d3 king g2 he's staying
on the lightsworks
he's uh listening to us right now
king g2
yeah okay you're right i'm really liking
queen e3 but can you make it work
queen e3
asking
white about his bishop queen e3 queen a1
looks looks like white is being
stretched
that is not breaking
not breaking
that's the thing there's only one
weakness right in white's c3 that is the
c3 square right now shabba is definitely
starting to eye uh that last move where
the structure has changed
and just to give you an idea when that
happened last okay
it was a thought it was 57.58 somewhere
56 yes 56. no never mind no captures
don't never mind the captures i think it
was 59 15 yes 59 is where the party
started so 30 moves in the party that's
it now we're at 89. okay that's 30 moves
still 20 moves to go but i mean we're
getting close
but a nice description for a 50 move uh
ruling the party started 30 moves ago
yes
that's when the shuffle dance right
the disco shuffle
all right so we
so again we are thinking
we are thinking that bishop c7
playing for that knight d8 idea
would be um now bishops is that one can
you start giving checks queen to a4 yes
uh king to c8 king to c8 and then
continue giving checks bishop to b8 here
he goes he's doing it he's reaching for
it
bishop to d8 that's okay
that's a different i i like this move
especially when the king was on f2
bishop to d8
so
just to keep our audience informed um
the move that we're looking for is
119.
if they get to that move without
exchanging any pieces actually never
mind 109.
see my calculation it's been
it's been many hours
you were close though really i mean
dorsa and i wanted to say well done
and here's where two of our tournament
stores have concluded for the day an
unfortunate day for tournament leaders
uh sophie moore suzuki lost her name to
jennifer yu
and sophie still has a point ahead of
three other people who are chasing her i
feel like with a bat
they're all
five points jennifer you italian
cervantes and russia who
exactly and him next two rounds
and in the juniors we also like you said
it's a tough day on the leadership as
christopher you also dropped his very
first game
a loss um and uh
against david brodsky a very resurgent
david protzky and andrew hong is only
half a point away from the leader
christopher yu
tight tight um
follower is mishra who i believe did
lose his game today
still in clear third
exactly
and don't worry folks we've got a lot
more chess coming your way this is going
to be the summer
of chess here in st louis as the grand
chess store
picks up in zagreb croatia july 20th
through 24th we already lost alejandra
we sent him over to croatia to get ready
for the grand chester and then of course
it all picks up here in st louis with
the rapid blitz in august as well as the
sinkfield cup beginning of september
then we have the bobby fischer chest
chest nine lx or chess 960 if you prefer
that will be september 13th and 16th oh
you guys do like do you have like two
weeks off then
yeah
then finally
uh the granddaddy of them all the us uh
open championship and women's
championships i wonder if carissa would
play in the open
could be song that would be fun and
there they are a remaining uh
protagonist at the board what do you
think of the position christian oh it's
nothing changed
nothing changed nothing has changed no
isn't black doing his best to reorganize
his minor pieces but put them
what are the ideal squares for the
knight and bishop if you were black
where would you
want them well i would love to get
closer to your king the white's king so
somewhere around d3 would be my guess
also f4 if i managed to get to f4 and
kind of connect
oh the never mind
what happened draw that was just a draw
agreed
wow
well we cannot expect that we did not
expect that at all right that came out
of nowhere um a little too many checks
uh harassing maybe it was that he could
i think you just cannot escape anymore
you cannot escape
perpetual checks at this moment yeah
bishop d8
didn't feel right neither did knight d6
but a very very hard-fought game i have
to say
igor will be
disappointed i agree that was such a for
us it's been a very very long day of
broadcast
and uh guys you hung in there really
really well
not me it just like faded badly here's
our commentator's pics
for the girls
wow the last couple of days i've been
doing well but i have to say my pick on
this one unfortunately not a good start
oops well it it was tough i i went with
the rating favor the pre-tel
rating favorite that
but alejandro alejandra was looking good
i got it before today's round exactly
exactly you know stumbled a little bit
today your mishra lost today
and then uh in the uh
seniors
that's a pretty significant ride
right she comes in she picks nepo
and he did win the tournament
you did good thank you thank you that's
very nice
and now we do with this draw we do have
the senior standings
and larry christensen is five points
soul leader
uh but a very tight follow from
vladimiropopian four and a half points
and then we got three people tied for
third
dimitri alex and maxim a lot to be
decided yes and our two penultimate
well our championship round games
penultimate tomorrow in championships on
saturday uh final thoughts christian on
a very very long broadcast well uh as
you greatly put it at the beginning of
the broadcast it feels like we have a
script writer an award-winning script
writer because right now i mean what
else we could have asked from today's
round jennifer you
winning against the leader and allowing
three players to get closely behind
sophie mori suzuki going into the
championship rounds the same can be said
for the junior section as well david
broski playing the spoilers role we
needed that because i mean these two
players were running away uh with the
tournament but right now the intrigue is
back on the menu and in the senior
senior sections uh i have to say i'm
happy to see my pick a copian
a great victory uh against larry against
maxim lugi that was an important one and
i have to say he is starting
to feel in shape and ready to put some
pressure on larry christiansen we're
going to have two amazing championship
rounds coming up next thank you
christian indeed
it's been a long day
great thank you everybody for joining us
and sharing your day with us we'll
certainly see you tomorrow and don't
miss championship saturday
as we will
crown three champions yes good night
everyone
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you